IS ALWAYS HERE SKINNER STERN Y.
CASCADE NEAR BY CASKEY HERE ALL
RIGHT SO WE'VE GOT TWELVE BILLS
ON THE CALENDAR- IN ORDER TO
GET THROUGH THE COUNTER WHERE
WE'RE GIVING- TEN MINUTES EACH.
ON BOTH SIDES WHICH INCLUDES
THREE MINUTES FOR LEAD WITNESS
TESTIMONYTHEY'RE MADE OF THE
TIME FOR ADDITIONAL CALLERS AND
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OBVIOUSLY
PEOPLE WANT TO SUBMIT THEIR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION TO BILLS
YOU'RE YOU'RE IF YOU'RE VERY
WELCOME WE HAVE LISTS OF THE
FOLKS IN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
HONOR. BILL ANALYSIS AS WELL.
TIME THE PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS
844-291-4185 ACCESS CODE IS.
SIX FOUR ZERO TWO FIVE ONE TWO.
AND- WE'VE ESTABLISHED A
QUORUM. LET'S FIRST- WE HEAR OF
MOTION FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. MOVE MOVE BY CENTER
DOLLY THANK YOU SENATOR.
SERCHHIP PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ISLANDS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ITEM NUMBER THREE AND ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE ALLEN'S HI I
BATES. DALLI DALLI AYE GONZALEZ
AND SALAS I SKINNER STERN FOR
CASKEY HI MY COUNTY I. IT'S A
REALLY THAT OPEN FOR THE
MEMBERS TO COME ON AND CENTER
SKINNER AS YOU MAY KNOW IT'S A-
AND BUDGET COMMITTEE. WELL I'M
AND CENTER STERN'S ON THIS IS
ON A PLANE AS I. GRIFT. THIS IS
THE RESPONSE. IT SAID OKAY SO
GET STARTED WITH YOU CENTER TO-
WORRY PRETTY PERCENT SB FIFTY
FORTY THREE ON FUEL CELLS.
HYDROGEN MANY FAVORITE TOPICS I
YOU- TRANSFER LAST WEEK YES
GOOD MORNING TO ALLEN AND
COMMIT MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SAID BILL SIX
FORTY THREE I KNOW YOU HAVE A
BUSY SCHEDULE WILL RIGHT
THROUGH IT SENATE BILL SIX
FORTY THREE. PASSED THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
IN CONSULTATION WITH THE ENERGY
COMMISSION THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION TO CREATE A WORKING
GROUP TASKED WITH PREPARING AND
ASSESSMENT OF THE HYDROGEN
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED TO MEET
OUR STATE AIR POLLUTION GOALS.
BEFORE GOING ANY FURTHER I
WOULD LIKE TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS ON PAGE
SIX OF THE ANALYSIS THAT WILL
REMOVE. TWO HYDROGEN INDUSTRY
MEMBERS ARE FROM THE WORKING
GROUP. THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD IS A LEAD
AGENCY AND CALIFORNIA WHEN IT
COMES TO HYDROGEN ANALYSIS
MOREOVER THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD IS WELL EQUIPPED WITH THE
TOOLS AND EXPERTISE NEEDED TO
CONVENE THIS WORKING GROUP AND
PREPARE THIS IMPORTANT
ASSESSMENT. HOWEVER THE MOST
IMPORTANT QUESTION S WHY IS
THIS ASSESSMENT NEEDED HYDROGEN
FUEL CELLS ARE AN IDEAL
ALTERNATIVE FUEL SOLUTION TO
ELECTRIFIED MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY COMMERCIAL VEHICLES. THESE
AND THESE VEHICLES ARE
NECESSARY COMPONENTS TO
ACHIEVING CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE
AND AIR QUALITY GOALS HOWEVER.
THERE EXIST A KNOWLEDGE GAP
RECOUP A REGARDING THE HYDROGEN
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS REQUIRED
FOR CALIFORNIA TO MEET ITS-
CARBON NEUTRALITY GOALS THE
STATE AGENCIES AND ENERGY
UTILITIES LACKS SPECIFIC
KNOWLEDGE OF THE AMOUNT OF
HYDROGEN FUELING INFRASTRUCTURE
AND HYDROGEN FUEL PRODUCTION
NEEDED. TO MEET CALIFORNIA'S
CLEAN ENERGY GOALS SAYS BILL
SENATE BILL SIX FORTY THREE
WILL HELP BRIDGE THAT KNOWLEDGE
GAP AND I'LL AND ALLOW
CALIFORNIA TO ADEQUATELY PLAN
AND IMPLEMENT HYDROGEN FUEL
CELLS AS AN ALTERNATIVE ENERGY
SOURCE. THIS BILL IS VITAL NO
DOUBT. I WOULD LIKE TO POINT
OUT MISTER CHAIR THAT IT WILL
BRIDGE THE GAP AS I'D MENTIONED
ONCE AGAIN AND MORE
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL PASSED
THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD INCOME IN CONSULTATION
WITH THE ENERGY COMMISSION THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION TO
CREATE A WORKING GROUP TASKED
WITH PREPARING AN ASSESSMENT OF
THE HYDROGEN INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDED TO MEET OUR STAGE.
LUCIEN GOALS THE WORKING GROUP
WILL FOCUS THEIR EFFORTS AROUND
ASSESSING PRODUCTION AND
DISTRIBUTION DISTRIBUTION
INFRASTRUCTURE DISPENSING AND
DISTRIBUTION EQUIPMENT STORAGE
EQUIPMENT SUPPORTING HARDWARE
AND SOFTWARE AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY SYNERGIES. ACROSS
HYDROGEN SECTOR FOR EXAMPLE THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN PRODUCTION
STORAGE AND DISTRIBUTION
FINALLY TO ENSURE TIMELY AND
ACT AND CURRENT DATA. THE
WORKING GROUP IS REQUIRED TO
COMPLETE THEIR ASSESSMENT BY
DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
WITH THE INFORMATION FROM THE
ASSESSMENT CALIFORNIA WILL BE
ABLE TO MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS
ABOUT OUR CLEAN ENERGY FUTURE
FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. END IT WITH ME ON THE
TELEPHONE THIS TODAY I HAVE JIM
SO SEEN BOARD PRESIDENT OF THE
WESTERN STATES HYDROGEN
ALLIANCE AND RUXANDRA BIGELOW
MAHDI- EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE WESTERN STATE CHARGES NOT
ALLIANCE. BOTH ARE HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AND HELP
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE MISSED RICHER
CAN I HAVE A CLARIFICATION
UNDERSTAND THAT THE AUTHOR HIS
IS GOING TO REMOVE THE TWO
HYDROGEN INDUSTRY FOLKS IS THE
PLAN RIGHT NOW ON THE BILL SO I
HAVE CLARIFICATION ARE WE GOING
TO EXPAND THE SCOPE OF THE AB.
EIGHT ANNUAL REPORT AND THE ADP
TWO ONE SEVEN FIVE TO INCLUDE
THE FUEL CELL ELECTRIC VEHICLE
FOLKS ARE WE STILL GOING WITH
AN INDEPENDENT- PANEL. WE'RE
GOOD WE'RE TRYING TO TAKE THIS
ACROSS THE STATE AND I KNOW
THAT THERE WE HAVE TWO BILLS ON
ON THE RECORD BUT THEY DON'T GO
AS FAR AS THIS BILL DOES TO
LOOK AT THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHERE IT'S NEEDED
WHY IT'S NEEDED. AND HOW THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS GOING TO BE
COMPLETED NO I UNDERSTAND THAT
THE BUT THE BUT DID STAFF
REPORTS INDICATED THAT WE CAN
TAKE THOSE EXISTING STUDIES AND
EXPAND THE ROLE OF THOSE WITH
THE WITH THE FOLKS THAT ARE
THERE. FOR SETTING UP A NEW- A
NEW TAB PANEL THAT'S I JUST
WANT TO KNOW WHAT WELL WHAT THE
AMENDMENTS YES UNDERSTANDING IS-
WE SO WE BECAUSE OF THIS CAR
THREE TIME ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
ISSUE ASSOCIATED THIS ITEM
FOLKS THE PANEL YOU KNOW I'M
TALKING A- RIGHT NOW WE DO HAVE
FUEL CELLS. TECHNOLOGY SO CPAS.
PASS OUT IN AB EIGHT JANUARY IN
AB TWO ONE SEVEN THIS IS ON
PAGE SIX BEFORE WE GET TO THE
HYDROGEN MEMBERS. AND SENATOR
ONE PERTAINS TO THE PLUGIN THE
OTHER WOULD CHANGE TO THE
INFRASTRUCTURE OF ABOUT A
HUNDRED TO TWO HUNDRED WHICH
THIS BILL GOES FURTHER THAT'S
WHY IT'S NEEDED BECAUSE IT
IT'LL OUT WILL HIT A WALL IF WE
DON'T OPEN IT UP FOR THE
ASSESSMENT. AND THAT'S WHAT
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
GRANTED THERE'S TWO THERE BUT
YOUR QUESTION IS CAN WE JUST
GET BACK ONTO IT MY ANSWER I
WOULD PREFER AND I THINK. THE
INDUSTRY WOULD PREFER IF WE
WERE ABLE TO KEEP THIS BILL A
SEPARATE ON ITS OWN. AND THAT'S
WHY IT'S SIX FORTY THREE IS
NEEDED TO LOOK AT THE ENTIRE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA NOW- WE
HAVE ONE SENATOR REPRESENTS
LONG BEACH- THE SENATE PIZZERIA
WE HAVE TRUCKS COMING IN WE
HAVE PORCH THERE THAT WE NEED
TO LOOK AT THEM. SO THIS THIS
STUDY IS VITAL TO GO ACROSS THE
STATE TO FIND OUT WHERE WE
STAND- TO MEET OUR GOALS AND
AGAIN- IT WILL HAVE IT ON THE
TABLE. BY TWENTY TWENTY THREE
AND THAT'S THAT THAT'S THE
THING HOW DO WE KNOW WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO GO UNLESS WE TAKE A
GOOD HARD LOOK AT IT. YEAH I
JUST WANNA SAY TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION FROM FROM THE
COMMITTEE PERSPECTIVE- YOU KNOW
WE DO AND I KNOW THE AUTHOR
KNOWS THIS WE DO CONTINUE TO
HAVE SOME ADMINISTRATIVE
EFFICIENCY ISSUES WITH. THE
BILL- YOU KNOW I MEAN I- HAVE
C. E. SO THE- OF THE FUEL CELL
ELECTRIC VEHICLE- THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT HERE. CURRENTLY MAKE
UP ABOUT IT PERCENT OF. HIS ABS
FIVE. SO YOU KNOW I KNOW I KNOW
THAT- THE BILL WAS ORIGINALLY A-
SO THE BILL FOR A R. B. THEN.
YOU KNOW RULES WANTED TO BE A
TASK FORCE FOR TO BE REFERRED
OUT WHICH IS YOU KNOW I DON'T
KNOW NOW WE KNOW IT'S OUR SO
THE COMMITTEE WOULD HONESTLY
PREFER TO DO ONE OF THOSE
SUGGESTIONS IT'S ON PAGE SIX
NOW I UNDERSTAND- YOU KNOW.
WE'RE WE'RE NOT THERE YET AND
THEN THE BILL'S GOING TO KEEP
MOVING- THE LADY GETS OUT TODAY
OBVIOUSLY- AND BUT THIS IN THIS
DISCUSSION WILL CONTINUE BUT TO
BE HONEST I THINK IT'S OUR
COMMITTEE'S PREFERENCE. THAT WE
EITHER EXPAND THE SCOPE OF THE
FINAL REPORT OR- UPDATE THE
SCOPE OF THE EIGHTY EIGHT
ANNUAL REPORT- TO REACH THE
SAME TYPES OF GOALS THAT THE
AUTHORS TRYING TO ACHIEVE. I
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT OKAY THAT'S A GOOD ONE
THANK YOUNG. AND I DON'T SEE.
YOU KNOW AYE SIR WOULD
APPRECIATE THAT INDEED YOU
CONTINUE WORK WITH THE AUTHOR
AND YOU KNOW WITH YOU. CENTER
MAKOWSKI- THE CITY THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD JUST TO MAKE SURE
WE GET THIS TO A PLACE. WHERE
REALLY ENDS UP HAVE YOU REACH
YOUR MUTUAL GOALS WHICH IS TO.
ENSURE THAT WERE. WE'RE WE'RE
WE'RE STUDYING- THIS THIS
IMPORTANT PART OF THIS HAVE
FUTURE. AND DOING SO IN A WAY
THAT IS EXTREMELY EFFICIENT.
TOP ANYWAY I IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT
UNFORTUNATELY MR SASINE IS NOT
ON THE LINE. AND IF THAT
CHANGES LET US KNOW BUT LET'S
GO TO THE LET'S GO TO THE I
DON'T SEE ONE TWENTY FORTY I
DON'T SEE ANYONE HERE TO SPEAK.
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINES
MODERATOR WHO WANTS TO VOICE
THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT YOU
MAY PRESS. ONE NINE ZERO. ONE
AND THEN ZERO FIORENTINA PORT.
AND THERE IS NO ONE IN CUBA.
OKAY I'M- AB ONE WE DON'T HAVE
ANY TIME OPPOSITION. THAT THAT
WE KNOW OF THAT HAVE SIGNED UP
TO SPEAK ON IS THERE ANY I
DON'T SEE ANYONE HERE OR IN
TWENTY FORTY AND- MODERATORS
ANYONE WHO'S CALLING IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. THANK
YOU IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS.
ONE ZERO. ONE MOMENT THERE'S A
FEW DOING UP. I'M I'M FIGHTING
THERE SOMEONE QUEUING UP HE
SAID. OKAY. YEAH ONE MOMENT WE
HAVE TOGETHER THEY'RE LIKE. AND
I DO HEAR AN ECHO FOR A LONG
WHILE. I'M SO SORRY TO OUR JUST
TO CLARIFY DO WE HAVE ANYONE OR
OR- THEY WERE WAITING FOR YOU
JUST TRYING TO SEARCH TO SEE IF
THERE IS SOMEBODY. WE HAVE
SOMEBODY ONE MOMENT WHAT THE
FEATHERING THEIR LINE NUMBER
GARCIA SO BOB GOT NOT
OPPOSITION THAT'S EXCITING
THREE GO. THERE YOU GO. THE NEW
ANYTHING RIGHT RIGHT VENUES
RETENTION. OKAY WE'LL GO TO
LINE OF TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI THIS IS TEMPTING
FROM THE WESTERN STATE HIDING
ALIVE I CAN TO CALL LYNN
INCLUDES. OF THIS BILL SO- IT
SHOULD STILL AN APPROPRIATE
TIME FOR ME TO SPEAK YES IF YOU
COULD IF YOU COULD MAKE YOUR
POINT TO SIMPLY WE WOULD
APPRECIATE IT BUT- WELCOME TO
THE HEARING. OKAY THANK YOU-
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU
ARTS CENTER ARCHULETA PRE WORK
ON BEHALF OF CLIMATE AND FOR
CALIFORNIANS AFFECTED BY
TRANSPORTATION POLLUTION- WE-
WHAT'S YOUR DATE HYDROGEN
ALLIANCE REPRESENT
MANUFACTURERS OF ZERO EMISSION
HYDROGEN FUEL CELL TECHNOLOGY.
CALIFORNIA'S NUMBER FOUR FRONT
THE U. S. INSTITUTING YOUR CARB
REGULATE ON. COULD MOVE THE
PACE OF THIS. THE CARD ALL OF
TRANSFER. MUST BE MET WITH
DILIGENCE AND PLANNING TO
PROVIDE SOLUTIONS THAT NOT ONLY
REMOVE CARBON BUT ALLOW FOR
ASSESSMENT OF ALL CHOICES. BUT
THE LOWEST COST APPROACH THAT
HAVE THE LEAST IMPACT ON OUR
BUSINESS OPERATIONS IN THERE BY
THE ECONOMY. SB SIX FORTY THREE
EMPOWERS CARDS EASY IN THE CQC
TO PROPERLY ASSESS HYDROGEN
ALTERNATIVES ALONGSIDE BRITAIN
BATTERY ALTERNATIVES TO
IDENTIFY WHERE SUCH
INFRASTRUCTURE CAN BE MORE COST
EFFECTIVELY INSTITUTED. THANK
GOODNESS BEEN MARGINALIZED OR
ABSENT FROM MUCH OF THE LONG
TERM PLANNING OF THE TRANSITION
OF OUR ENERGY SYSTEM TO A
CARBON FREE ONE. AT THE SAME
TIME HYDROGEN CONTINUES TO
ADVANCE IN TRUCKING RAIL OFF
ROAD AND MARINE SECTORS
PROVIDING OVERLAPPING NEEDS
THAT FURTHER IMPROVE HYDROGEN
BUCHANON X. IT'S CRITICAL THAT
THE TRANSITION CONSIDER ALL
OPTIONS AT SCALE. FOR A FULL
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM TO ENSURE
NOT ONLY CLIMATE EXPECTING
JUNIOR ECONOMIC PROSPERITY. THE
COUNTRIES AROUND THE WORLD THAT
HAVE ADVANCED MOST QUICKLY TO
DECARBONISE THE COMPLETED
HYDROGEN ROADMAPS AND PLANS AND
I HIGHLYENCOURAGE COMMITTEE TO
ENABLE ITS- AGENCIES TO DO THE
SAME I LIKE WILL WELCOME ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE ON THE SUBJECT. AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WORK AND ATTENTION
TO THIS MATTER. MISTER THAT YOU
ARE SO LET'S NOW BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO THE CAN. FOR
DISCUSSION- MEMBERS YOU HAVE
QUESTIONS FOR. BUT YOU KNOW
YOU'RE YOU'RE EARLIER I THINK
IS APROPOS CENTER AND YOU KNOW
THIS IS IT WITH THIS IS THAT
CERTAIN WORK AND. MISTER CHAIR
I MEAN. CLEARLY THE HYDROGEN.
IN THE OFF. WOULD LIKE TO. MORE
FUNDING GOING TO THE CREATION
OF HYDROGEN STATIONS WE KNOW
THAT. GIVEN THE EXECUTIVE
ORDERS THAT THE- ADMINISTRATION
AND THE PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION
IS SET ON HYDROGEN THING. GOING
BACK TO- GOVERNOR
SCHWARZENEGGER WERE NOT ON. ON
TARGET TO MEET THOSE THOSE
LOFTY- NEEDS. I GUESS I'M I'M
JUST CURIOUS IF WE CAN ONLY
HAVE FORTY OF THE TWO HUNDRED
STATIONS THAT WE NEED DOING
ANOTHER ASSESSMENT OF IT WELL
IT MAY BE TO LET US KNOW HELP
WOEFULLY BEHIND WE ARE AHEAD
AND REPEAT THOSE COUPLES
PURPOSES JUST BEHIND- SO. I'M
I'M RELUCTANT TO SUPPORT THE
BILL BECAUSE I THINK IT'S JUST-
IT DID WE DON'T NEED IT WORKING
GROUP TO CREATE THE ASSESSMENTS
I THINK THAT STAFF REPORT THAT
SAID I'M GOING TO VOTE FOR IT
THIS MORNING- JUST SOMEONE ON
THE DON'T MIND TALKING TO THE
AUTHOR ABOUT IT MR- MISTER
CHAIR ABOUT. HOW WE CAN YOU
KNOW STREAMLINED I SEE I
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE ULTIMATE
GOAL IS RIGHT NOW I DON'T KNOW
I THINK WE CAN INCORPORATED IN
THE EXISTING- WORKED AT THE
AIRPORTS DOING AND- I THINK OF.
OBVIOUSLY SOME FUNDING FOR NEW
HYDROGEN STATIONS AT THE POOL
MOVE THE ADVOCATES. ALONG
PASSED SO. INTENDED I MIGHT ADD
YOUR YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
THERE IS ROOM TO LOOK ON THE
IDEA OF PIGGY BACKING TO A. B.
EIGHT- BUT THAT'S SOMETHING WE
CAN DISCUSS IN THE FUTURE. AND.
AS WE MOVE THIS BILL ALONG. ALL
RIGHT SO I ASSOCIATE MYSELF
WITH COMMENTS SENATOR. AT SO
THE TO MOVE BY A SAN CASKEY
MANY QUESTION THAT'S YEAH. IT'S
AN EXHAUST. THANK YOU I'M
CENTER ARE CHILL THAT I KNOW
THAT YOU A BIG PLAYER- IN THIS
SPACE I JUST TO THANK YOU THAT
WERE- I TO A WANT TO THAT- WE
JUST AS WE JUST HAD A NEW WERE
THERE. ON FRIDAY A LOT OF THE
WORK UP AHEAD THERE'S SO MUCH
WORK TO DO IN THIS SPACE AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU AS WELL- JUST TO ENSURE
THAT WE GET THIS RIGHT AND I A
LINE. AS WELL THE SENATOR
MCCASKEY IN THOSE THOUGHTS THAT
PERHAPS THERE'S MAYBE OTHER
WAYS THAT WE CAN GET TO THE
GOALS THAT YOU'RE LOOKING AT-
IN IN A MORE COMPREHENSIVE WAY
BUT- LOOK FOR DISAPPOINTING IT
TODAY THANK YOU. ALL RIGHTS
MOVEMENTS. CASKEY. WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE YES AND I PER THE CA
AND I COULD SEE THE WERE ALL
TRYING TO DO TOGETHER TO CLEAN
AND MAKE CALIFORNIA THE
CLEANEST STATE IN THE NATION
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR INPUT AND
WITH THAT. I ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL.
ARCHERFISH CORAL I TO NUMBER
ONE. SB SIX FOUR THREE BY
ARCHULETA. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON TRANSPORTATION ALLEN. HI I
I SKINNER STERN WHITE HOUSE E.
CASKEY I. OKAY THANK YOU FOR
THE CENTER WE'RE GONNA LEAVE
THE ROLL OVER FOR OTHER MEMBERS
TO ADD ON. THE NEXT BILL IS.
ATKINS SB AND PRETENDING ASK IF
I BE- ABLE TO PRESENT SO LET ME-
HAVE THE GAVEL TO MY- BASED.
ARE YOU GOING TO DO THAT HERE
MAN I WAS TO DO HERE TO
PROFICIENCIES PLEASE BE OKAY
ALL RIGHT SO- MADAM MADAM VICE
CHAIR AND CALL I BILL A ONE
STAB FOR THE FIRST TIME CAL LAW
THE NEW PLANNING IN PUBLIC
AGENCIES OF TO THE AND- OF
LEVEL RISE AND IT REQUIRES THE
COASTAL COMMISSION TO ADOPT AND
PERIODICALLY UPDATE STANDARDS
FOR USE IN LOCAL AND REGIONAL
COASTAL PLANNING. IN ORDER TO
MORE EFFICIENTLY IDENTIFY
ASSESS AND MITIGATE SEA LEVEL
RISE SB ONE ESTABLISHES A NEW
CROSS GOVERNMENT COLLABORATIVE
TO ENSURE THE IMPACTS OF SEA
LEVEL RISE ARE ANTICIPATED IN
ADDRESS BEYOND SIMPLY-
ENVIRONMENTAL DEPARTMENT BUT
ALSO BY OUR TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE AGENCIES AND
THEN FINALLY IT ESTABLISHES NEW
FUNDING CONTINGENT UPON
APPROPRIATION IN THE ANNUAL
BUDGET FOR STATE REGIONAL AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO PLAN FOR
AND MITIGATE. AGAINST THE
INEVITABILITY OF SEA LEVEL RISE
SEPARATELY EXPENSE EXISTING
CALLIE PA ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
GRANT PROGRAM TO ENSURE THAT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNIIES MOST
IMPACTED FROM SEA LEVEL RISE
HAVE A VOICE IN ACTIONS
GOVERNMENT TAKES TO ADDRESS THE
CHALLENGE I WE ALL SEEM TO BE
THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE
MASSIVE WILDFIRES- LOSS OF
HUNDREDS OF LIVES PROPERTY
DESTROYED BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN TAXPAYER COSTS. A BIT BUT
CLIMATE CHANGE SEA LEVEL RISE
ARE AFFECTING CALIFORNIANS IN
IN MORE SUBTLE BUT EQUALLY
DAMAGING WAYS ACCORDING TO OUR.
OUR LEGISLATIVE ANALYST.
CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCE
AUTHORIZED OF HALF OF IN THE
NEXT DECADE. AND UP TO SEVEN
FEET BY THE END OF THE SENATE.
I PERIODIC EVENTS LIKE COASTAL
STORMS KING TIDES. FIVE IS A
FAX THESE CHAIN COULD VERY WELL
IN AND DAY LOCAL- COASTAL AREAS
AND EVEN INLAND AREAS WREAKING
HAVOC ON BOTH PRIVATE AND
PUBLIC FACILITIES. STATE
GOVERNMENT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ARE ONLY IN THE VERY EARLY
STAGES OF PLANNING FOR
ANTICIPATING SEA LEVEL RISE- I
MYSELF HAVE A BILL ON THIS- THE
LONGER WE WAIT THE MORE COSTLY
THE DAMAGE WILL BE IN THE
ALLEY- RECOMMENDS MORE FINDING
GREATER STATE REGIONAL LOCAL
COLLABORATION BETTER INFORM
PLANNING LAND USE DECISIONS.
AND SO DOES THE RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT ARE EMBODIED IN THE BILL
THAT'S BEFORE US TODAY TWO
pTEMPTING SOMETIMES TO SEE AT
SEA LEVEL RISES A- A FIRST
WORLD PROBLEM FOR WEALTHY
COASTAL ENCLAVES LIKE MALIBU
HI<c.cyan>. BUT IN REALITY IT WILL</c>
DO MOST HARM TO THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT CAN LEAST
AFFORD TO DRESS SECURITIES LIKE
IMPERIAL BEACH CHULA VISTA. IN
THE PRO TEM'S REGION PORT WHY
NINI MARINA. IN OUR ON OUR
CENTRAL COAST MIL PAETUS
CRESCENT CITY. IN THE NORTHERN
PART OF THE STATE. I MEAN THE
OTHER THING SHE WANTED TO MAKE
SURE WE MENTION IT'S TEMPTING
TO SEE FIELD ARISES JUST
ANOTHER ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUE.
BUT IT ALSO CUTS ACROSS MANY
AREAS FROM TRANSPORTATION
COMMERCE RECREATION. IN THE
PROTESTERS TO COASTAL EROSION
FROM SEA LEVEL RISE AND CLIFF
EROSION IS KILLED STROLLERS
WALKING ON THE BEACH. IT'S CUT
OFF KEY RAIL TRANSPORTATION
INTO AND OUT OF SAN DIEGO-
CERTAINLY WE HOPE THE
CHALLENGES THE BIG SERVICE
FACED. SO THIS BILL PRESENTS A
COMEDIAN. WITH AN OPPORTUNE GET
OUT. OF THIS IMPORTANT. OF
CLIMATE IN OUR- STATE AND- I
CERTAINLY JOINT. AND I YOU FOR
AND I'VE. I KNOW OF. THE THANK
YOU SENATOR ONLY AND YOU HAVE
YOUR LEAD OF YES THE LEE. THE
ARE- SERRA. I MEAN AS TO WHO'S
A WITH THE COOK CAL COSTA AND-
JENNIFER SAVAGE FROM THE SERVER
FUND. WITH MODERATOR OUR ON THE
LINE AND READY TO TESTIFY AND
SO. YES OUR LINES ARE OPEN AND
THEN GO AHEAD. OKAY GOOD
MORNING COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS TERRY AND DADA.
RELIGIOUS SERVING ON THE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL COMMISSION
I'VE ALSO STUDIED THE IMPACT OF
THE AUTHORIZED ON SHORELINE
AREAS AN ADVOCATE- NEEDED
REFORMS FORGET YEARS SH A
SENATOR MENTIONED WE KNOW THE
IMPACT WILL NOT HAPPEN SLOWLY
GRADUALLY AT THE FAR OFF TIME
HORIZON AT TWENTY FIFTY AND
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED MIGHT APPLY.
BUT INSTEAD AND YET PREDICTED A
MERCHANT FEES ASSOCIATED WITH
EXTREME WEATHER AND ULTRA HIGH
TIDE EVENTS. I WANT TO SPEAK
TODAY IN PARTICULAR THE IMPACT
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IN
CALIFORNIA MANY OF THEM HAVE
BEEN EXCLUDED FROM COASTAL
AREAS THROUGH STATE SANCTIONED
AND MENTOR MAN. RELEGATED TO
AREAS VULNERABLE TO FLOODING
THE REDLINING OF FEDERAL
HOUSING PROJECTS AND WHO LIVE
IN LARGELY PARK OR AREAS AND
CAN ACCESS TO COASTAL AREAS.
ONLY WALKING A PUBLIC. THE
LITTLE RISE. AND ARE ARE STATE
ACT OR INACTION WILL PERPETUATE
AN ACT AND- OF. THAT IF WE DO
NOT KNOW. WITH REPORT LIKE THE
AND HAD THE ONE SH LOWER INCOME.
AND THOSE WHO LIVE IN RENTAL.
AND ALL THE THAT ALAN MENTION.
ARE MORE LIKE TO BE. BY
FLOODING OR DELAYED IMPACT AS
COMPARED TO PROPERTY OWNERS
THEY LACK THE FUN. AND OUR
ABILITY TO REBUILD. ALASKAN OR
STATE'S AND OFTEN HAVE. ACCESS
TO ENSURE. I THINK ONE WILL
OCCUR A FREE FOR TWO OUR BEFORE
IT'S TOO. AND ENACT THE FOR
COMP. PEOPLE RIGHT PROGRAM
INSTEAD GOVERNMENT. AND
ESTABLISHES FOR A GUY. AND
COMMUNITIES THE PLAN CORN MANY
THE LEVEL RIGHT. IT WOULD MAKE
UP TO ONE MILLION DOLLARS A-
FOR LOCAL YOU PREPARE. WERE
USING EXISTING STATE.
STRUCTURES AND GOVERNOR. AND
EXPLICITLY I THE LITTLE RIDE TO
THE- ENVIRONMENTAL. GRANT PARK.
FUNDING CRITICS NEEDED FUNDS
THAT THE COMMUNITIES. EVERY
YEAR THAT WE CANNOT TAKE ACTION.
TO PREPARE STAY CHRISSY LAURA.
IN THE STATE OF OUR- AND
CHOICES. AND WE KNOW THAT THE
WATER WILL FELT MOST SHARPLY.
BY DISADVANTAGE AND UNDER
COMMUNITIES. ARE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WITNESS THE FUND FROM
COSTA CA TO SAVAGE. ARE YOU ON
THE PHONE ON THE. YES I'M HERE-
AND GOOD MORNING TO MEMBERS
JENNIFER SAVAGE CALIFORNIA.
MANAGER THE THIRD FIGHTER FOUND.
I THINK HER THE HARM THE LEVEL
OF WILL BE CAL PEOPLE ACROSS
AND- LIFE I BEEN MADE CLEAR AND
THE OWNED REPORT. IF WE DO NOT
TAKE PLACE WE WILL LEAVE OUR
BEACHES AND FRONT COMMUNITY AT
THE ENTIRE. AND OUR THEM THE
MOST BIODIVERSE COASTAL IN THE
TO. IMPROPER TERMS THIS MEANS
THE MILLION OF CATTLE READ AND
TO WORK. ADMIRE AND OTHER LIFE
BY BUT STILL AND ARE BECAUSE
LINE WELL NO LONGER THE TO GO
TO IT MEANS THAT THE COULD
WITHOUT. WITH THAT FOR THE MOST
CATHOLIC AND LOSS. PRINCIPAL
LINE STATE ACTION SIGNED BY
SEVENTEEN AGENCIES AND
COMMISSIONS. TO CREATE A WHOLE
OF GOVERNMENT COORDINATED
APPROACH. THE BILL TACKLE
PEELABLE RIGHTS ISSUES ON THE
FRONT LINES USING PROVEN
INSTITUTION A COASTAL RESOURCES
MANAGEMENT. TO BETTER INTEGRATE
THE LEVEL RISE IN THE COASTAL
DEVELOPMENT PLANNING AND
PERMITTING. SB ONE ALSO
PROVIDES DESPERATELY NEEDED
ANNUAL FUNDING TO LOCAL
REGIONAL AND TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS. AND COMMUNITIES.
ANYTHING EXTRA. ADAPTATION
CHALLENGES IT'S CRITICAL TO
NOTE THAT THE LONGER BEFORE CO
INVESTING IN THE PLANNING
GOVERNANCE AND PHYSICAL
ADAPTATIONS NECESSARY. TO
RESPOND TO RISING FEES. AND
MORE EXPENSIVE. WILL BECOME HIS
SAVVY ONE WITH ELEVEN YEAR A
GUY YOUR TIME LIMIT SO. YOU OF
YOU KNOW BECAUSE WE UP THEIR-
CAN GO TO THOSE NOT THANK YOU
FOR ALL. YES FOR ALL OF THE
TREES AND WE ASK FOR YES VOTE
ON SB. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY. NOW WE'LL GO TO OTHER ARE
WE SHOULD TESTIFYING SUPPORT TO
IDEA SEE ANY IN. THIS ROOM INTO
THE MICROPHONE AND I DON'T SEE
ANYONE IN ROOM TO FORTY SO WE
GO TO. ARE THOSE THE TELE NO RE
THEM THAT YOU HAVE MADE JAMS
STAY YOUR NAME YEAR FILL.
HANDLE ALL OF YOUR UP. SO I. DO
WE HAVE. BOB DID. QUEUING UP
JUST ON THE TELL LINE. THANK
YOU YOU AREN'T THE OF AS ONE
YOU MIGHT PER ONE THEN ZERO.
BILL THE LIGHT OF TWENTY. YOUR
LINE IS- OPEN. GOOD MORNING
NORTH AMERICA TO GET CONSERVE
BETTER IMPORT. THANK YOU ANNEX
OVER LINE OF FIVE YEAR LAW IS-
OPEN. GOOD MORNING JUST NOT
FROM THE BILL VALLEY GROUP WE
HAVE THE OF AMANDA PETITION THE
REASONS IN OUR LETTER THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU. NEXT OVER
THE LINE OF. ONE YEAR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING JAMIE GO I
BEHALF OF SCHOOL SUPPORT THANK
YOU. OKAY THANK YOU NENEK SILVA
LINE OF. NINE FIFTY ALAINA
THOUGH. FOR MORE DANIEL BROWN
ON BEHALF OF SHARE CALIFORNIA
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MEXICO LINE
UP FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE OPEN.
GOOD MORNING DAILY JAPA BEHALF
OF COMMUNITY NATURE CAN'T MADE
CONTENT WILL BE OPENS DISTRICT
AND CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS ON
IN. THANK YOU NEXT WILL LINE
FORTY YEAR OF THE. NINE FOUR
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOU
HAVE ASSIGNMENTS. OKAY WE'LL
MOVE ON TO LINE FORTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JONATHAN
CLAY ON BEHALF OF THE PORT OF
SAN DIEGO SUPPORT. THANKYOU AN
EXTRA LINE OF FORTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY SUPPORT OF SB ONE
BANK AND FOR THE LEVEL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND NEXT TO
WILLOW OF FOR NINE YOUR LINE IS
A- NO MORE MADAM CHAIR MEMBER
GLENN WITH SAN DIEGO WATER
AUTHORITY IN SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE. THANK YOU. AN EXTRA
LINE OF. YOUR LINE IS- OPEN.
DID YOU EVER- COVER MEMBER THE
LONG BEACH CLOSE CHRISTIAN BY
THE CAN THANKS FOR. THANK YOU
AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORT
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU MODERATOR WE DO HAVE BEFORE
WE GO TO THOSE WHO MAY WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION ONE OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO
ASK A QUESTION SENATOR MIKE
ASTI. YEAH I APOLOGIZE- TO POP
OUT- AFTER THIS- ONE OF THINGS
I WANT TO BRING TO COMMITTEES
ATTENTION IS THAT THERE'S MONEY
IN THE LAST THREE BUDGETS THAT
HAVE BEEN GOING TO THE BAY AREA
CONSERVATION DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION TO DO PLANNING AND
PART OF THE PLANNING AS WE KNOW
THAT MIL PAETUS AND HEY WE'RE
GOOD NOW FOR YOU SO IN. EAST
PALO ALTO PARK IN INDIA IS TO
GIVE. A G. COMMUNITY. MONEY FOR
PLANNING. TO THE THEY THEY FIVE
OUT- OR SS THE- IMPACT THAT THE
WOULD HAVE ON C. LEVEL. TO
THEIR NAY. IT MAY NOT THE HE
THE DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY BUT
MAYBE THERE. OR NAY THAT MAY
TAKE SOME. IN THE OF ADAM. THAT
WILL HAPPEN. THE SECOND IS THAT
ON THE- MONEY FOR THE- EACH
CASE GRANTS PROGRAM. YOU KNOW
IT'S I'M I'M CONFUSED BECAUSE
IT INCREASES THE MAXIMUM
AMOUNT. FROM ONE AND A HALF
MILLION TO TWO TWO MILLION
DOLLARS BUT THEN IT MANDATES
THAT NOT MORE THAN A HALF A
MILLION DOLLAR BE GIVEN TO
ORGANIZATIONS WORKING ON SEA
LEVEL RISE. PRICE SO MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT. THAT'S A
MAX OF FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND.
STATEWIDE. ON SEA LEVEL RISE SO
WELL THIS IS IT APPEARS TO BE
S. LEVEL RISE BILL. THE
LIMITING THE OF MONEY THAT CAN
GO TO ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
GRANTS- FOR THAT WORK FOR THAT
WORKING AGAIN. IT MAY BE THE
NEIGHBORS THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
WORKING THAT THAT THAT THAT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY CAN
HELP WITH THE PLANNING DOCUMENT
SO YOU CAN SEE YOU CAN SAY THAT
IF YOU DO YOU CAN MAKE CERTAIN.
PURPOSE C. WALL IT'S GETTING
INUNDATED THE LOWER INCOME
AREAS SO- THOSE ARE THE
CONCERNS I WANT TO RAISE THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I APPRECIATE
MANAGER. THANK IN SENATOR ALLEN
DID YOU HAVE A RESPONSE- THE
AND I DON'T THINK OF THE
SENATORS. HE'S RIGHT. THAT THIS
IS THE WAY THAT THE FOR STARTS
YEAH OKAY. THEN WE WILL NOW TO
THOSE WHO MAY WISH ODD SPEAK AN
OPERA TO SB. I DO NOT SEE ANY
IN ROOM HERE IN THIS NOR IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. THEREFORE WE
WERE GO TO THE PHONE LAW ARE
MONTEREY DO WE HAVE ANY ON THE
PHONE LINES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB ONE. THANK YOU
IF YOU ARE NOT. YOU MAY PRESS
AND THEN. ZERO IN OPPOSITION
OUT OF S. B. ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND WE HAVE
NOBODY IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU. THANK YOU THEN
WILL BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK
TO COMMITTEE ON IN INDIA
ADDITIONAL. COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FOR SENATOR ALLEN ON
SB ONE. I SEE NONE. THEN
WITHOUT WILL CALL THE ROLL. THE
ITEM NUMBER TWO SB ONE BY
SENATOR ACTIONS THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ALAN HI ALAN I
BATES. ALLEY GONZALEZ FIVE
DOLLARS AYE SKINNER STERN Y.
CASKEY. THAT HAS TO BILLS WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN. THANK YOU
W. THIRTY MATHIS HERE- ALL
RIGHT LET'S SO- LET'S NOW. THE
NINETY CENTER LEYVA. FIVE
HUNDRED DO YOU WANNA CONSIDER
THE MERITS UNIVERSE YOUR BILL
ACTUALLY. YOU DON'T CHAT WITH
YOU ABOUT OKAY WANT TO PULL UP
TO AT ONE IS THE MINUTES FIRST
OKAY OKAY OKAY. ASSEMBLY YEAH
OKAY. OKAY SO I'M JUST CHATTED
WITH THE SENATE OUT- ON THAT'S
BEFORE AN FIVE HE'S GOING TO
PUT WORK SOME MMA AND WILL WILL
BE I GUESS HAVE A TO OTHER SO
IT'S LET'S LET'S TALK. OKAY
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. AS CENTER
ON HER WAY. YEAH OKAY FROM. BUT
THEN WHEN WE WILL IT SENATORS
ALL I'M SORRY YOUR LET'S THAN
LET'S ITEM EIGHT IS. THREE TWO-
SOUTH BECAUSE OUR QUALITY
MANAGER DISTRICT. GOOD MORNING
MISS. DECADES HAS SOME OF THE
WORST AIR QUALITY IN THE NATION
NO NO NEW SURPRISE TO THIS- AND
OF COURSE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES HAVE HISTORICALLY
BEEN OVERBURDENED WITH THE
IMPACTS OF AIR POLLUTION MANY
OF WHICH ARE IN MY COMMUNITIES-
LIKE SOUTHEAST LOS ANGELES- AND
LONG BEACH AND ALONG THIS BY
SEVEN TEN K. CORD OR THEY PAY
THE HIGHEST COSTS. I WOULD SOME
OF THE WORST AIR QUALITY IN THE
NATION AND APPOINTING MEMBERS
TO THE BOARD THAT REPRESENTS
AND WORK DIRECTLY WITH
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY BURDENED BY
HIGH LEVELS OF POLLUTION WILL
BRING VALUE FULL EXPERTISE
CONCERNING THE ENVIRONMENTAL
BURDENS THAT ARE UNDERMINING
THE REGION'S ABILITY TO MEET
AIR QUALITY STANDARDS AND WILL
DRIVE SIGNIFICANT CHANGE TO
PROTECT THE WELL BEING OF THESE
COMMUNITIES. WE KNOW THAT THIS
HAS BEEN TRIED BEFORE BUT WERE
AT IT AGAIN BECAUSE WE REALLY
DO BELIEVE THAT THERE NEEDS TO
BE REPRESENTATION FOR THESE
COMMUNITIES WE MUST ACT NOW TO
DELIBERATELY INCLUDE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE VOICES
AND ESTABLISH ACTIVE LONG TERM
COMMUNITY REPRESENTATION AS WE
STRUGGLE TO MEET THESE GOALS-
ARE ALSO STILL WORKING ON THE
BILL WITH MANY STAKEHOLDERS I
WOULD SAY AND- I JUST.
CERTAINLY URGENT AYE VOTE WHEN
IT IS APPROPRIATE BUT
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT TODAY I
HAVE SUPERVISOR NATHAN FLETCHER
ARE SAN DIEGO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS HE IS ALSO A
SERVING MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
AND BOARD MEMBER OF THE SAN
DIEGO AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICT. I ALSO HAVE A PROBLEM
ASSEMBLY DIRECTOR OF RESEARCH
AND POLICY WITH COMMUNITIES FOR
A BETTER ENVIRONMENT I THANK
THEM BOTH FOR BEING HERE. THANK
YOU. MODERATOR FOR GOING TO THE
SUPPORT LINE. I DO NOT SEE
EITHER ONE OF THEM ON THE PHONE
LINES AT THIS TIME. OKAY DO WE
HAVE ANYONE ELSE- I DON'T SEE
ONE TWENTY FORTY OR HERE IN THE
ROOM ANYONE ELSE WANTS TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. ON THE
LINES OF I'M SORRY DO YOU IN
OPPOSITION AS WHEN. YOU'RE OUT
OKAY WHEN YOU COME UP IN. SARAH.
OKAY GO FOR. GOOD MORNING MY
QUEST THE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL.
REACHED OUT TO THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE BECAUSE LEGAL. YOUR
VOICE ON THE COAST AND THEN D.
E. AND F. AS FOR ONE OF THESE
NEW SEATS TO BE. RESERVED FOR
SOMEONE FROM ORGANIZED LABOR
AND WE HOPE THAT THESE
CONVERSATIONS ARE FRUITFUL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR. ALL
RIGHTS ON THE ON THE LINE-
MODERATOR WHAT'S OUR SITUATION
WE HAVE. TO BE ON RIGHT NOW
BOTH THE SUPERVISOR AND THE
FROM BUT I'M I'M HEARING THAT
AT THE TIME EIGHT YEAH WAITING
TO BE LET IN. THE BILL AUTHOR
IS UNDER THE UNDERSTANDING THAT
THE TO LEAD WITNESSES- BOB FROM
FACILITY AND- SUPERVISOR.
FLETCHER ARE BOTH WAITING TO BE
LET IN IS THAT. CORRECT WE DO
HAVE MASON FLETCHER ON THE LINE.
RIGHT WHEN WE START WITH THE
SUPERVISOR. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OK YES WE
CAN HEAR YOU LOUD AND CLEAR A
LITTLE BIT OF AN ECHO BUT WE
CAN HEAR YOU. OKAY DID YOU. I'M
I JOIN OUR- WANTED HIM. CENTER
LEANING IN DOLLARS FOR BRINGING
THE PLEDGES. FORWARD I EAT I
THINK ABOUT THESE ISSUES A LOT.
AND IN MY ROLE BOTH AS A MEMBER
OF THE CALIFORNIA RESOURCES
BOARD. AND OUR LOCAL AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT. I
REPRESENT A AN AREA IT IS IT IS
NOT. DISSIMILAR FROM OTHER
AREAS OF CALIFORNIA WHERE
CHILDREN. IN MY DISTRICT- ONE
GROUP OF CHILDREN. EIGHT TIMES
MORE LIKELY TO HAVE OUTLIVED
ANY NO OTHER GROUP OF CHILDREN.
BECAUSE OF ISSUES OF AIR
POLLUTION IN THE ROLE OF OUR
AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICTS. ARE VERY SIMPLE IT
IS TO CONTROL. AIR POLLUTION.
HI IT IS IT WOULD BE AN
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE. AIMS AND
INTENTIONS TO ENSURE. THAT
THERE IS A CLEAN AIR ARE AND
THAT THERE IS OPPORTUNITY FOR
HELP- ALONGSIDE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. LAST YEAR I CAME
BEFORE YOUR BODY IN SUPPORT OF
AB FOUR TWENTY THREE WHICH
ADDED ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
SEATS. FOR RTNDA GO AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT AT
THE SAME. EFFORT BEING
UNDERTAKEN HERE TODAY. AND I
CAN TELL YOU AS A MEMBER OF THE
AUDIENCE ALREADY HAD A
TREMENDOUSLY POSITIVE IMPACT.
IN ENSURING THAT THE
COMMUNITIES MOST IMPACTED- IN
THE ENTITIES MOST INVOLVED IN
FIGHTING FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE. HAPPY BOYS IN THE SEAT
AT THE TABLE FOR THE ENTITY
TASKED WITH ENSURING
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE. I WOULD
ALSO SURE THIS IS NOT. A NEW
CONCEPT FOR THE LEGISLATURE.
ANY MULTIPLE- S. B. TWO FIFTY
EIGHT. EMPIRE JUST SEE THE- TO
THEIR REPORT BOARD- I MEAN WE
JUST- THE EIGHT SIX. PER
REQUIRED. COMMUNITY FOR BOTH
FAIR DISTRICTS AND CAR. AND
THEN OF COURSE YEAR WE THIS IS
REALLY OUT OF THE MEASURE OF
LOCAL CONTROL. BY ADDING LOW.
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE SEEDS- TO
THE AIR DISTRICT I THINK THIS
IS A GREAT AFRICAN PLEASED TO
SUPPORT AND I REALLY HOPE WE
CAN ADVANCE TO FULFILL THE TRUE
MISSION INTENDED TO THEIR
DISTRICTS AND- AGAIN MY
APPRECIATION THE AUTHOR FOR ALL
HER WORK TO BRING THIS FORWARD
AND- HOPEFULLY OUT. LIKE LIKE
TO SEE SUPPORT FOR TODAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND I IT'S MY
UNDERSTAND THAT- THE OTHER LEE
WITH. NOW AVAILABLE THANK YOU
BUT THANK YOU SUPERVISOR.
BAHARAMPUR DALY. HI HOW- HELLO-
BUT MORNING MY NAME'S
BACKGROUND PERSONALLY DIRECTOR
RESEARCH AND POLICY AT CP OUR
COMMUNITY IS LIVING AT THE
FENCE LINE- OF FOSSIL FUEL
OPERATIONS AND OF COLLUDING
FACILITIES I'VE EXPERIENCED
FIRSTHAND THAT MANY TIMES ON
KEY VOTES THE MAJORITY OF A
JUNKIE BOARD MEMBERS HAVE BEEN
RELUCTANT TO STAND UP TO BIG
OIL AND PROTECT WORKING CLASS
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. INFLUENCE
OF BIG OIL AND THE BORDER SO
SIGNIFICANT. THAT WE SEE IN
MANY CASES AN AGENT GETS STAFF
WHO HAVE EXTENSIVE EXPERTISE ON
THE ISSUES ARE OFTEN RELUCTANT
TO PROPOSE I'M MOST HOW
PROTECTIVE MEASURES TO BENEFIT
FRONTLINE COMMUNITIES IN FEAR
OF BEING REJECTED THE CHASTISED
BY SPEND MAJORITY OF BOARD
MEMBERS ARE OFTEN MUCH MORE
ENTHUSIASTIC TO PROTECT OUR THE
POOREST MAN I'M FAMILIES
LIVING. WITH THEM KING OF. THE
ADVERSE HEALTH IMPACTS.
POLLUTION THE CARD IN WORKING
CLASS RESIDENTS OFTEN OUR TIME
ON FROM THE NINE- WHAT DO
TESTIFY A. COUNTY BOARD THANK
ISSUES RIGHT TO ENFORCEMENT AND
WILL MAKE. I SOME OF THE MOST
HAVE THEIR ON OFFER AND THE
THING FINAL THAT SHE BOUGHT MY-
HOW ALREADY MADE UP THAT-
BEFORE LOOK TO THE CAN OR EVEN
TO THE THAT OUT OF THE THERE ON
THE STATE WHEN IT REGIONAL A
DIRECTORY I'M SO SORRY WERE
GONNA WE'RE GONNA GET YOU MIGHT
JUST YEAH BROWN UP FROM SAYS WE
WOULD HAVE TO CONSTRAINTS. I
JUST LIKE ONCE A THAT HE YES
PLEASE. WHAT IT WHEN IT AGE
CREE BY THE STATE DOES NOT DO
MUCH TO PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF
ITS MOST VULNERABLE GROUPS THAT
STATE HAS AN OBLIGATION TO
EXPECTING REGISTRATION NEEDS TO
STEP IN AND FIX THE FLAWED
DECISION MAKING STRUCTURE.
INFLICTED IMMEASURABLE PAIN AND
SUFFERING ON TO FAMILIES LIVING
IN THE MOST POLLUTED REGIONS
THE NEIGHBORHOODS AND THE FACT
WAS THAT BEST THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
DIRECTOR FOR YOUR FOR YOUR- FOR
PARENTS THANK YOU. OKAY I DO WE
HAVE OTHER PEOPLE WHO WANT. TO
VOICE SUPPORT ON THE PHONE
LINES. THANK YOU IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE OF TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NO MATTER WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION VOTERS
IN SUPPORT OF ATHLETES BECAUSE
JAIL. THANK YOU WHAT A LINE OF
FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
JIMMY GOLEN WE HAVE THE
ENVIRONMENT FOR THE FUN FUN IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND WE'LL GO
TO LINE OF FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GETTING ABROAD ON BEHALF
OF SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NOT THE BILL
LINE OF TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. KRISH OTHERS IF YOU
POLICY DIRECTOR COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
AN EXTRA LINE OF THIRTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL PROJECT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY CALLING ON WITH
THE TRIAL COURT AND THE MEN OF
THE COURT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NOW FOR
THEIR SUPPORT IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU. CAN WE GO TO
OUR POSITION WITH AS I
UNDERSTAND AS A LEAD WITNESS
WHO'S HERE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION CERRO- WILTFONG
FROM- LA COUNTY. BUSINESS
FEDERATION. YES I'M HERE YES.
GREAT GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
TERRIBLE FONG AND I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BUSINESS FEDERATION ALSO NOTED
THAT WE ARE IN A LIFE OVER TO
COULD HAVE BEEN ORGANIZATIONS
REPRESENTING OVER FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND EMPLOYERS OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WE TAKE A STRONG
OPPOSITION SENATE BILL AT AT.
THREE FORTY TWO FOR THE
FOLLOWING REASON SH ONE THE
BILL IS UNNECESSARY DUPLICATE
CHECKS BAKER OF THE ASSEMBLY
AND SENATE WILL COMMITTEE AND
THE GOVERNOR ALREADY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO EACH APPOINT AN
INDIVIDUAL TO AT&T- IN FACT
APPOINTEES FROM TIME AND TIME
AGAIN EXPRESSED THEIR
COMMITMENT TO IMPROVING THE
ENVIRONMENT NUMBER TWO IF WE
CAN VOCAL CONTROL BUT THE
DANGER OF CRAFTSMEN AND TAKE
THREE AUTHORITY AWAY FROM LOCAL
ELECTED OFFICIALS TO
ACCOUNTABLE TO THEIR
CONSTITUENTS. SB THREE FORTY
TWO AGAINST STATE APPOINTED NOT
ELECTED REPRESENTATIVES ONE
THIRD OF THE SPEECH ON THE
RESULT BOARD THAT IS MEANT TO
REPRESENT LOCAL INSURANCE AND
CURRENTLY REPRESENTED BY
SITTING COUNTY CRYSTAL WHO FOR
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA COUNTY
ELECTED OFFICIALS SERVING ON
THE BOARD HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY
TO THEIR VOTERS IT'S OBLIGATION
WILL BE WEEKEND BY ADDING MORE
APPOINTEES. ARE NOT ACCOUNTABLE
TO THE PUBLIC. NUMBER THREE. IT
IS PACKED WITH. THE LOCAL
LEADER. BY ADDING BOARD SEAT AT
THE THREE FORTY APPLY TO THE
LEFT OFFICIALS SERVING ON THE-
ARE NOT. SACKED SPENDING CALL.
COMING UP CURRENT THIRTEEN
NUMBER. HAD FOR ALL. FIFTY
YEARS. NUMBER THE SP. DO YOU
HAVE ALREADY- HOW A BARBELL
JEFF THAT THE THREE. OF THE
BOY'S MEMBER. AS CHAIR. IN THE
NINETEEN NINETY THE BORDERS. A
TO A BUY MOST. THEIR QUALITY.
DISTRICT OVER. THEM PUBLIC
HEALTH THE DISTRICT. IN
COMMUNITIES. YES CAN BE IN. OF
THE GROUP INCLUDE I THINK INTO.
DIVERSE MEMBERSHIP OF THIRTY
PEOPLE AND ACTIVATED. AND
EIGHTEEN D. BOARD MEMBER STARR
TO THE CHAIR COULD BE THE
REASON ANYMORE INSTEAD. SB
THREE FORTY TWO. WE SUBMITTED A
COALITION LETTER TWENTY SIX
OTHER ORGANIZATION TO ALSO
COVER DID NOT MAKE THE
COMMITTEE NOW THAT.
ORGANIZATIONS ARE. THE BUILDING
OWNERS AND MANAGERS ASSOCIATION
WALKING LEFT THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE THE
CALIFORNIA. EVEN IF THE PATIENT
THE CALIFORNIA THAT THE
PROPERTY WITH THE STATION. THE
CALIFORNIA HISPANIC CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE THE CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
METAL COALITION. THE CONFERENCE
CALL WITH THE LION CARD WHO TO
MAKE IT OR THE LINE. ABOUT THE
ENERGY COALITION. CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY AIR QUALITY COALITION
FUTURE COURT. R. TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION AND I'M HER
ECONOMIC PARTNERSHIP. FOR
ENERGY CURRENT TAX LATIN BUT
THE THIRD BASEMAN BOBBY JERRY
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE LOS ANGELES
AREA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. WHICH
I THINK WILL BE ORANGE COUNTY
BUSINESS COUNCIL PACIFIC
MERCHANT SHIPPING ASSOCIATION
THANK EVERYBODY ECONOMIC
PARTNERSHIP. VALLEY INDUSTRY
AND COMMERCE ASSOCIATION. AND
WILMINGTON CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
ARE ALSO SOME OF THE COOLEST
WITH TWENTY. AND ORGANISER. AND
WE HIGHLY ENCOURAGE TO BE ABOUT
IT WELL. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COULD. NEVER COME. THANK YOU
MISS WILL FALL. I APPRECIATE
THE COMMENTS OKAY I DON'T SEE
WHY HERE WHO LIKE TO VOICE
OPPOSITION OR ANYONE ROOM TWO
ONE FORTY- MODERATORS ANYONE OF
LINE- LIKE TO EXPRESS OPPOSITE
OR CONCERN ABOUT US THREE FOUR
TWO. THANK YOU FOR OPPOSITE YOU
MIGHT ONE AND THEN. ONE AND
THEN ZERO ZERO OPPOSITION. AND
WE DO HAVE A FEW LINES TO AN UP
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. AND AS A
REMINDER WE ARE IN OPPOSITION.
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AND WE'LL GO LINE OF FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
FIFTY EIGHT. YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
A GUN YES. WE WERE DEALING WITH
THE INLAND EMPIRE ECONOMIC
PARTNERSHIP YOU'RE SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF A NUMBER OF BUSINESS
ORGANIZATIONS THE INLAND EMPIRE
SUPPORT I'D LIKE TO LIST ON THE
BALL MUCH CHEAPER OF COMMERCE
THE BIG BEAR CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE CHINO VALLEY CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE CORONA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE. MONTANA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE THE GREATER COACHELLA
VALLEY CHAMBER OF COMMERCE THE
GREATER I GUESS WHICHEVER OF
COMMERCE GOING UNDER THE
COUNCIL HIM ATTEMPTED TO VALLEY
CHAMBER THE HIGHLAND AREA
CHAMBER INLAND EMPIRE COME
PARTNERSHIP MEDICAID ELEGY
BERMAN OVERLY CHAMBER SLASH
WILL TO MARCHING BURKE EVERY
SPOT YOU WANT TO CHAMBER RANCHO
CUCAMONGA CHAMBER. REDLANDS TO
MAKE YOU AN OPEN CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE ALL IN OPPOSITION WE
THINK THIS IS REALLY A BILL
THAT'S REALLY UNNECESSARY THE
SPEAKER AND THE PROGRAM ALREADY
HAVE APPOINTEES IF THE
PROPONENTS BELIEVE OPPOSED
APPOINTEES ARE NOT DOING THEIR
JOB ADEQUATELY REPRESENTING
FROM THE JUSTICE COMMUNITIES
THEY SHOULD CALL FOR NEW
APPOINTEES. CAN DO THOSE-
ADEQUATELY REPRESENT THOSE
CONDITIONS ARE ON THE
ULTIMATELY THIS IS JUST A WEEK
BACK THE BOAT THANK YOU THANK
YOU SIR. OKAY THANK YOU GO TO
AND LINE OF SIXTY. OR OPEN. YES
HELLO MR SAYS SCOTT WHAT'S ON
BEHALF OF THE CAL TO PIPE
TRADES COUNTS. AND THE STATUS
SEE OF ELECTRIC WORKERS IN
OPPOSE TO S. B. FORTY TWO- FOR
THE RE STATED EARLIER WE
BELIEVE THAT IDENTIFYING ONE
PARTICULAR GROUP FOR
APPOINTMENT WILL JUST SERVE TO
BALKANIZED THE BOARD WENT
CHAMPION SORRY I'M SO SORRY SIR
BUT THE WE ALREADY HAD OUR LEAD
OPPOSITION WE WOULD. BURN THE
PRIEST ACROSS WE DID HAVE A
COMMENTS FOR THE BUILDING
TRADES FROM SOMEONE HERE IN
PERSON BUT I NEED I NEED TO
IMPOSE SOME I'M JUST ASKING
EVERYONE NOW TO JUST. STATE
THEIR NAME IN OPPOSITION BUT
I'D APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION MISTER WHICH-
LET'S GO TO THE NEXT- CALLER
THANK YOU NEXT- BILL. A LINE OF
FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
EXACTLY ON BEHALF OF THE
WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION MORE POST. THANK
YOU AND NEXT TO A LINE OF-
SIXTY SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. JOHN WALL AND I'M
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WE HAVE NO FURTHER OPPOSITION
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU SO MUCH LET'S MOVE LET'S
COME LET'S BRING THE BILL BACK
TO COMMITTEE FOR THOUGHTS
CONCERNS QUESTIONS. ISSUES. YES
MAKE A COMMENT I WILL BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT THE CITY BUT I THINK
THAT SENATOR GONZALEZ IS
FOCUSING IN ON SOMETHING THAT
HAS COME BEFORE BAYERN MENTAL
QUALITY COMMITTEE ALL THE SINCE
THE TIME I'VE SERVED ON IT-
WITH THOSE WHO LIVE IN ALL
THESE AREAS THAT ARE OF A VERY
HIGHLY POLLUTED BUT THEY ALSO
ROOM- PRESENTED A CONCERNED
ABOUT BALANCE ENSURING THAT
SOME OF THE REGULATIONS THAT
ARE PUT FORTH BY THE AIR
QUALITY ON MANAGEMENT DISTRICTS
HAVE IMPACTED IN THE ECONOMY
AND MOST AREAS SO I THINK WHAT
I'LL DO TODAY IS I'M GONNA LAY
OFF AND HOPE THAT HE'LL SPEND
SOME TIME WITH THE OPPOSITION
LOOKING FOR A BALANCE HERE AND
I THINK THAT THAT'S THE ONLY
THING THAT'S MISSING BECAUSE I
THINK A VOICE. OF THIS
PARTICULAR ONE I REMEMBER SO
CLEARLY HE CAME FROM SOUTH
CENTRAL LA WHERE I USED TO WORK
AS A SOCIAL WORKER AND IT WAS
SUPPORTIVE OF WHAT THEY WERE
TRYING TO DO BUT HE SAID IT WAS
REALLY THE UNDERTAKEN ENOUGH
TIME TO REALLY LOOK AT HOW JUST
GIVING AUTHORITY TO A ARE B.
AND Q. M. D. R. DIDN'T PROVIDE
BALLOTS FOR THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE ISSUES THAT THEY WERE
FACING AND THOSE COMMUNITIES IT
WAS VERY VERY ENLIGHTENING SO
WITHOUT IOWA JUST LAY OFF TODAY
AND THEN I KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO
BE WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION
TO OUR- MAYBE. YOU KNOW RAINY
AND SOME OF IT AND- REALLY
FOCUS ON BALANCE BECAUSE I
THINK THAT'S THE ISSUE THAT I
HEAR FROM THE OPPOSITION SO
WITH THAT THANK YOU MANAGER ALL
RIGHT SO I'VE MOVED AUTHOR EVEN
HEARD SOME CONCERNS WERE RAISED
BY OPPOSITION INCLUDING- BOTH-
FROM BUSINESS AND LABOR FOLKS
YOU YOU. WANNA RESPOND ANY OF
THEM AND MAYBE CLOSE. OKAY
RIGHT NOW ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND THING YOU SO
BATES AND THANK YOU TO ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS YOU KNOW THIS IS I
KNOW NOT AN EASY SUBJECT OF
COURSE THIS IS BEEN TRIED
BEFORE IN THE LEGISLATURE BUT
HAVING COME FROM A DISTRICT
WHERE THAT HAS BEEN HEAVILY
IMPACTED BY STATIONARY SOURCES
AT A COMMITTEE BOARD WHILE THEY
DO AN AMAZING JOB OVER 60% OF
THEM ARE ELECTED OFFICIALS AND
SO WE WANT TO BRING NEW
PERSPECTIVES INCLUDING THE AN
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES WE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO
ENSURE WE GET THIS RIGHT IN
HERE FROM EVERYBODY BUT- I
THINK THE TIME IS NOW FOR US TO
TURN THE PAGE AND HAVE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE VOICES AT
THE TABLE. I WANT TO THANK DR-
DIRECTOR FOR THE LEN SUPERVISOR
FLETCHER FOR LENDING THEIR
VOICES IN SUPPORT- AND WILL
CONTINUE I'M WORKING ON THIS
BUT I WOULD URGE AN AYE VOTE
AND I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK ON
THIS AS WELL. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. OKAY SOMEBODY'S BEEN MOVED
BY THE AUTHOR AND- THE SECTOR
PLEASE COLOR. ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT. SB THREE FORTY TWO BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE. ALAN HI. ALAN I
BATES. DALLY GONZALEZ FIVE.
IT'S ALWAYS AYE SKINNER STERN
BY CASKEY. OKAY WE'RE GONNA
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR OTHER
MEMBERS TO ADD ON AYE I THINK
YOU AND I SEE A CENTER LEYVA
HAS HERE SO WOULD LOVE YOU TO
PRESENT YOUR BILL. SB THREE
SEVENTY TWO AND THEN WE'LL GO
BACK TO. WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS
IN THE NEXT FEW BOTHER SO THANK
YOU THE SENATE LABOR FOR COME
ON DOWN. RIFIC THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS- AND I WISH I WAS ON
THE COMMITTEE TO VOTE FOR SB
THREE FORTY TWO. THAT'S A GREAT
BILL LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING IT
ON THE FLOOR. A MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR OUR HELP GIVE ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT TODAY.
FIRST MISTER CHAIR I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK YOU AND YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR YOUR HARD WORK ON
THIS BILL. AND I BELIEVE YOU
HELP MAKE IT A BETTER PROPOSAL.
I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ON PAGES
EIGHT AND NINE THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS. SB THREE SEVENTY TWO
ESTABLISHES THE MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE FLEET PURCHASING.
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. WHICH WILL
BE ADMINISTERED BY THE
CALIFORNIA POLLUTION CONTROL
FINANCING. AUTHORITY THIS BILL
WILL IN CONSULTATION WITH
STAKEHOLDERS. DESIGN NEW
FINANCING TOOLS TO HELP OWNERS
OF MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES. PURCHASE CLEANER ZERO
EMISSION ALTERNATIVES. AS MANY
OF YOU ARE AWARE OF MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS AND BUSES. OR
A MAJOR SOURCE OF AIR POLLUTION
IN CALIFORNIA. CONTRIBUTING TO
POOR AIR QUALITY AND NEGATIVE
RESPIRATORY HEALTH OUTCOMES.
THESE LOCAL AIR EMISSIONS HURT
THE HEALTH OF CALIFORNIANS.
ESPECIALLY THOSE IN UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
POPULATIONS. REPLACING THESE
VEHICLES WITH ELECTRONIC
ELECTRIC OR OTHER ZERO EMISSION
ALTERNATIVES IS NEEDED TO
REDUCE THE HARMFUL AIR
POLLUTION. THAT NEGATIVELY
IMPACTS PUBLIC HEALTH AND
WORSENS CLIMATE CHANGE.
CALIFORNIA'S CURRENT SOLUTION
FOR FINANCING THE TRANSITION TO
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES. HAS
BEEN VOUCHER OR GRANT PROGRAMS.
IN ORDER TO MEET THE DIVERSE
FINANCIAL NEEDS OF CURRENT AND
FUTURE FLEET OWNERS. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT THE STATE PUTS
MORE TOOLS IN THE TOOLBOX.
TRANSITIONING FLEET SHOULD BE
STRAIGHTFORWARD AND EQUITABLE
BOTH FOR THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
LIVE IN THE AREAS WITH HIGH
CONCENTRATIONS OF DIESEL
POLLUTION. EVER THE BUSINESS
OWNERS WHO MANAGE THESE
VEHICLES. THE INTENT OF THE
BILLS TO GET THE STATE TO THINK
CREATIVELY ABOUT HOW WE CAN
BEST LEVERAGE STATE FUNDS.
BRING IN PRIVATE CAPITAL AND
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
MAXIMIZE THE ABILITY FOR FLEETS
OF ALL SIZES. TO TRANSITION TO
ZERO EMISSION OPTIONS. AFTER
ALL THERE'S ONLY ONE AMAZON AND
WE KNOW THEY LIKE TO TOUT. THAT
THEY HAVE MANY ELECTRIC
VEHICLES BUT NOT EVERYONE IS AS
BIG AS AMAZON AND WE AS A STATE
CAN DO A BETTER JOB. TO HELP
SMALL AND MEDIUM SIZE
COMPANIES. SB THREE SEVENTY TWO
WILL ALSO CREATE A ONE STOP
SHOP WEBSITE. TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION ABOUT ALL OF THE
POTENTIAL FINANCING GRANT
OPTIONS AND OTHER TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. THAT IS AVAILABLE
TO HELP OBTAIN FINANCING FOR
THESE VEHICLES. BY CREATING
MORE OPTIONS THAT MAXIMIZE
CALIFORNIA'S AVAILABLE FUNDING
AND PRIORITIZE DEPLOYMENT. AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES SB
THREE SEVENTY TWO CAN ENSURE.
THAT ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
TRANSITIONS. IT TRANSITION AS A
VIABLE EQUITABLE AND BENEFUL
BENEFICIAL OPTION FOR DIFFERENT
SIZES AND TYPES OF FLEETS IN
COMMUNITIES. WITH ME TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT AS MICHAEL COLEMAN
WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE
FUND AND BILL MCGOVERN WITH THE
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR.
MEMBERS AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER ALRIGHT
LET'S NOW GO TO MCGARRY. WHO TO
SAW A LIMITED AS LAST WEEK.
MISTER COLIN IS GOING FIRST
OKAY- LET'S START LET'S START
WITH MISTER COLEMAN AND FROM
EDS. HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
MICHAEL HOLDEN WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND WE
ARE THE PROUD SPONSOR SENATE
BILL THREE SEVEN TWO. MEDIUM
AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLE MARKET
WHICH INCLUDES EVERYTHING FROM
SEMI TRUCKS AND DELIVERY VANS
TWO CITY BUSES AND GARBAGE
TRUCKS. IN TRANSMISSION IS IN
TRANSITION TO ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES. CONDITIONAL HAVE BEEN
OUTSIDE IMPACT ON OUR STATE'S
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
ESPECIALLY WHEN CONSIDERING
LOCAL AIR POLLUTION IN THE
HEATED HEALTH IMPROVEMENTS.
CALIFORNIA CANNOT TRANSFORM THE
MARKET YOU JUST BY USING PUBLIC
FUNDS IT IS TRYING TO BRING IN
PRIVATE CAPITAL TO GENERATE
LEVERAGE. SENATE BILL THREE
SEVEN TO EIGHTEEN THREE Q.
PRINTABLE. FIRST OF ITS
EMPLOYEES PUBLIC FUNDS NEEDED
NOTES BY CONCENTRATING PUBLIC
5% OF THE FUNDS DEPLOYED
CARBONE BOTH POPULATIONS.
SECOND IT DEVELOPS PRIVATE
INVESTMENT IN FINANCING OPTIONS
FOR ALL THREE HI THIS BY
CORRECTING THAT CALIFORNIA
POLLUTION CONTROL FINANCING
AUTHORITY. TO UTILIZE THEIR
EXISTING RELATIONSHIPS WITH
PRIVATE BANKING INSTITUTION AND
WITH THE TRUCKING INDUSTRY. WE
WILL BE A CRITICAL IMPLEMENTING
PARTNER. AND THIRD. IT TARGETS
A FULL SET OF RELEVANT TO THE
FULLY TRANSITION I MEAN THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
AND HE ADMINISTRATING HMP
AMENDED BY THE COMMITTEE. WILL
ENABLE THAT INTER AGENCY
COORDINATION AND DEVELOPMENT OF
A ONE STOP SHOP WEBSITE. DONE
RIGHT SENATE BILL THREE SEVEN
TWO WILL DELIVER CRITICAL FOR
AND ECONOMIC BENEFITS INCLUDING
PUBLIC HEALTH. DEUCE CLIMATE
POLLUTION LOWERED LIFECYCLE
COSTS FOR THE OPERATOR OF THE
VEHICLE. IN CONCLUSION I'D LIKE
TO THANK SENATOR LEYVA AND HER
STOP IN THERE CLEAR VISION AND
TIRELESS LEADERSHIP AND
ENCOURAGE- I ABOUT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LET'S GO OVER TO MR
MCGOVERN. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS BILL MCGOVERN WITH
THE COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE SEVENTY TWO
CALIFORNIA IS ON THE VERGE OF
THE TRANSFORMATIONAL CLEAN UP
OF THE TRUCKING SECTOR WE CAN
MOVE GOODS WITH OUT INFLICTING
TOXIC DIESEL EXHAUST ON OUR
COMMUNITIES. WE'RE STARTING TO
HAVE EMPLOYEES OR REGULATORY
FRAMEWORK FOR THAT TRANSITION
AND TO COMPLEMENT THAT
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE
FINANCING TOOLS AVAILABLE
PARTICULARLY FOR THE SMALLER
WEEDS THAT THIS BILL WOULD
FOCUS SUPPORT FOR. WERE ALSO
VERY HAPPY TO SEE THAT THE GOAL
IS TO GET AT LEAST 75% OF THE
SUPPORT TO UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES THAT MOST OFTEN
BEAR THE DISPROPORTIONATE
IMPACTS FROM THE ADVERSE
POLLUTION COMING FROM THE
MOVEMENT OF GOODS. AND WE ALSO
AGREE WITH THE PRIORITIZATION
OF PORT TRUCKS WHERE WE HAVE A
PARTICULAR CONCENTRATION OF
EXHAUST IN A REPORT COMMUNITIES
SO WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT TODAY
FOR SB. THREE SEVENTY TWO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT LET'S GO TO THE- I DON'T
SEE ON HERE I DON'T SEE ONE
TWENTY FORTY LET'S GO TO THE
PHONE LINE CIVIC CENTER ELSE
WANTS TO RAISE. I WANT TO VOICE
THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR IN SUPPORT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. WELL THE LINE OF TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY
THEY HUNG UP OVER LINE OF
SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR JONATHAN
CLAY ABOUT THE PORT OF SAN
DIEGO IN SUPPORT AND WE'D ALSO
LIKE TO THANK AUTHORED SPONSORS
FOR WORKING WITH US ON THE
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL. THANK YOU
FOR GO TO LINE OF FORTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
DAILY JEFF ON BEHALF OF CAL
START IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
WILL GO LINE OF SEVENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MENTIONED
OR AT LARGE- WITH THE CLIMATE
CENTER IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE OF FIFTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
DANIEL BROWN AND GAPS OF SHARE
CLUB CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE OF
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
MORNING WILL KRIEGER COURT
THREE FIFTY SACRAMENTO IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THE LINE OF
SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI DAVID CANTON ON BEHALF OF
THE LOS ANGELES CLEANTECH
INCUBATOR IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE OF SEVENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS JANET **** FOR THREE FIFTY
JORDAN VALLEY AND THREE FIFTY
BAY AREA ACTION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IS CONNECTS DOUBLE
LINE OF WHAT. WHAT LINE OF
TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING AMERICA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION BETTER.
REPORT DETAILS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NOW FOR
THE SUPPORT IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU THANK YOU AND
LET'S NOW GO AND SEE IF THERE'S
ANY- OPPOSITION I DON'T BELIEVE
WE HAVE A LEAD OPPOSITION IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINES
I DON'T SEE ON HERE IN PERSON
OR IN ROOM TWENTY. FORTY AS
WITHIN ONE OF THE PHONE LINES
WHO. WANT TO RAISE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BILL. THANK YOU IF
YOU'RE NOT PHYSICIAN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE SEVENTY
TWO. AND WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME MISTER
CARE ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU WELL
THIS IS GREAT LET'S LET'S OPEN
UP THE CONVERSATION TO THE
COMMITTEE A QUESTION SPOTS I
SEE CENTER GONZALEZ. I JUST
WANNA SAY THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I KNOW WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT EV'S IN MANY
DIFFERENT SPACES THE LIGHT THE
HEAVY DUTY- BUT I THINK THE
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY IS THE
SPACE WHERE WE NEED TO GET
AHEAD OF IT SO I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR- FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND- I KNOW THAT THE
ANALYSIS CALLED OUT. JUST THAT
DIFFERENT- YOU KNOW JUST TO
ENSURE THAT THERE'S NOT
REDUNDANCIES AND SO- YOU KNOW I
KNOW WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THAT AND I WOULD BE HAPPY TO
WORK WTH YOU AS WELL VERY
CLOSE AND THAT'S IT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SNATOR GONZALEZ WE
ARE NOT LOOKING TO BE REDUNDANT
WE ARE HOPING THAT THIS WILL
EXPAND THE TOOLBOX THAT IS
AVAILABLE TO SMALL AND LIGHT
DUTY MEDIUM DUTY TRUCKS THANK
YOU AND WE WOULD LOVE TO WORK
WITH YOU AS WELL. I SEE A VICE
CHAIR. DILLON YES THANK YOU.
SENESCHAL LEYVA A COUPLE QUICK
QUESTIONS ON THE WAY I READ THE
BILL YOU'RE NOT EXCLUDING THE
OTHERS THEY OF TECHNOLOGIES SO
IT'S NOT JUST ELECTRIC IF THAT
WRAPPED BECAUSE THERE'S A
QUESTION AND ANALYSIS ABOUT
COUNCIL THAT'S GOOD AND THEN IN
TERMS OF THE FUNDING THAT WOULD
JOB CAP AND TRADE MANY BE
AVAILABLE. WOULD WOULD HAVE
QUALIFIED FOR THIS ALSO YEAH
SEEKING FUNDING FOR A LOT OF
THIS IS WHERE I THINK WE HAVE
START FOCUSING SO WE GET THE
BEST OUR- BEST FOR A BUCK IF
THEY SAY YES WE ARE LOOKING TO
USE ALL RESOURCES SO CAP AND
TRADE COULD BE PART OF IT THEIR
PRIVATE FINANCING. ONE THING
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT IS
SOMETHING CALLED STACKING WHERE
A COMPANY COULD USE ALL GET A
LITTLE BIT OF MONEY FROM
DIFFERENT SOURCES I THINK THE
ONE STOP SHOP IS WHAT MAKES
THIS BILL SO UNIQUE AND HELPFUL
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT SO MANY
COMPANIES THEY DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO HIRE SOMEONE TO
FIND THIS. THIS WILL GIVE THEM
THE ABILITY TO FIND THE
RESOURCES SO THAT THEY TOO CAN
DO THE RIGHT THING. AND THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT OUR- WE SHOULD THE BILL
AND- I APPRECIATE GONZALEZ SAYS
THE MOTION FOR THE BILL. AND
WITH THAT LET YOU CLOSE CENTER.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NAY VOTE
RATE HAS ACTUALLY PLEASE
CALDERON. I ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB
THREE SEVENTY TWO BY SENATOR
LEYVA THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION ALLEN HI I BATES
FIVE EIGHT FIVE DALY. GONZALEZ
I WAS HI SKINNER STERN WHAT
KASKY. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR OTHER
MEMBERS THAT ON BUT THANK YOU
CENTER. MEMBERS APPRECIATE YOU
AND I AND I BELIEVE I SAW
CENTER WIENER HERE. TO PRESENT
SB TWO SIXTY THIS IS A CRIME
COURT CORPORATE ACCOUNTABILITY
ACT. YOU MAY PRESS THE DAYS
WHEN READY CENTER. I REMEMBER
THIS ITEM SIX IN YOUR FOLDERS.
BUT I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
FOLKS THAT UNDERSTAND THAT
NORMALLY WOULD HAVE CENTER
NEWMAN. SEND HIS BILL SB TWO
EIGHTY NINE HE'S DELAYED PLEASE
ANOTHER COMMITTEE. WE'LL GO
WE'LL WE'LL START WITH YOU
CENTER WIENER. GREAT TWO NINETY
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN- I FIRST WANT TO START
MISTER CHAIRMAN BY THANKING YOU
AND YOUR COMMITTEE STAFFER
WORKING VERY VERY HARD AND
DILIGENTLY WITH US ON THIS
BILL- AND DOGS IS EXTREMELY
APPRECIATIVE THAT WE'RE HAPPY
TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES ARE
VERY HELPFUL MOMENTS SO THANK
YOU- COLLEAGUES ARE SENATE BILL
TWO SIXTY OF THE CLIMATE
CORPORATE ACCOUNTABILITY ACT
WILL REQUIRE ALL UACS US BASED-
COMPANIES BOTH PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE. WITH OVER ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IN ANNUAL REVENUE WHO
DO BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA TO
REPORT THEIR FULL CARBON
FOOTPRINT. BOB WITH THE TO
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
AFTER THIS DISCLOSURE BOB KARP
WILL BE REQUIRED TO PROVIDE- TO
PROVIDE AN EXCUSE ME A REPORT
ON THESE ENTITIES TO WHICH WILL
INCLUDE REASONABLE ESTIMATES
ARE FOR THE LEVEL OF REDUCED
EMISSIONS REQUIRED. SO THAT WE-
IN CALIFORNIA AND THESE
CORPORATIONS ALIGNED WITH THE
ONE POINT FIVE DEGREES CELSIUS
OF WARMING MAXIMUM- BEYOND PRE
INDUSTRIAL LEVELS- THAT WE
BELIEVE IS NECESSARY TO AVOID A
CLIMATE DISASTER. BY INCLUDING
RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW TO
EFFECTIVELY REDUCE- TO THAT
LEVEL TO THE ONE POINT FIVE
DEGREES CELSIUS AS WELL AS
REASONABLE ESTIMATES FOR TWENTY
THIRTY AT TWENTY FORTY FIVE
EMISSIONS LEVELS THE
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE AND CLEAN
ENERGY GOALS ARE MET. SB TWO
SIXTY IS A NECESSARY A BOLD
STEP FORWARD TO ENSURE THAT WE
NOT ONLY HIT OUR CURRENT
CLIMATE GOALS- BUT HAVE THE
NECESSARY DATA AND INFORMATION
TO SET NEW STANDARDS AND GOALS.
ARE YOU CAN'T REGULATE WHAT YOU
DON'T KNOW AND AS THE STATE
CONTINUES TO CURB ITS EMISSIONS
ACROSS SECTORS- WE HAVE- A WILL
HAVE A CLEARER AND CLEARER IDEA
OF WHAT WORK IS REMAINING AND
WHAT ACTION NEEDS TO BE TAKEN
TO CONTINUE PROGRESS. HOWEVER
THE SAME CAN'T BE SAID OF THE
PRIVATE SECTOR I CURRENTLY
EMISSIONS REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS ARE LIMITED TO
LARGE POINT SOURCE THE MENTORS
LEAVING OUT BASS SWATHS OF
CORPORATE EMISSIONS SOME
COMPANIES TO VOLUNTARILY REPORT
VOLUNTARILY REPORT SOME OF
THEIR EMISSIONS- SOME OF THEM
BUT VERY FEW REPORT ALL OF
THEIR EMISSIONS- BUT IT'S
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT. TO BE
CERTAIN OF REPORTS VALIDITY.
MANY CORPORATION ONLY. PARTIAL
CARBON FOOTPRINT REPORTS OF THE
PUBLIC. WORKS SECTION OFF PARTS
OF THEIR OPERATIONS TO DISPLAY
TO THE PUBLIC WHILE NOT
DISCLOSING OTHER PARTS THE LACK
OF VERIFICATION AND UNIFORMITY
ALLOWS FOR MANIPULATION AND
FRANKLY MISREPRESENTATION OF
DATA. AND CAN LEAD TO
GREENWASHING. OUR CUSTOMERS AND
POLICYMAKERS ARE LEFT WITH NO
FURTHER INFORMATION BEYOND THE
PUBLIC FACADE PUT OUT IN TERMS
OF MARKETING BY A COMPANY
BACKED EMISSIONS DISCLOSURE
ANOTHER WITH A COMPANY COOPER
TRADE ITSELF. AS BEING
EXCEPTIONALLY GREEN. ONE BIG
SWATHS OF THE COMPANY'S
OPERATIONS AND SUPPLY CHAIN ARE
INCREDIBLY CARBON INTENSIVE AND
INCREDIBLY DAMAGING IN TERMS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE. COMPANIES
CONTINUE TO SET AND ACHIEVE
AMBITIOUS CLIMATE GOALS FOR
THEMSELVES BUT WITHOUT FULL
TRANSPARENCY. WITHOUT
VERIFICATION OF THE DATA
WITHOUT PUBLIC DOCUMENTATION
THEIR EMISSIONS WITHOUT ALL
THAT HOW CAN WE BE SURE THAT
THEIR CLAIMS ARE ACCURATE. SB
TWO SIXTY WILL ALLOW FOR THAT
MUCH NEEDED TRANSPARENCY BY
REQUIRING FULL DISCLOSURE. OF
THREE SCOPES OF EMISSIONS
COVERED FROM ALL COVERED
ENTITIES. THIS MEANS COMPANIES
MUST DISCLOSE DIRECT EMISSIONS
FROM THEIR CORE OPERATIONAL
ACTIVITIES. EMISSIONS FROM
THEIR ELECTRICITY AND OTHER
POWER USAGE AN INDIRECT
EMISSIONS FROM THEIR SUPPLY
CHAIN WATER USAGE EMPLOYEE
COMMUTES AND OTHER SOURCES.
SHINING A LIGHT ON TO THE WORLD
OF CORPORATE EMISSIONS
REPORTING WILL ENSURE THAT
THOSE WHO ARE CORRECTLY
REPORTING WHAT MINIMAL WORK TO
BE ALIGNED WITH US TO TWO
SIXTY. PUBLIC SUPPOSED THAT THE
COMPANIES THAT ARE USING
UNREGULATED. EMISSIONS
DISCLOSURES BAD FAITH THAT I
WANT TO BE CLEAR WE'RE NOT
TRYING FOR THE COMPANIES THAT
ARE ALREADY DOING REPORTING
CRITICISM ESTABLISH AREA.
CARBON REPORTING- THIS BILL
SHOULD NOT CREATE EXTRA WORK
THEY'RE ALREADY DOING IT AND
WHAT. THEY'RE ALREADY DOING
SHUFFLED AND- TO THIS.
REPORTING THE FULL SCOPE OF A
MEASURE HAS RECOGNIZED AS A
NECESSITY FOR PROPERLY REDUCING
EMISSIONS AND AS SUCH
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS THE WORLD
RESOURCES INSTITUTE HAVE
DEVELOPED THE GREENHOUSE GAS
PROTOCOLS TO HELP ENTITIES
PROPERLY REPORT THE STANDARDS
ARE OFTEN PAIRED ALONGSIDE
SIMILAR GLOBALLY RECOGNIZED
METHODOLOGY FOR SETTING
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS TARGETS
ALTHOUGH SB TWO SIXTY WILL
CERTAINLY PUSH MANY COMPANIES
INTO NEW TERRITORY. THIS BILL
WILL NOT REINVENT THE WHEEL
RESURRECTING CARP TO CONSOLE
AND CONSIDER THE GUIDELINES AND
PROTOCOLS- THAT HAVE ALREADY
BEEN ESTABLISHED CARDS FOCUS
HERE ONCE COMPANIES ARE IN
COMPLIANCE AND REPORTING SHOULD
BE TO ACTIVELY MAINTAIN AND
UPDATE OUR PUBLIC FACING
WEBSITE DETAILING THESE REPORTS.
SB TWO SIXTY THROUGH CARP WILL
ALLOW FOR CONSUMERS TO HAVE A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF THE
IMPACT OF THE HOUSEHOLD BRANDS
AND BIG COMPANIES SAY NO. TO
KNOW WHAT THE CARBON FOOTPRINT
IS. IT WILL PROVIDE THE ABILITY
TO MAKE A DECISION BETWEEN ONE
PRODUCT AND ANOTHER AS
MANUFACTURERS EMISSIONS WILL BE
DISPLAYED AND EASILY VIEWED.
ONLINE I MOST OF ALL ALLOW
CONSUMERS TO SEE WHICH
CORPORATIONS ARE ACTUALLY
MAKING PROGRESS WHICH ARE
PUTTING THEIR MONEY WHERE THEIR
MOUTH IS AND WHICH ARE CAUSING
CALIFORNIA TO LAGGED BEHIND
EMISSION REDUCTIONS. SB TWO
SIXTY IS THE NEXT NECESSARY
STEP IN CALIFORNIA MUST TAKE ON
CLIMATE TO ENSURE THE CORPORATE
ACTORS IN OUR STATE- ARE
ALIGNED AND WORKING AS
DILIGENTLY AS WE NEED THEM TO
BE. WE NO LONGER HAVE THE
LUXURY OF TIME TO ALLOW
CORPORATIONS TO WORK BEHIND AN
OPAQUE CURTAIN EMITTING MORE
AND MORE CARBON WHILE PROMISING
US CHANGE- AND WHILE THE WORLD
BURNS SB TWO SIXTY PULLS BACK
THE CURTAIN AND SHINES A
FLOODLIGHT. ON ANY AND ALL
POTENTIAL BAD ACTORS AND ALSO
THOSE THAT ARE DOING A GREAT
JOB COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. WITH ME
TODAY ARE COUPON ON NARLIKAR
CLIMATE ACTIVISTS AND NINTH
GRADE STUDENTS AND SAN
FRANCISCO AND KATHARINE OGDEN
DIRECTOR. OF CARBON ACCOUNTABLE.
ALL RIGHT LET'S GO TO YOUR
LEAVING THIS IS. THANK YOU
COMMITTEE CHAIR ALLEN AND
SENATORS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY I'M CATHERINE ACT
INDIRECT AND DIRECT THREAT
CARBON ACCOUNTABLE IT CROWD
BECAUSE BONTA SB TWO SIXTY
ALONG THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS AND PLANNED
RIGHTS BAY AREA. CALIFORNIA HAS
A LONG AND PROUD HISTORY OF
ENVIRONMENTAL AND CLIMATE
LEADERSHIP SB TWO SIXTY THE
CRITICAL NEXT STEP THAT WILL
DRIVE PRIVATE SECTOR GHG
EMISSION REDUCTIONS. THAT ARE
NEEDED TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA
AND ITS RESIDENTS INCLUDING BY
PARK COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
CLIMATE CHANGE. REQUIRING
BILLION DOLLAR BUSINESSES
BENEFITTING FROM THE LARGESSE
OF CALIFORNIA TO MAKE DATA
ABOUT THEIR GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS PUBLICLY AVAILABLE
WILL ADDRESS THE CERES DATA GET
GAPS THAT EXIST GIVEN SPOTTY
AND NON PUBLIC VOLUNTARY
REPORTING IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
WE HAVE LEARNED THROUGH THE
CODEPENDENT THAT RELIABLE
COMPREHENSIVE DATA IS ESSENTIAL
TOOL IN DRIVING SMART ACTION.
INFORMATION ON THE COMPANY'S
GHG EMISSIONS IS NO LONGER A
NICE TO HAVE A CRITICAL COMPANY
DATA THE CONSUMERS INVESTORS
AND POLICY MAKERS NEED TO
INFORM THEIR CHOICES- AND
CLIMATE ACTIONS. THE GOOD NEWS
IS THAT SB TWO SIXTEEN
CONNOTATION BENEFITS FROM TWO
DECADES OF EXPERIENCE
DOMESTICALLY AND
INTERNATIONALLY AND USING
GLOBALLY RECOGNIZED STANDARDS
LIKE THE GHG PROTOCOL TO CREATE
POLITICAL CONDITIONS PROBE.
THIS INCLUDES SUPPLY CHAIN
EMISSIONS DATA WHICH ARE MORE
THAN TEN TIMES HIGHER THAN
OPERATIONAL MISSIONS MANY OF
THE LARGEST CORPORATIONS ARE
ALREADY DOING IT AND ARE
EXPERIENCING STRONG RESULTS
FROM THE ENGAGE WITH THEIR
SUPPLY CHAINS. THE ACT INSURERS
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS. HAVE
ACCESS TO THIS CRITICAL
INFORMATION WITH THE CREATION
OF A PUBLIC FACING DIGITAL
PLATFORM THAT WILL SHARE
COLLECTED DATA INACCESSIBLE
MANNER. SB TWO SIXTY ALSO
DIRECTS THE STATE BOARD TO
ISSUE A PUBLIC REPORT ON
COMPANIES EMISSIONS
TRAJECTORIES. IN A WAY THAT
WILL CATALYZE SCIENCE BASED
TARGETS ADDING IN LINE WITH THE
ONE POINT FIVE TO THE FUTURE.
WITH SB TWO SIXTY CALIFORNIA
HAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ACCELERATE GHG REDUCTIONS FOR
THE BENEFIT OF THE STATE IT'S
RESIDENTS AND PEOPLE EVERYWHERE
IT'S FOR THIS. REASON THAT WE
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL. THANK YOU. WE'RE GOING
TO- KAPAN IN OUR THE CARCASS.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
HELLO. YES WE CAN HEAR YOU I'M
CLEAR. OKAY. HI MY NAME IS
CALLED AN ARTICLE AND A HIGH
SCHOOLER AND A NUMBER OF
TONIGHT BAY AREA I'VE DIRECTED
A LOT OF MY FOCUSED TO THE
CLIMATE CRISIS AND WHAT IS
NECESSARY TO ENSURE THAT THE
FUTURE I WILL BE STEPPING INTO
A BILLABLE ONE I KNOW THAT IN
ORDER FOR MY GENERATION TO HAVE
A LIVABLE FUTURE WE NEED
TRANSPARENCY AND COORDINATED
ACTION BETWEEN CORPORATIONS AND-
CORPORATION. ARE THE LARGEST
CONTRIBUTORS TO GLOBAL
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
CLIMATE CHANGE. HOWEVER THE JOB
OF COAL AND LARGE CORPORATIONS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THEIR ROLE IN
THE CLIMATE CRISIS LARGELY
GOING LEFT TO THE CORPORATION
FROM ABOUT. MANY LARGE
CORPORATIONS HAVE STEPPED UP
AND MADE EFFORTS TO TRACK AND
REDUCE THEIR MISSION. MANY HAVE
NOT CURRENTLY WE ARE NOT SEEING
THE NECESSARY ACCOUNTABILITY.
THERE IS THE CORPORATIONS ARE
NOT REQUIRED TO MEASURE OR
REDUCE THEIR EMISSIONS AT ALL.
WE CAN ONLY UNIFORMLY ENSURE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR ALL LARGE
CORPORATIONS BY LEGALLY
REQUIRING TRANSPARENCY AND
ACTION. SB THREE SIXTY DOES
EXACTLY THAT. PUBLIC RECORDING
OF CORPORATE EMISSIONS WILL
COURTNEY OUR CORE IN THE
REDUCTION EFFORT. OVER THE PAST
TWENTY YEARS THERE HAVE BEEN A
PROGRESSIVE
INSTITUTIONALIZATION OF
TRANSPARENCY AND ENACTMENT OF
INTERNATIONAL STANDARDS AND
CORPORATE EMISSIONS ACCORDING.
TO GLOBAL REPORTING INITIATIVE
AND CARBON DISCLOSURE PROJECT
ESTABLISHED THAT INFRASTRUCTURE
OVER THE LAST DECADE THE
ENVIRONMENT SOCIAL AND
GOVERNMENT GOVERNANCE MOVEMENT
AMONG INVESTORS DROVE
COMPLIANCE I'M SO SORRY ALL.
WE'RE RUNNING UP AGAINST THE
TIME FOR THIS THE LEAD WITH A
SO IF YOU COULD JUST DRIVE UP
WITH. OUR YES. A LITTLE MINI
COOPER. ARE ALREADY. OR HONOR-
THE CHANGE BEEN ABLE BAKER.
TRAIN IN FIFTEEN. CRACK IN THE
MISSION. TRACK TECHNOLOGIES I
THINK IT'S- WILL GOING TO
TRANSFER. ACCORDING TO OUR
BETWEEN. FOR THE. I'M THE KIND
CRISIS STRENGTHEN. SOPH I'M
GIVEN THE TIME CONSTRAINTS OR
UNDER BUT- LET LET'S LET'S OVER
THE PHONE LINES TO SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR OR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN THE BUREAU.
WE WILL GO TO LINE OF TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MORNING ONE HOUR THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION VOTERS. BONSER
AFFECTED YOU SIXTY AND NOW WE
ARE HOLDING. HI WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL ALLIANCE OF
NURSE FOR HEALTH BAYERN OUT OF
ONE CALIFORNIA. CREDIT WE ALLEN
CAN BE THEY CHAPTER COURAGE
CALIFORNIA. UNDERSUPPLY ELDERS
CLIMATE ACTION NOR CAL INFO
CHAPTER. ENVIRONMENT AND FIND
THANKS COMMITTEE ON THE
LEGISLATURE HELLO. RENDON
HARPER DID YOU CAN PARK
FRIENDLY- THE LAST. GREEN BELT
LINE. NATIONAL PARK. AT THE-
MOTORHOME RECYCLE FIFTY.
SACRAMENTO IS CON. TOGETHER THE
BIG. THANK OUR SHORES. SURVEY
AND GENERATION OF VERY
COMPELLING CORNIA. INVALID YOU
ACTION THE FIVE JARED. THE
CENTER FOR OCEANIC. RESEARCH
EDUCATION. THE CLIENT. WHICH
YOU CAN. YOU GREEN CALLED.
MEETING IN A COMBINED FIND.
JAMIE COUNTY HAPPENED
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ONE NEXT IN LINE- EIGHTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BILL
MCGOVERN COALITION FOR CLEAN
AIR IN SUPPORT. YOU NEXT IN THE
LINE OF SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. FIND SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. OR BOTH THE LINE OF
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
MY NAME IS. DID YOU EVER AND
TODAY I'M REPRESENTING CARE OF
THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR
RETIRED AMERICANS. SB SIXTY.
THE CORPORATION CLIMATE CALGARY
ACT THIS TIME THE VIDEO
CORPORATIONS TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY. VERY IMPACT ON
OUR ENVIRONMENT TO DEVELOP LAND
REDUCE THE CARBON INPUT I'M SO
SORRY ON A BILL FOR IT YEAH.
YEAH SO SORRY WE'RE JUST ASKING
PEOPLE TO JUST GIVE THEIR-
THEIR NAME AFFILIATION. THANK
YOU LINE EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. JANET **** RESURGENT
TELECOM BALLY IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU THANKS THE GOAL LINE OF
TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE BANK WITH THE CLIMATE
REALITY PROJECT AREA IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. X. OF A LINE OF
THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO TO WEAR SOME RIGHT
CLAREMONT COLLEGES IN SUPPORT.
IF WELL LINE OF TWENTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE FIRST OF
YOUR FRIENDS BEGIN BEHALF OF AS
YOU SHOP I DO SALAS SHAREHOLDER
REPRESENTATIVE GROUP AND MEMBER
OF CRIME ACTION ONE HUNDRED AND
WE SUPPORT THE MEASURE FOURTH
AT THE TWO SIXTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. FIND FORTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BEFORE. AND
I SEE NO FURTHER UP THE- THE
PORTANTINO AT THE TIME. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. LET'S NOW TURN TO
OPPOSITION WITH MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE HAVE.
LEAD OPPOSITION IS LEAH LEAH
SILVERTHORNE FROM THE CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE IS SAM MISSILE
RETURN OF. RATING AVAILABLE
ONLINE. GO AHEAD PLEASE. THE
MORNING AFTER HEARING MEMBERS
WITH REGARD WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND YOU'RE
ALL AWARE TALKING REPRESENTS
INTERESTS OF OVER FOURTEEN
THOUSAND LARGE MEDIUM AND SMALL
BUSINESSES ACROSS CALIFORNIA
OKAY REMEMBER THEIR COMMITTED
TO DOING THEIR PART TO ADDRESS
CONCRETE AS WE CONTINUE TO THE
NEW COMPANY VOLUNTARILY COMMIT
TO TRACKING AND AUDITING
MISSION DATA ARE CRACKING LONG
TERM GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
GOALS WORK EITHER ALL THAT SAID
IT IS EASIER VERY FOR SOME. FOR
OTHERS AND THE ABILITY COST
ECONOMIC IMPACT DIFFERENT
SECTORS WIDELY WHICH IS WHY YOU
SEE COMPANIES IN VARIOUS STAGES
OF ANALYSIS. TRACKING ANGLE.
OKAY RESPECTFULLY THE PUT THE
BILL OF THE- DATA AFTER. THAT
WILL BURN IN HELL THANK. MARCH
SMALL THE BILL BECAUSE YOU'RE
CREATING A- NEW AND VERY VERY
LARGE DIVISION WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA RESOURCES BOARD
ORDER TO ROUTE ALL AND A WEB.
EACH MISSION. I CAN THAT
MISSION. DATA NOT THAT BY THE
LARGE COMPANY OBJECTED THAT
THEY'LL COLLECTING SCOPE THREE
EMISSIONS ALSO REQUIRES THAT
THOSE LARGE COMPANIES IMPOSE
UPON THEIR ENTIRE SUPPLY CHAIN
WE HAVE A SMALL MEDIUM AT. A
DUTY TO ANALYZE TRACK AND
REPORT TO THEM EMISSIONS DATA
THE BROADWAY WHICH EXCEEDED THE
KEEP TRACK IT MEANS THAT
THERE'S NO WAY CANNOT IMPACTS.
WHILE MEDIAN. I JANE MANY OF
THEM ARE LEFT THREE. RESOURCE
AND WE BEAR THE- OF THE COST
YOUR CONTRACT BUDGET. IN A
DIFFERENT IN A THE BILL DOES.
NOT SEEM TO BE A TO SOMEWHAT
RECREATE THE WHEEL. INSTEAD OF
USING THE TERM NOTED BY THE
COMEDIC THEIR ARE YOU BEING
USED AT THE NATIONAL AND
THEY'RE NOT LEVEL BASIC OF THE
NAY TRACK. THE BILL WOULD
CREATE A NEW A- GROUP.
CARPENTRY NEW TO. FOR EVEN MORE
COMPANIES HAVE ALREADY BEGAN
TRACK SKILLS WANTED SCOPE TO
DATA ENTERING THE PROCESS OF
THE- STILL THREE MISSION. WHICH
ARE CURRENTLY NOT BAD IN A G.
H. CAN CALL AND FIND TARGET. IN
ACCORDANCE WITH THE CURRENT
RECORD SB TWO SIX WILL REQUIRE
THEM TO MAKE. THE BIG CHANGES.
THEY'RE NOT OF VERY CONSISTENT
WITH THE INTERNATIONAL
STANDARDS. THE STANDARD EVEN.
THE ENTERED AT THE INTERNET REP.
LEVEL DO RECOGNIZE THE TRACK
ANGLE IS NOT A ONE I FITS ALL.
THAT THE DOCTOR. PUT MINIMUM
THE BILL SHOULD BE REFERRED TO
CREEK THE WITH THE. NASH GUARD.
BANK INVESTED WITH THE RIGHT.
THAT G. H. EMISSIONS AN
INTERNET. ISSUE DR WE
CALIFORNIA ONE AN ISSUE NOT A
BINDER. COMMITTEE NOW AFTER.
ARE THESE. THAT YOU RESUME.
EARLIER DO WE OFTEN IN THE- BUT
WE DO LOOK. THE AND PROJECT
INCLUDING CONTINUED WILLINGNESS
TO WORK WITH US TO THE ISSUE.
THANK. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR RITTER. OKAY I DON'T
SEE ANYONE ELSE HERE IN I IN
PERSON OR IN RE TWENTY FOUR- TO
VOICE UP- THE MODERATOR DO YOU
WANT TO GO WITH GO TO THE PHONE
LINES AND- C. YOU MAY WANNA ADD
A AN OFFICE. OR IS CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BILL ON THE PHONE.
THANK YOU HAVE YOU'RE NOT BUSY
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT THEN THERE.
WE WILL GO TO LINE OF NINETY
YEAR IS- OPEN. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS JUSTIN HIGHER FROM
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
AND WE MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
THE BILL FOR THE REASONS
OUTLINED IN OUR LETTER THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU X. ALIGN
OF TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING THE COOKING
ON BEHALF OF THE HOUSEHOLD AND
COMMERCIAL PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT TO CAROLINA WON
A ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS TRUDIE HUGHES
OF THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE AT THE
PRODUCERS REPRESENTING COULD
PROCESSING AND OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL ROBBERY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT TO WILL LINE UP
BY EIGHTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS A LARGE
GAME ROOM YOU HAVE TO
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION OF
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL FOR THE READING LIST.
THANK YOU AND ACCESSIBLE LINE
OF EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE CARD FOR THE WESTERN STATES
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BALL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AN EXTRA GOAL
LINE OF NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU GUYS VERY
TAILORED TO PERSONAL INSURANCE
FEDERATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ANEXO GOAL LINE
OF NINETY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING JOHN MOFFETT
ON BEHALF OF THE ALLIANCE FOR
AUTOMOTIVE INNOVATION IN
OPPOSITION PROLIFERATION STATED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT OF A
LINE OF NINETY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS TRICIA GERINGER WITH
AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL CALIFORNIA
ALSO RESPECTIVELY IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER OPPOSITION IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME MISTER
CHAIR. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO
MUCH. PART LET'S BRING THE
COMMITTEE BACK BUT SPRING THE
BILL BACK TO COMMITTEE-
THOUGHTS QUESTIONS ABOUT
INVESTOR. A YEAR FOR A QUESTION
FOR A SENATOR WIENER AND YOU
INDICATED THAT THE BILL ONLY A
PATH IMPACTS LARGEST OF
BUSINESSES. HOWEVER I THINK ALL
THE- REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
CALCHAMBER ACTUALLY RAISE THE
ISSUE REGARDING THE MEDIUM AND
SMALL BUSINESSES THAT ARE PART
OF THE OF SUPPLY CHAIN OF THE
BIGGER BUSINESSES AND- CAP AND
TRADE IN TWENTY SIXTEEN DID
BUILDING PROTECTIONS. OF
SIMILAR NATURE FOR THE SMALL
AND MEDIUM BUSINESSES AND-
HELLO R. HOW IS YOUR BILL OR
ANY AMENDMENT SHOULD BE WILLING
TO TAKE. PART TO PROTECT THE
SMALL AND MEDIUM BUSINESSES
FROM THE IMPACTS OF THIS BILL
COULD HAVE ON THEM BECAUSE
THEIR WAY DOWN THE LINE AND
YET. THE BIGGER A CORPORATE
ENTITY IS GOING TO HAVE TO
INCLUDE THEM IN THEIR REPORT.
YET IT WAS JUST TO BE CLEAR IN
TERMS OF THE OBLIGATIONS OF THE
BILL BEING TO PUT TOGETHER ALL
OF YOUR DATA FROM ALL ASPECTS
OF YOUR OPERATIONS- TO WORK
WITH TO HAVE THAT AUDITED. TO
WORK WITH KERR. ON THOSE-
THAT'S THE MECHANICS OF THE
BILL THAT APPLIES IF IT REVENUE
OF A BILLION DOLLARS OR MORE
PER YEAR- YOU'RE CORRECT THAT
IT COULD THAT IF- IF A BILLION
PLUS DOLLAR CORPORATION IS
WORKING. AS ONE OF THE SUPPLY
CHAIN PROVIDERS FOR EXAMPLE IS
SMALLER THEY WILL HAVE TO
COLLECT INFORMATION. FROM THAT
SUPPLY CHAIN OPERATOR- BUT THAT
SUPPLY CHAIN OPERATOR IF
THEY'RE SMALLER DOES NOT HAVE
TO GO THROUGH THE
ADMINISTRATIVE STAFFS ARE
PUTTING TOGETHER THEIR ENTIRE.
FOOTPRINT OF BEING AUDITED IT
CETERA- AND YOU KNOW THE ANYA
REFERRING TO ITS SCOPE THREE-
WHICH IS A SUPPLY CHAIN AMONG
OTHER THINGS BUT PRIMARILY
BECAUSE MY JAM. THAT IS A VERY
IMPORTANT PART OF THE BILL IN
THE ANALYSIS ACTUALLY DID AN
EXELLENT JOB- EXPLAINING WHY-
IT'S AN IMPORTANT PART OF THE
BILL. BECAUSE IF YOU DON'T HAVE
THE SCOPE THREE SUPPLY. CHAIN
AT ALL- ASPECTS INCLUDE. A
COMPANY CAN BASIC. CON OUT ITS
CURRENT BOOK FOR. AND HAVE IT'S
HIS CALL. ACTUALLY BE THE
CARBON FOOTPRINT AND THE
COMPANY ITSELF LOOKS VERY PURE
AND GREEN- BUT MEANWHILE THE
RELYING ON SUPPLIERS. WHO ARE
BURNING COAL OR DOING-
WHATEVER- SO OBVIOUSLY WE WANT
THE COMPANIES WILL HAVE TO WORK
WITH THEIR SUPPLIERS- TO DO
THAT BUT WE DO THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THE BILL. I
JUST THINK THE AMOUNT OF
OPPOSITION ON A COUPLE OF THOSE
ISSUES SO CENTER TO WINNER AND
I UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW WHERE YOU
WANT TO GO AND VERY VERY
IMPORTANT OBVIOUSLY CONCEPT
BUT- I THINK IT NEEDS A LOT OF
WORK IN TERMS OF THE
PROTECTIONS THAT SHOULD BE
THERE FOR THAT KIND OF DATA
COLLECTION YOU'RE PUTTING ON
THE BACKS OF. SMALL AND MEDIUM
IN PARTICULAR SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT THAT WILL BE PART OF AN
OVERALL WILL BE IMPACTED BY ANY
OVERALL- MISINFORMATION THAT'S
PROVIDED YOUR DATA THAT'S NOT
ACCURATE. SO AB I DON'T THINK I
CAN SUPPORT IT TODAY BUT THAT
DOESN'T MEAN I DON'T THINK
YOU'RE HEADED IN THE DIRECTION
TRY TO GET THIS ALL INTO PLACE
SO WE CAN MAKE SOME BETTER
POLICY- AND I. APPRECIATE THAT
I JUST WANNA- THAT YOU KNOW
THIS BILL OF COURSE. DOESN'T
REQUIRE THE COMPANIES. TO
CHANGE THEIR CARBON FOOTPRINT
REYES THOUGHT BACK TYPE OF
REGULATION. OF A RECESSION YOU
MUST DO THESE THINGS. IT SIMPLY
INFORMATION AND DATA
TRANSPARENCY ON OF COURSE IF
THERE ARE SPECIFIC IDEAS. ABOUT
ABOUT WAYS TO. HELP SMALL
BUSINESSES WHO MIGHT BE PART OF.
IN THE SUPPLY CHAIN. WE'RE
ALWAYS WILLING TO TAKE A LOOK
AT IDEAS THAT PEOPLE HAVE.
THANK YOU. I SET OUT. WHEN THEY-
SORRY SORRY FOR BEING INTO
COMMITTEES AT THE SAME TIME I
WANT TO MAKE SURE AND TALK
ABOUT THE RIVER THIS IS A- THIS
IS THE- CALCULATION OF.
CORPORATE AND RIGHT SO THIS IS
EMISSIONS A LOT A LOT SO I
WANTED TO ASK THE- SENATOR. THE
TRICKLE DOWN EFFECT ME I THINK
IS SOMETHING I WANTED SOME
CLARIFICATION ON SO LET'S SAY
THAT THEY'RE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
FOR THEIR- AMOUNT OF- CARBON
THE MIRROR THEIR THEIR- THEIR-
REPORTING. AND THEY HAVE
SUPPLIERS THAT ARE SUPPLYING TO
THEM. THEY'RE GONNA BE
OBVIOUSLY PUSHING DOWN ON THOSE
TO ASK THEM WHAT THEY'RE
REPORTING ARE SO LET'S TAKE FOR
EXAMPLE. MY COMPANY I PRODUCE
SEED FOR OTHER FARMERS- AND IT
GOES UP THE SUPPLY CHAIN AND
NURSE. IT COULD BE. IT COULD GO
TO ARCHER DANIEL MIDLANDS WHICH
IS A BILLION DOLLAR.
CORPORATION AND THEN THEY WOULD
REQUIRE ME TO DO THIS WORK SO
THAT THEY CAN REDO THE
REPORTING AND SO THE TRICKLE
DOWN EFFECT WOULD ACTUALLY
IMPACT EVERY BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT DOES BUSINESS
WITH. LARGE CORPORATIONS IS
THAT CORRECT- IT DOES APPLY TO
ANYONE IS PROVIDING ENERGY- TO
ACCOMPANY- AND IT ALSO APPLIES
TO THE SUPPLY CHAIN AND SO IT
WOULD AFFECT OTHER COMPANIES
THEY ON'T HAVE BUT THOSE
COMPANIES ARE NOT REQUIRED TO
REPORT- THEY'RE NOT REQUIRED TO
BE AUDITED THEY WOULDN'T BE
THEY CAN BE PENALIZED BY CAR
THAT WOULD ONLY BE THE COVERED
BILLION DOLLAR PLUS ENTITIES-
BUT OFFICES AND THESE ARE GOING
TO WORK WITH THEIR SUPPLIERS.
TO BE ABLE TO GET THAT
INFORMATION SO THAT WE HAVE
TRANSPARENCY AND CAN KNOW WHAT
WE NEED TO DO TO FIGHT CLIMATE
CHANGE THAT THE WORLD DOESN'T
CONTINUE TO BURN UP. SO IT
WOULD IMPACT MY BUSINESS I
WOULD BE REQUIRED I MEAN THEY
THEY ARE THEY SAY HEY IF YOU
DON'T REPORT TO US THEN WE
CAN'T DO BUSINESS WITH YOU
ANYMORE AND THEN. AND SO. I
GUESS FOR ME IT'S THIS IS A- I
THINK A- VERY LARGE- TAX OR- IF
YOU WANNA CALL TAX IS STILL A
REGULATE SOME HAS TO DO
SOMETHING. CEMEX REPORT COST
MONEY. AND RESOURCES NOT DO I.
CARE ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENT
ABSOLUTELY THAT'S WHY. I LOVE
THIS COMMITTEE. BUT I THINK
THAT. WE EAT WITH THE PLAN IS
NEED TO COME UP WITH A WAY TO-
YOU KNOW REALLY ANALYZE WHAT
THAT WHAT'S THIS IS GONNA DO TO
EVERY BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA
THAT WORK FOR THE BILLION
DOLLAR COMPANY THERE'S NOT TOO
MANY IN THIS DAY AND AGE THAT
SOMEHOW DON'T GET TOUCHED BY.
CORPORATIONS ONE WAY OR THE
OTHER THAT ARE BILLION DOLLAR
COMPANIES. SO I WANT TO GO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY- BUT I
THINK THIS IS REALLY GOING TO
IMPACT EVERY SINGLE BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA AND THERE'S A LOT OF
THERE'S A LOT OF- THINGS THAT
YOU KNOW OUR CALL TAXES OR OR
THE CONVICT THEIR REGULATIONS
WHICH REGULATION IS A TAX IF
YOU HAVE TO DO SOMETHING YOU
HAVE TO PAY SOMEBODY TO GET
THAT INFORMATION. THANK YOU.
SENATE AND HOUSE YEAH I AM A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE ACTUALLY USED TO
WORK FOR A CORPORATION WHO-
FOLLOWED MUCH OF THESE
GUIDELINES BEFORE THIS HAS BEEN
ENACTED IN THIS IS JUST
REPORTING AT THIS TIME AS
YOU'RE MENTIONING THAT'S NOT A
CHANGE IN THAT THE BUSINESS
MODEL WHATSOEVER IT'S JUST A
REPORTING MECHANISM TO- THE A.
R. B. AND I'M ACTUALLY LOOKING
FORWARD TO SEE WHAT IS
CORPORATIONS- WILL- COME UP
WITH YOU KNOW AND HOW THEY
COULD. YOU KNOW CHANGE PERHAPS
SOME OF THEIR- THIS SOME OF THE
OPERATIONS TO BE A LITTLE BIT
MORE SUSTAINABLE- I THINK. ON
THE SUPPORT ON ON THE COMPANY
THAT I WORKED FOR ME THEY HAD
AT SUPPLIER SORT OF CODE OF
CONDUCT BUT THEY REALLY TRIED
THEIR BEST TO HELP THE SMALL
BUSINESSES IN THE SUPPLY CHAIN
IT WASN'T- WE'RE NOT GOING TO
WORK WITH YOU ANYMORE WAS
REALLY TRYING TO BE ABLE TO
HELP THEM TO GET. INTO
COMPLIANCE AND MAKE THEM MORE
EFFICIENT AND BETTER- SO. MY
PERSPECTIVE ON THAT BUT I WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU- YOU KNOW FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND HAPPY
TO SUPPORT. OUR CENTER DO YOU
WANT TO DO YOU WANT TO CLOSE
WANTED ALSO TAKE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO RESPOND TO THE CONCERNS THAT
WERE RAISED BY SOME OF OUR-
COMMITTEE COLLEAGUES. YES
ABSOLUTELY AND I WAS JUST
TRYING TO FIND ONE THING HERE-
BONTA OKAY- FEDERAL ID. THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES AND SENATOR I
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE SAYING I
THINK IT'S ALSO VERY IMPORTANT
TO UNDERSTAND. THAT WHAT WE'RE
PROPOSING HERE IS NOT LIKE A
BRAND NEW IDEA RIGHT THERE ARE
COMPANIES BIG CORPORATIONS THAT
ARE ALREADY DOING THIS THEY MAY
BE DOING IT AT DIFFERENT LEVELS
AND ONE OF THE THINGS WE'RE
TRYING TO BRING IS CONSISTENCY
SO THAT ONE DIFFERENT COMPANIES
MIGHT REPORT THE FORMING CARBON
FOOTPRINT WE KIND OF CONFIDENE
THAT THEY'RE DOING IT. IN THE
SAME WAY AND IT'S NOT BEING A
GRITAR GREENWASHING BUT I- AND
IN THIS IS US IN SOME OF THE
MATERIALS FOR THE COMMITTEE-
THERE IS. ALREADY SOME. CALL
THE CDP'S SUPPLY CHAIN PROGRAM.
WHICH HAS REPRESENTS- HUNDREDS
FOUR MEMBER CORPORATIONS THAT
ALREADY DO THIS WORK WITH THEIR
SUPPLY CHAIN THAT INCLUDES.
MICROSOFT OF WHICH I THINK I
BELIEVE AS A COMPANY THAT
SENATORS OFFICES WORKFORCE. A
STANLEY BLACK AND DECKER
WALMART. ALPHABET KELLOGG
MCDONALD'S NIKE NORDSTROM
TARGET AND COCA COLA WHO ARE
ALL WORKING I THINK WITH A LOT
OF THE DOWNSTREAM SMALLER
BUSINESSES THAT YOU'RE-
REFERRING TO ENSIGN IAGO IN
HERE BUT OBVIOUSLY A LOT OF
SMALL BUSINESSES ARE SUPPLYING-
THESE LARGE CORPORATIONS. SO
THEY'RE ALREADY DOING MASS AND
I UNDERSTAND- YOU KNOW THE
CONCERN ABOUT PUTTING IN. YOU
KNOW AFFECTED BILLION
OBLIGATION BECAUSE THEY'RE
GOING UP TO WORK WITH. THEIR
SUPPLIERS BUT IN THE END WE
IT'S SO IMPORTANT COURT
CORPORATE CARBON EMISSIONS. ARE
NOT THE ONLY PIECE OF IT I DO A
LOT OF WORKERS IN ON LAND USE
AND HOUSING AND TRANSPORTATION.
BUT CORPORATE EMISSIONS ARE A-
BIG PIECE OF THE PUZZLE. UNTIL-WE KNOW WHO'S EMITTING WHITE
IT'S HARD TO KNOW. WHAT SMART.
PUBLIC POLICY LOOKS LIKE AND SO
I WITHOUT COLLEAGUES I
APPRECIATE. EVERYTHING I ASKED
FOR AN AYE VOTE. PART OF BILLS
MOVE BY SECOND DOLLAR- SECTOR
PLEASE CALL. I THE NUMBER SIX
TWO BY CENTER WE- THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY ALLEN HI.
BATES NO IT'S NO DALLY NO ALLEY
KNOWS AND SALAS GONZALEZ I.
SKINNER EARNED WHAT KASKY. ALL
RIGHT REALLY THEY'RE OPEN FOR
OTHER MEMBERS THAT I THINK YOU
SENATOR THINKING COLLEAGUES
FOR- THE MEANINGFUL DISCUSSION.
LET'S NOW. GO AHEAD NOT SOME
GUY I DON'T SEE CENTER WHEN WE
NEWMAN HERE'S LET'S GO BACK TO
CENTER GONZALEZ TO PRESENT SB
SEVEN TWENTY SIX THIS ITEM NINE.
RELATED TRANSPORTATION
SUSTAINABILITY STRATEGY BUT OUR
TRANSPORTATION CHAIR ITEM NINE
MEMBERS THANK YOU MR. AND
MEMBERS HERE AGAIN TO PRESENT
SB SEVEN TWO SIX WHICH WILL
UPDATE THE CALIFORNIA'S
EXISTING CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM TO FOCUS FURTHER
INVESTMENTS. ON ADVANCING
EQUITY AND WILL SET UP A
FRAMEWORK FOR INTER AGENCY
COLLABORATION TO PLAN AND
IMPLEMENT THE FUTURE OF CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. SB SEVEN TWO SIX
IMPLEMENTS CRITICAL UPDATES AND
REFORMS TO THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM WHICH
CURRENTLY ALLOCATES CLOSE TO
ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY TO ENSURE INSTEAD OF
DOLLARS ARE USED TO ADVANCE
EQUITY IN CLEAN TRANSPORTATION.
THESE CHANGES WILL HELP MAKE
CLEANER VEHICLES ACCESSIBLE TO
ALL CALIFORNIANS AND HELP
CONVERT THE WORST POLLUTERS
LIKE DIESEL POWERED TRUCKS THAT
HAUL GOODS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
FOR MY DISTRICT TO MANY OF OUR
OTHER DISTRICTS- AND
COLLEAGUES. ACROSS CALIFORNIA
CURRENTLY AIR POLLUTION FROM
GOODS MOVEMENT
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS OF
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AS WE KNOW
AND THROUGH A STUDY FROM THE
UNION OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS
FOUND THAT ON AVERAGE AFRICAN
AMERICAN LATINO AND ASIAN
CALIFORNIANS ARE EXPOSED TO
DANGEROUS PARTICULATE MATTER
EXHAUST. FAR MORE THAN OUR-
CAUCASIAN COUNTERPARTS. IN
ADDITION TO UPDATING THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM SB SEVEN
TWO SIX ALSO REQUIRES THE
GOVERNOR TO APPOINT A LEAD
AGENCY TO OVERSEE ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE DEPLOYMENT. AND
REQUIRES CROSS AGENCY PLANNING
TO BETTER ALIGN CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION STRATEGIES WITH
PRODUCTION GOALS INVESTMENT IN
THESE PROJECTS AND EIGHT LEVEL
HEADED APPROACH TO PLANNING FOR
THE FUTURE OF CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION IS NECESSARY TO
PAVE THE WAY FORWARD. TO A
BRIGHTER AND MORE CLEANER CAL
CALIFORNIA TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT TODAY HAVE MERITED
ALEXANDER REPRESENTING CAL
START. AS WELL AS BILL MCGOVERN
THE POLICY DIRECTOR FOR THE
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR I WANT
TO THANK THEM BOTH AND AT THE-
APPROPRIATE TIME RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR I BILL ON SB SEVEN TWO
SIX THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. ALL
RIGHT. GREAT SO LET'S GO TO
START WITH THE MISSILE CENTER.
RIGHT HI GOOD MORNING ALLEN
NUMBER CAN YOU HEAR ME OK. YES
WE HAVE A GREAT. PLAN FOR.
RIGHT HERE TO HELP. THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR HAVING ME AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR SENATOR
GONZALEZ FOR HER WONDERFUL
LEADERSHIP ON CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION. ALEXANDER
POLICY DIRECTOR FOR CAL STAR
AND HERE AT THE COUNTER ATTACK
HAVING TO TAKE. CAL STARTED IN
INTERNATIONAL MEMBER BASED
NONPROFIT WITH OVER TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY MEMBER COMPANIES ALL
DEDICATED TO TRANSFORMING THE
TRANSPORTATION INDUSTRY. I
THINK CRITICAL MANUFACTURED
THE- MENTION TECHNOLOGY AN
ALTERNATE CALL PROVIDERS. AS
WELL AS PRIVATE PRIVATE AND
PUBLICLY AND MANY MORE. AND
EASY TO CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM AND IS NOW NOW ON HOW
BURLY BEEN A CRITICAL ELEMENT
OF OUR- TRANSPORTATION CLIMATE
PROGRAM. HOWEVER I THINK THAT
WAS ESTABLISHED ALMOST TWENTY
YEARS AGO WE PASSED MANY
LANDMARK CLIMATE LIES. AND WE
HAVE ADOPTED VERY AMBITIOUS.
MANDATE FOR CLEAN VEHICLE. IN
FACT VERY FOR THE- EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS. CALLED THE REALLY
MAKE SENSE TODAY NOT. BATCH YOU
THAT GUY YOU. TO ENSURE THAT
THEY ARE. EIGHT CURRENT GOAL.
AS WELL AS RETURN TECHNO THE-
AND MARKET. BECAUSE REALLY NEED
TO INCREASE THE PACE OF OUR
PROGRESS. AND IT ALSO CRITICAL
AND MENTION TO ENSURE THAT THE
AGENCIES WORK TOGETHER TO THE
COURT THEIR SHARED GOALS AND
TARGETS. SO THE ENERGY
COMMISSION AND REALLY MORE NOW
THAN EVER THE STATE NEEDS TO
REACH ONE AND A HALF MILLION
MIGHT BE EASY CHARTERED BY
TWENTY THIRTY. AND WE NEED TO
RAPIDLY SCALE UP
INFRASTRUCTURE. FOR MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY YOUR ATTENTION
VEHICLE. WHICH WILL BE CAN MORE
RAPIDLY COMING TO MARKET DUE TO
THE ADVANCED CONTRACT ROLE AND
OTHER CARD REGULATIONS. AS WELL
AS JUST GENERAL LIKE WE GOT
MARKET TREND TOWARD YOUR NEXT
VEHICLE. IT'S FOR THESE REASONS
THAT WE ARE REALLY PLEASED TO
SPONSOR THE SPELL AND WORK WITH
SENATOR CONVOLVULUS. AND WE
WELCOME CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS
WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND THE
GOVERNMENT THROUGH THE PROCESS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH. LET'S. NOW
GO TO BILL MCGOVERN. HAVE
SENATOR FAVOR THANK YOU- TO. WE
GO THANKS VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- THE ONLY
WITH THE COAST FOR CLEAN AIR
AND I ALSO SERVE ON THE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE TO THE
ENERGY COMMISSION'S CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM THAT
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR MOST OF
OUR WORK IS DIRECTED AT
CLEANING UP THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR FOR THE SIMPLE REASON
THAT ABOUT 80% OF OUR AIR
POLLUTION COMES FROM
TRANSPORTATION AND ABOUT 50% OF
OUR GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
COME FROM TRANSPORTATION. WHEN
YOU INCLUDE THE UPSTREAM
EMISSIONS BUT WE ALSO SEE THERE
A LOT OF INEQUITIES IN THE WAY
THAT TRANSPORTATION POLLUTION
AFFECTS DIFFERENT CALIFORNIANS
IN FACT THERE RESOURCES BOARD
FOUND THAT 45% OF THE AIR
POLLUTION EXPOSURE DISPARITY
FOR THE BLACK POPULATION WAS
FROM MOBILE SOURCES OF YOUR
ANALYSIS POINTS OUT. SO WE
SUPPORT SB SEVEN TWENTY SIX WE
STRONGLY AGREE WITH THIS
PRIORITIZING REDUCTIONS IN AIR
POLLUTION IN OUR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES WHICH ARE MOSTLY
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. WE HAVE SOME SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS TO MAKE THE EQUITY
COMMITMENTS FROM THE ENERGY
COMMISSION MORE QUANTIFIABLE TO
BRING MORE ACCOUNTABILITY TO
THOSE AND ALSO TO UPDATE THE
SCRAP AND REPLACE ENHANCE WHAT
MODERNIZATION PROGRAM SO THAT
THE REPLACEMENT VEHICLES WOULD
ONLY BE ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES
SO WE APPRECIATE CENTER
GONZALEZ CONSIDERING THOSE
AMENDMENTS AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO WORK WITH HER
ON THOSE AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT LET'S NOW
GO OKAY SO LET'S NOW I DON'T
SEE ANYONE HERE IN. PERSONAL
SIN OVER TWENTY FORTY. HI
EVERYONE WANTS TO SUPPORT ON
THE FOR LINES THIS S FOR SB
SEVEN TWENTY SIX MODERATOR.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. A
LINE OF SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO NATALIE PERKARA ON
BEHALF OF E. NOW CHANGE ENERGY
DEVELOPER ENERGY MOTOR CARS
FOLLOW GROUP NORTH AMERICA AB
BEING CORPORATION MOMENTUM
DYNAMICS MAKOLA CORPORATION
AMPLY POWER- DYING SYSTEM
ANAHEIM TRANSPORTATION NETWORK
THE LION ELECTRIC COMPANY
ARRIVAL MOTIV POWER SYSTEMS AND
GREENPOWER MOTOR COMPANY ALL IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN TWO SIX.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT TO THE LINE OF FORTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI DILLON
JACK ON BEHALF OF THE ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING ASSOCIATION WE
EVER SUPPORT IF AMENDED
POSITION FOR THE REASONS
OUTLINED IN A LETTER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU X. WELL THE
LINE A ONE OH NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING HEIDI IS A
CLEAR EXAMPLE OF POWER IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND NEXT TO
THE LINE OF FIFTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
AUDRA HARTMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION AND
SUPPORTED SB SEVEN TWENTY SIX
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORT IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR.
THANKS SO MUCH ALL RIGHT LET
SOME I KNOW I DON'T SEE ANYONE
REGISTERED AS A LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS- I DON'T SEE ONE HERE
IN PERSON OR IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. THE MODERATORS ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINES YOU WANT TO
VOICE CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL
SB SEVEN TWENTY SIX OR
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU FOR IN
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN
ZERO IN OPPOSITION OF THE BILL
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AND WE DO HAVE A LINE ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. JUST A REMINDER
TO ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION. OF SB. SEVEN TWENTY
SIX. THEN THAT PERSON DECIDED
NOT TO QUEUE UP THAT WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME DR OKAY- OKAY WELL LET'S
SO LET'S NOW BRING THE BILL
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
DISCUSSION COMMENTS FONG.
MEDEVACED HERE. FOR THE SENATOR
THERE'S A NUMBER OF- COMMITTEE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR MINUTES ARE
YOU CONSIDERING THOSE AND ALSO
THE SUPPORT- WITH AMENDMENTS IF
YOU GO FOR IT BECAUSE IT COMES
A TRANSPORTATION IS MY
UNDERSTANDING YES ABSOLUTELY
OKAY GREAT FIVE. EIGHT HI AGAIN
I'M I GET LIKE 6270% THERE WAS
SOME OF THESE BUT THEN I NEED
TO KIND OF HOLD BACK UNTIL I
SEE THE- SO I'M NOT GOING TO
SUPPORT IT TODAY BUT I AM HAPPY
TO MAKE A MOTION TO PEAS. ALL
MAKE THE MOTION AND THE LAUGHS
SO THAT WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
FLOOR. IS THAT POSSIBLE SIR. SO
THAT HE CAN MOVE FORWARD AND
THEN SHE'S GOING TO CONSIDER
THOSE LAST MINUTES. DUTY ON
USUAL BUT POSSIBLE YEAH I THINK
I THINK IT'S I'VE- IN THE RULES
AND I KEEP MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION I LIKE. IT'S A GREAT
WAY OF. SENATOR ALLEN- WHEN. WE
MAKE OUR WILL WE PRESENT OUR
BILLS WE USUALLY SAY WERE TAKEN
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS OR
SOMETHING THESE ARE KIND OF.
GENERAL ELUSIVE SO I'M THINKING
THIS IS A WORK IN PROGRESS.
YEAH KIND OF APPROACH IT YEAH
OKAY GOOD ALL RIGHT. BECAUSE
INTERESTING I HAD THE SAME
CONCERNS I WALKED IN- IN THE
MIDDLE OF THIS SO I AGAIN I
WOULD CHOOSE RESTATED D.
GREENHOUSE GAS. IN CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM IS DESIGNED TO
REDUCE CARBON I KNOW WE FUSE-
POLLUTION WITH THEM ALSO AND I
WAS CONCERNED WITH THE HIGHEST
PRIORITY BEING FOR POLLUTION
REDUCTION NOT THAT THOSE ARE
NOT LAUDABLE GOALS IF YOU GET
BOTH OF THEM FROM TAIL PIPE
IT'S GREAT BUT- BUT THERE COULD
BE. CONFUSION IN OTHER SECTORS
AND UNDERFUNDING THAT THESE
WOULD BECOME THIS BECOME A
POLLUTION- FUND FOR FOLKS AND
I'D LIKE TO KEEP THAT.
DISTINCTION BETWEEN- THE
MANGLED OF HAVING CARBON SO. I
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THIS
NEXT WEEK IN TRANSPORTATION I
GUESS. I THINK IT WILL BE THERE
OKAY I MEAN JUST TO CLARIFY I
MISS MY REASON YOU HAVE
ACCEPTED THE AMENDMENTS- BUT IS
THERE. WHAT WHAT- TELL ME WHAT
WE'RE- I KNOW THAT THERE'S A
FEW I WILL GET CLEAR ON THAT
BUT I KNOW THAT WE'RE ACTIVELY
WORKING ON THIS SO I. YOU KNOW
WE'RE WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE.
I DON'T BELIEVE WE'VE ACCEPTED
THAT AMENDMENTS. DEGREE BUT I
MEAN THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
AYE AYE- ARE THE CONSULTANT WHO
WORKED ON THIS IS IT WAS A
CONTEST BY SANTA ROSA AYE AYE-
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO GET THAT
CLARIFIED. OKAY YEAH MY NOTES
TO JESSE YOU HAVE BUTI ALSO
AND I APOLOGIZE WE DID ACCEPT
THE AMENDMENT OKAY. BUT I KNOW
WE'RE STILL WORKING ON QUITE A
FEW OTHER THINGS AS WELL THIS
IS APLANNING DOCUMENT AND THE
WHOLE SCHEME OF THINGS AND
WE'RE CONTINUING TO WORK WITH
ALL STAKEHOLDERS AND- WILL COME
UP WHEN IT GETS IF IT SHOULD
COME OUT YOU KNOW WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE AS
WELL IN WHICH I CHAIR BUT- YES.
OKAY YES OKAY. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU- SO WITH THAT UNDERSTANDING
I'M CERTAINLY HAPPY TO MOVE FOR
WITH THE BILL I'M AYE SIR ON
TRANSPORTATION AS WELL- SO THE
BILL'S REMOVED BY OUR VICE
CHAIR- IF YOU LOOK TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH TO ALL THE
SENATORS- FIRST THAT THEIR
COMMENTS AND I ALSO. THINK OUR
OUR STAKEHOLDERS AS WELL FOR
CALLING IN THANK YOU VERY. 30%
OF HIS KALRA. CONSULTANT FOR
ITEM NUMBER NINE SB SEVEN TWO
SIX BY SENATOR GONZALEZ THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON TRANSPORTATION
ALLEN FIVE ONE AYE BATES. BATES
NOT VOTING DALY. GONZALEZ HI
GONZALEZ I SKINNER EARNED BY
CASSIE HI THE I. OKAY. OKAY I'M
NOT TAKE A SIM CENTER NEWMAN
STILL PRETTY SUPPOSED IS THAT
RIGHT. THAT'S WHAT YOU WANT TO
GO AHEAD AND- PRESENT YOUR
FINAL BILL SENATOR- SB SEVEN
SEVENTY SIX. MY LAST ONE NO WE
APPRECIATE IT BECAUSE IT'S-
ALLOWING US TO. GIVE THIRTY
MINUTES OF OUR TIME OKAY GREAT
ABSOLUTELY. NO PROBLEM THANK
YOU KNOW IT'S GONNA SCARE AND
MEMBERS AGAIN MY LAST BILL
TODAY TO PRESENT IS SB SEVEN
SEVEN SIX- WHICH WILL MAKE
VARIOUS STATUTORY CHANGES TO
ENHANCE THE STATE WATER BOARDS
ABILITY TO MORE EFFECTIVELY AND
EFFICIENTLY IMPLEMENT THE SAFE
AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER
ACT. WHICH WAS SB TWO HUNDRED
AND TWENTY NINETEEN OF COURSE
THE GOVERNOR GOVERNOR NEWSOM
SIGNED INTO LAW SB TWO HUNDRED
WHICH ANNUALLY DIRECTS ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION TO SUCK
FUND SAFE DRINKING WATER
EFFORTS AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AROUND THE STATE
OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS. MANY
OF THESE COMMUNITIES HOWEVER
CANNOT WAIT TEN YEARS FOR SAFER
WATER ESPECIALLY NOW AS WE FACE
ANOTHER PROBABLE DROUGHT WITH
MANY VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS
STILL SHELTERING IN PLACE FROM
COVERED NINETEEN. THE STATE
WATER BOARD HAS WORKED HARD
OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS TO
IMPLEMENT THE LEGISLATURE'S
VISION FOR THE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER
PROGRAM BUT IS IDENTIFIED A
NUMBER OF CLARIFYING STATUTORY
CHANGES THAT ARE NEEDED TO
QUICKLY EFFICIENTLY PROVIDE
FUNDING. AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO THE COMMUNITIES
IN NEED WITHOUT AN ANY
UNNECESSARY ADMINISTRATIVE
DELAY. THESE AMBITIONS SEIZE
INCLUDE CLARIFYING THAT PUBLIC
WATER SYSTEMS AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROVIDERS ARE
ELIGIBLE FUNDING RECIPIENTS.
AUTHORIZING THE BOARD TO MAKE
ADVANCE PAYMENTS PROVIDING THE
AUTHORITY TO ACT EXPEDITIOUSLY
TO PURCHASE EMERGENCY BOTTLED
WATER AND OTHER RESOURCES.
BITING THE ABILITY TO QUICKLY
SEND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROVIDERS INTO A FAILING
SYSTEM. TO RIGHT THE SHIP.
THESE CLARIFYING CHANGES ARE
BALANCED BY THE BILL'S
PROVISIONS THAT RECASTING
CONSOLIDATE THE BOARD'S
ADMINISTRATIVE ENFORCEMENT AND
THE AUTHORITY TO FIND TO ENSURE
THAT THE STATE'S FUNDS DO NOT
FALL VICTIM TO FRAUD OR ABUSE.
SB SEVEN SEVEN SIX IS A
THOUGHTFUL MEASURED APPROACH IN
PROVIDING THE EFFICIENCIES THAT
THE WATER BORDER NEED THAT THE
WATER BOARD NEEDS TO BE NIMBLE
AND EFFECTIVE IN GETTING. SB
TWO HUNDRED FUNDS AND PROJECTS
OUT THE DOOR TO THE COMMUNITIES
THAT NEED IT THE MOST.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT TODAY WE
HAVE LESLIE LADEN THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR THE DIVISION OF
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE AT THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD. AND ALSO IN THE ROOM FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IS ON A
MELINDA'S THE LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD I THINK
THEM BOTH OR BEING HERE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR FIVE FOOT
BOAT SB SEVEN SEVEN SIX. OKAY
ALL RIGHT LET'S GO TO LET'S GO
TO LESLIE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR GONZALEZ MISTER CHAIR
IN TWENTY NINETEEN IN THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED AND THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED SB TWO HUNDRED
THE SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER ACT WHICH
PROVIDES A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY TO THE
TOP PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS
DELIVER SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER. AND ASSIST WITH
THE LONG TERM OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE FOR FAILING WATER
SYSTEMS THAT'S THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD WORKS
TO IMPLEMENT THE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER
PROGRAM THE BOARD HAS
IDENTIFIED SEVERAL STATUTORY
CHANGES THAT ARE NEEDED TO HELP
COMMUNITIES MORE QUICKLY. SB
SEVEN SEVEN SIX WILL ALIGN THE
WATER BOARD'S DRINKING WATER
AUTHORITIES WITH ITS WATER
QUALITY AUTHORITIES IT ALLOWS
THE WATER BOARD TO ADOPT
EMERGENCY REGULATIONS THAT WILL
HELP THE BOARD TAKE QUICK
ACTION IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT
DATA IS READILY AVAILABLE AND
IS IN KEEPING WITH OUR EXISTING
AUTHORITIES. THE BILL ALSO
EXTEND THE WATER BOARD'S
AUTHORITY TO REQUIRE TECHNICAL
REPORTS FROM STATE SMALL WATER
SYSTEMS. THIS WILL ENSURE SAFE
DRINKING WATER AND SMOKE
SYSTEMS IN COMMUNITIES AND IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE BOARD'S
CURRENT AUTHORITY TO REQUIRE
THIS INFORMATION FROM LARGER
PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS. SB SEVEN
SEVEN SIX WILL ALSO ALLOW THE
WATER BOARD TO ADDRESS
EMERGENCY SITUATIONS THAT OCCUR
AT FAILING WATER SYSTEMS.
SPECIFICALLY THE BOARD WOULD BE
AUTHORIZED TO PROVIDE UP TO TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS WITHOUT A
WRITTEN AGREEMENT IN ORDER TO
ADDRESS THE DRINKING WATER
EMERGENCY. FOR EXAMPLE TO
PROVIDE BOTTLED WATER. THE BILL
ALSO AUTHORIZED THE BOARD TO
MAKE ADVANCE PAYMENTS TO
ENTITIES THAT ARE AUTHORIZED TO
RECEIVE SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER FUNDS. THE WATER
BOARD GENERALLY MAKES PAYMENTS
ON A REIMBURSEMENT BASIS
HOWEVER THIS PROCESS CAN BE A
FINANCIAL BURDEN PARTICULARLY
ON DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
THAT DO NOT HAVE THE CASH FLOW
UP FRONT. THIS WILL HELP SMALL
COMMUNITIES ACCESS SAFE
DRINKING WATER MORE QUICKLY. SB
SEVEN SEVEN SIX ALSO INCLUDES
AN EXEMPTION FROM CERTAIN STATE
CONTRACTING REQUIREMENTS IN
ORDER TO CLARIFY THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER
PROGRAM. THE NINETEEN TWENTY
BUDGET ACT APPROPRIATED THE
FUNDING FOR IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE PROGRAM AND PROVIDED THE
BOARD WITH THIS EXEMPTION. SB
TWO HUNDRED HOWEVER FAILED TO
INCLUDE SUCH AN EXEMPTION THIS
BILL WILL ALIGN EXEMPTIONS
INCLUDED IN THE NINETEEN TWENTY
BUDGET ACT WITH THE INTENT OF
SB TWO HUNDRED. FINALLY SB
SEVEN SEVEN SIX WILL PREVENT
AND ADDRESS POTENTIAL FRAUD IN
THE SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER PROGRAM FUNDS.
THESE PROVISIONS MERRICK CYSTIC
OF SORTIES CURRENTLY EXERCISED
BY THE BOARD FOR OTHER FUNDS
AND ARE IMPORTANT TO HELP
PREVENT MISUSE OF PUBLIC FUNDS.
PROTECT COMMUNITIES AND HELP
ACHIEVE OUR SHARED CLEAN
DRINKING WATER GOALS THANK YOU.
FOR ALL RIGHT- WE'RE NOT GONNA
WHO DOES NOT GONNA GO TO THE
PHONE LINES TO SEE PEOPLE HAVE
ADDED TO WANT TO SUPPORT.
CORRECT GREAT BIG BUT I DON'T
SEE ON THE TWENTY FOUR YEAR
HERE. MODERATOR ANYONE ELSE IN
THE FUNDS WHEN A VOICE SUPPORT
FOR SB SEVEN THIRTY SIX. DURING
SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT WITH A LINE OF
FORTY FOUR. THEY'RE NOT THERE.
I HAVE NO OF FURTHER US SUPPORT
QUEUE AT THIS TIME OKAY THANK
YOU. I DON'T SEE ANYONE
REGISTERED IN OPPOSITION- TO
TESTIFY BUT- IF THERE'S ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINES FOR TWENTY
FOUR YEAR HERE I DON'T SEE ONE
IN PERSON AND I THE ROOMS-
ANYONE WHO WANTS TO REGISTER
OPPOSITION OR SAID OR OR
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL. ON THE
PHONE LINES MODERATOR. THANK
YOU FOR IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE
AND THEN THEY OFFER OPPOSITION.
AND ONE MOMENT ONE CUED UP
WOULD HELP THEY DISAPPEARED WE
HAVE NO FURTHER OPPOSITION HERE
AT THIS TIME. OKAY LET'S BRING
THE ITEM TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
DISCUSSION ANY THOUGHTS
CONCERNS YES SENATE WITH CASKEY
SIDE IF I MAY MISTER TORRES.
SENATORS WITNESS A QUESTION ON-
THE THREE HUNDRED COMMUNITIES
ARE SYSTEMS ARE FAILING AND I
WANT TO LOOK AT I THIS IS
TAILORED TOWARDS HELPING THOSE
WHO NEED A LITTLE MORE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE- ECONOMIC
TO SUCCEED OR TO CONSOLIDATE OR
MERGE. I WANT TO GO ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE PEOPLE THE
COMMUNITY SERVER WAIT ON THEY
ARE THEY ARE MANAGED A FIELD
WATER SYSTEM THEY ARE THERE'S
NO AMOUNT OF MONEY NO AMOUNT OF
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THEY CAN
BE GIVEN TO THE THIS THIS AREA
TO DO IT I DON'T KNOW IF THIS.
SIXTEEN HOUSES ONE APARTMENT
BUILDING WHATEVER WHATEVER IT
IS THEY'RE FILL SYSTEM WHAT
DOES IT LOOK LIKE WITH THE
TOOLS THAT THE WATER RESOURCE
BOARD HOW DO WE- ADDRESS ITS
ABANDONMENT I GUESS I GUESS IS
A BETTER BECAUSE WE NEED WE
DON'T TALK ABOUT THAT BUT IT
IS. A TOOL THE THAT YOU TRY TO
PROVIDE SAFE WATER MEANING
SOMEBODY HAS TO MOVE TO A
COMMUNITY THAT HAS IT VERSUS-
WELL AS- IT IS. COMPLETELY AND
RECOVER OUR WATER SYSTEM WHAT
DOES THAT LOOK LIKE FOR THE
MORTARBOARD. A LOT OF BOARD OF.
HI FAILING WATER. SO THE WAY
THAT WE'VE BEEN MANY OF HUNDRED
THIS IS TRYING YOU KNOW IT'S
GOING. YOUR AVAILABLE DATA. IF
WE CAN THE MINISTER MAKE THEM
OF THE POSITION AS PA. AND THEN
THERE IS THE POTENTIAL THAT WE
COULD DO AN ADMINISTRATIVE
CONSOLIDATION IF THEY'RE TO
REMOTE THAT WE CAN'T HOOK UP A
PIPELINE AND PHYSICALLY
CONSOLIDATE THEM WE CAN YOU
KNOW OF OUT THEM TO A NUMBER OF
SMALLER WATER SYSTEMS AND
ADMINISTER THEM JOINTLY THROUGH
OUR ADMINISTRATIVE AUTHORITY
AND SO THAT'S GOING TO BRING
EFFICIENCIES TO THE PROGRAMS.
SO WE'RE GOING TO YOU KNOW USE
ALL OF THOSE TOOLS WE HAVEN'T
GOTTEN TO THE POINT OF THAT
THAT YOU MENTION OF YOU KNOW
FINDING A SYSTEMS THAT
ABSOLUTELY CAN'T BE
EFFICIENTLY- OPERATED SO I
THINK THAT WHEN WE USE ALL
THESE DIFFERENT TOOLS THAT WE
HAVE. FOR ADMINISTRATIVELY
CONSOLIDATING AND MAKING THEM
AS EFFICIENT AS POSSIBLE YOU
KNOW WHERE WHERE HELP AND THEN
AT SOME POINT IN THE LONGER
TERM- AND I'M SUPPORT THAT WE
WOULD PROVIDE WOULD BE IN
TOMORROW MARC AFFECTIVELY
ADMINISTERED. THANK YOU MR I
WAS A YEAH I SERVE WITH MY KING
AND WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY VOTED
IN TWENTY TWELVE TO STAB WISH-
RIGHT A BASIC RIGHT TO WATER I
THINK SOME PEOPLE
MISINTERPRETED LIKE THOSE
STATES THAT HAVE STAND YOUR OWN
GROUND LIKE OKAY I'M HERE I'M
LIVING HERE RIGHT NOW IN THE
CITY CALIFORNIA'S COULD RUN-
CLASS A WATER SYSTEM INTOMY
HOUSE AND TOOK ME UP AND I'VE
GOT I'VE GOT SAFE DRINKING
WATER AND THERE'S JUST A LITTLE
BIT OF. MISINFORMATION OUT
THERE BUT WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO WITH THESE FAILING SYSTEMS
THAT SHOULD BE SHUT DOWN YEARS
AGO FOR NOW AT THE RALLY I
DON'T WANT TO BE OVER
OVERSTATED BUT SOME OF THESE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN SHUT DOWN LONG
LONG AGO SO I WILL MOVE THE
BILL- HAVE BEEN A BIG. PLATE IN
THIS CONSOLIDATION ARAB LOOKING
FORWARD TO HAVING THE STATE
WATER BOARD USED THE MUSCLE
THAT'S PROVIDED HERE IN THE
BILL TO ACTUALLY GET THIS
FEELING SYSTEMS EITHER SHUT.
DOWN OR CONSOLIDATED TRIP.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. YES I JUST
WANT TO I TO THE BILL REALLY
HITS SOME OF THINGS WERE AB-
WHEN PASS THE SAFE DRINKING
WATER BILL LAST YEAR I MEAN IT
REALLY CLOSE WITH THE GAPS ON
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WERE
MISSING AND ASKED IT PROVIDES
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR EXPEDITING.
AND I THINK THAT THAT SPAN-
VERY GOOD OUT TO THIS WE'VE
DONE THAT AT LOCAL GOVERNMENT
ON A NUMBER OF OCCASIONS JUST
WILL TRANSPORTATION BE ABLE TO
EXPEDITE PROJECTS WHERE THE
MONEY THE CASH FLOW WASN'T
THERE SO CAN THANK YOU SENATOR
GONZALEZ. I THINK IT'S A GOOD.
I PREPARE TO SUPPORT IT. THANK
YOU MA'AM I CERTIFICATE OKAY SO
THE BILL A MOVE BY SARAH CASKEY.
IF YOU LOOK CLOSE. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE I WANT TO
THANK OUR WITNESSES FOR BEING
HERE AGAIN LET'S A LOT IN FRONT
OF A DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
DIVISION OF FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE AT THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD. AS
WELL AS ON THE MELINDA'S THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT. SIR CONSOLE PLEASE
KALRA. ITEM NUMBER TEN SB SEVEN
SEVEN SIX BY SENATOR GONZALEZ
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED BUT
FIRST HE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY. ALLEN
HI I BATES HI EIGHT SIDE DALY.
AND SALAS GONZALEZ I SKINNER
STERN WHITE HOUSE STERN AYE. HI
MY COUNTY. IT WAS MY. THAT'S
PART THANK YOU. WINDOWS TEN
NINETEEN YEAH YES. I KNOW THE
LAST YEAR IS OKAY LET'S NOT GO
TO OUR GUY CENTER STERN WHO
HERE- WELCOME SENATOR HERE TO
PRESENT SB FIVE EIGHTY TO THE
SIDE ELEVEN IN. OUR AGENDAS. IN
A GREAT ROOM HERE OR THERE.
YEAH THE YEAH YEAH OKAY. THANK
YOU MISTER BURST PLEASE RE. SAN
BILL FIVE EIGHTY TWO ALL TO.
THIS BILL FOR ON THREE
COMPONENTS OF OUR CLIMATE
CHANGE PROGRAM- WHEREAS I THINK
WE'VE HAD A- ONE DIMENSIONAL
STRATEGY TO SOME EXTENT TO THIS
POINT. WHERE WE FOCUSED ON
MITIGATION. AND THE REDUCTION
DIRECTLY OF EMISSIONS. THE
SCALE OF THE PROBLEM I WOULD
SUBMIT TO YOU ALL IS SO BIG-
AND SO DAUNTING THAT SOMETIMES
WE DON'T REALLY LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE IT IT'S JUST TOO
OVERWHELMING TO THINK ABOUT SO
LET ME TRY TO GROUND IT AND
JUST THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN
HAPPENING THIS PAST YEAR AS
OPPOSED TO THINKING OUT TO.
TWENTY THIRTY OR TWENTY FIFTY
OR WHAT THE WORLD WILL LOOK
LIKE IN TWENTY ONE HUNDRED- HIT
A HUNDRED THIRTY DEGREES- THIS
AST AUGUST. IN OUTSIDE OF LOS
ANGELES. THE ENTIRE POWER GRID
OF TEXAS SHUT DOWN BECAUSE
BASICALLY FROZE ALL THEIR
FOSSILIZED FUEL INFRASTRUCTURE.
THAT ONE OUT OF EVERY TWENTY
FIVE ACRES IN THE STATE WERE ON
FIRE. OVER FIFTY BILLION
DOLLARS IN DAMAGE OVER THE LAST
SIX YEARS FROM WILDFIRES ALONE.
A TESTIMONY DIRECTLY FROM THIS
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT THE TOTAL
COST OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
FROM UNABATED CLIMATE CHANGE-
OVER A TRILLION DOLLARS THE T.
WORD WAS USED- TO TALK ABOUT
THE SCALE THIS IMPACT AND IT'S
ABOUT REAL PEOPLE TO. FEMA'S
VULNERABILITY INDEX CAME OUT
THEY THEY FINALLY PUBLISHED FOR
THE FIRST TIME EVER NATIONAL
RISK INDEX FOR THE ANALYZED WHO
WOULD SUFFER FROM DISASTER. AND
IT TURNS OUT IT'S THE SAME
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN SUFFERING
FROM ALL THE OTHER DISASTERS
WE'VE HAD WHETHER IT'S THE WILD
FIRES OR THE PANDEMIC. SENIORS
AND THE ELDERLY PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES PEOPLE STRUGGLING
WITH POVERTY. PEOPLE WHO DON'T
LIVE NEAR RESOURCES LIKE WHAT
WE JUST TALKED ABOUT HERE IN
THE PAST BILL OF CLEAN WATER.
ACCESS TO AIR CONDITIONING AND-
AND COOLING AND HEATING. I'M
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE WHO WILL
SUFFER MOST OF THE PREMISE OF
THIS BILL IS THAT THE CURRENT
TRAJECTORY OF CLIMATE DISASTER
IS COMPLETELY UNSUSTAINABLE AND
THEREFORE INHERENTLY UNJUST.
AND THAT THE CURRENT TRACK WERE
ON UNDER THE SB THIRTY TWO AB
THREE NINETY EIGHT FRAMEWORK
TO. REDUCE EMISSIONS 40% BELOW
NINETEEN NINETY LEVELS BY
TWENTY THIRTY WHICH IS CURRENT
LAW. IS SIMPLY INSUFFICIENT.
THE E. U. ITSELF ADOPTED A 55%
TARGET BY TWENTY THIRTY. THE U.
K. IS ON TRACK 468% REDUCTION
TARGET SO WE'RE ALREADY BEHIND
OUR PARTNERS TO THE EAST.
CONGRESS ITSELF IS LOOKING AT A
BILL TO. TO REDUCE EMISSIONS
50% BY TWENTY THIRTY. TO ME
ACTUALLY BEHIND THE U. S.
CONGRESS AND I DON'T THINK OF
CALIFORNIA IS A STATE THAT
LEAVES FROM BEHIND. SO THIS
BILL. INITIALLY SETS OUT THE
AMBITIOUS BUT I BELIEVE QUITE
ACHIEVABLE GOAL OF DOUBLING OUR
EFFORTS OVER THE NEXT DECADE.
BUT THE SECOND PREMISE. IS THAT
VIRGIN THE PATH WE'RE ON IS
TOWARDS RESTORATION. IT'S NOT
SIMPLY TOWARDS MITIGATION THAT
IF WE'RE GOING TO ACTUALLY
FIGHT CLIMATE CHANGE WE
ACTUALLY HAVE TO REVERSE IT AT
THE CURRENT LEVEL OF EMISSIONS
IN THE CURRENT LEVEL OF WARMING
WHICH WILL LAST FOR CENTURIES
IS GOING TO CAUSE SECTION JUST
IS THAT THE ONLY JUST THING TO
DO IS TO ACTUALLY TURN THINGS
AROUND AND START TO REVERSE THE
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND
SO THAT. THE NOTION OF CLIMATE
RESTORATION IS SOMETHING THAT
IS NEW TO THIS LEGISLATURE AND
IT'S SOMETHING I WANT TO SUBMIT
FOR THE FIRST TIME THIS
COMMITTEE IT'S A DIFFERENT WAY
TO CONCEIVE OF JUSTICE IS THE
LENS THROUGH WHICH WE ADVANCE
CLIMATE ACTION- IT'S NOT ENOUGH
TO JUST ACCEPT THE STATUS QUO
PEOPLE ARE GETTING HURT NOW. IN
ORDER TO DO THAT THOUGH. OUR
PATH ALSO HAS TO BE JUST INTO
THE THIRD PIECE OF THIS BILL IS
ABOUT RESILIENCE. ANGLING THE
STATE'S EFFORTS ON BOLSTERING
IN ADAPTING AND- HARDENING OUR
WAY. THROUGH THIS CLIMB
DISASTER ALSO HAS TO BE JUST WE
HAVE LAWS ON THE BOOKS RIGHT
NOW TO. SPEND GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUNDS IN THE MOST
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE THOSE PEOPLE ARE THE
ONES WHO ARE HURT MOST FIRST.
AND LIKEWISE WE SHOULD BE DOING
THE SAME. WHEN IT COMES TO
INVESTMENT IN OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND RESILIENCE
TO GO TO THE MOST VULNERABLE
PEOPLE FIRST. IT IS NO
COINCIDENCE. THAT THE FEMALE
VULNERABILITY INDEX THAT SAYS
L. A. COUNTY IS THE MOST
DANGEROUS PLACE TO LIVE IN THE
WHOLE COUNTRY. RISKIEST PLACE
IN THE COUNTRY IT IS NO
COINCIDENCE THAT THE EQUITY
MAPS TO LOOK AT FROM THIS
PANDEMIC OVERLAP DIRECTLY WITH
THAT VULNERABILITY INDEX. AND
ALSO WITH THE POLLUTION INDEX
FROM THE STATE ON THE CALENDAR
VIRUS GREAT. BECAUSE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE SAME PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO BE HEARD. SO THANK
YOU FOR CONSIDERING THE
LEGISLATION AND THANK YOU TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK-
ALL THE CONCEPTS OUTLINED IN IN
IN YOUR- IN YOUR STAFF REPORT-
WE- WERE SAYING YES TO- AND
SPECIFICALLY. YOU KNOW WE
APPRECIATE THE NOTION THAT. THE
CLIMATE RESTORATION PEACE
SHOULD NOT BE THOUGHT OF AS
SOME KIND OF NEW OFFSET
PROGRAM. THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
CARBON REMOVAL SIMPLY AS A AS A
WAY TO LESSEN THE PRESSURE ON
THE MITIGATION SIDE. BECAUSE
THE MITIGATION PIECES THERE IS
OUR ACCOUNTABILITY MECHANISM TO
ACTUALLY SAY NO NO WE'RE GOING
TO BE DRIVING DIRECT EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS IN COMMUNITIES. BUT
THIS RESTORATION CONTACTS
HOPEFULLY ADDS A NEW COMPONENT
THAT GOES BEYOND NATURAL AND
WORKING LANDS IT SAYS WE
ACTUALLY NEED A FRAMEWORK TO
REMOVE CARBON. IN THE STATE AND
SET OURSELVES ON A PATH
PREINDUSTRIAL LEVELS. SO I
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S WORK
ON THAT AND ALSO THEIR CONCERN
OF KEEPING THE INTEGRITY OF THE
CURRENT. EMISSIONS REDUCTION
PROGRAM SO CORDONING THOSE OFF
AND FINING THOSE LINES I THINK
IT'S GONNA BE REALLY IMPORTANT
SO- COMMITTED TO THAT EFFORT
AND WORKING WITH YOU ALL IN
THAT ENDEAVOR- AND I JUST
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME WE CAN GET
INTO IT FURTHER BUT I. TO SHOW
YOU THAT IT'S FEASIBLE AS
OPPOSED TO JUST TELL YOU I
WANTED TO HAVE OUR FIRST.
WITNESS PROFESSOR DAN KAMAN.
FROM UC BERKELEY WAS ALSO
SCIENTISTS ON THE IPCC THAT
DEVELOPED- THE PARIS AGREEMENT
AND A LOT OF THE UNDERLYING
SIGNS THERE. WHO HAS DONE THE
MODELING- TO ACTUALLY LOOK AT
THE FEASIBILITY OF THIS FOR
CALIFORNIA. I THINK YOU'LL HEAR
FROM HIM AND ALSO THE SENIOR
ATTORNEY ALEX JACKSON ENTERED
THE C. IS YOUR MAIN WITNESSES
AND I HOPE. IT COMPELS YOU TO
SUPPORT THE BILL. THANKS SO
MUCH. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU WILL
GO TO. A PROFESSOR KAREN. I
THINK WE ARE OPEN ON YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE DO
A DRUM ROLL YOU THINK THEY
MISSED THAT. THREE GOOD IDEA
YOU ARE YOU AYE MUTE. BECAUSE
WHICH IN CHATTANOOGA ALLEN
JACKSON FIRST SOUTH JACKSON
JACKSON WHAT. TWENTY NINE JANU.
YEAH GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE DALLAS JACKSON
ON BEHALF OF AN ORANGE THE-
HELLO. MY LOOK AT THIS BILL
IT'S CANADA VIRAL BECAUSE OF
FATHER WHO WANTS HIS KIDS TO
INHERIT A LITTLE PLANET. I
THINK WE'VE SEEN IN RECENT
YEARS THAT'S NOT HYPERBOLE. I'M
A CHAIN HERE HAPPENINGS.
DEVASTATING AND OUR CURRENT
TARGETS ARE NOT CURRENTLY UP TO
SNUFF. OUR OWN CLIMBING
ASSESSMENTS. I'M FORECAST
FIRING THAT WE GOING TO SEE TO
THE MID CENTURY WE'RE SEEING IT
TODAY- SO WE KNOW WE DO NOT
TOLERATE OUR EFFORTS. TO
COMPREHENSIVE INTEGRATED.
FASHION AND THAT'S THIS BILL.
THE AMBITION AND COMMITMENT
NECESSARY. TO CONFRONT AND WHEN.
THIS CRISIS AND IT DOES SO BY
INTEGRATING THE THREE KEY
COLORS AT A RESTAURANT TALK
ABOUT MEDICATION RESTORATION
AND RESILIENCE TOGETHER AT
SCALE WE WILL CLOSE STOP COOPER
BURST AND ALL THE OTHER
GREENHOUSE GASES IN THE
ATMOSPHERE. CRUCIALLY INVEST
ACADEMICALLY IN THE COMMUNITIES
MOST AT RISK AND. MOST
DESERVING KUMAR SOLUTION. TO BE
CLEAR SO TARGETS NO SUCH FOR
THE HARD WORKING THE CLINTON.
WHICH IS SUCH. I DON'T WANT TO
SAY TO MAKE SURE WE'RE ON TRACK
FOR OUR EXISTING TWENTY THREE
TARGETS BUT IT MATTERS WHAT THE
WORLD'S FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY
COMMITS TO. ENSURE SENDING
STRONGER TARGETS WILL HELP YOU
CALIFORNIA ON THE CUTTING EDGE
OF INNOVATION. BOTCHING JOBS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
IMPORTANT AREAS LIKE GREEN
HYDROGEN. WE ALSO HAVE A
HISTORY OF SETTING TARGET THAT
LOOK AWFULLY DAUNTING DEBATE
BUT IN HINDSIGHT LOOK ALMOST
INEVITABLE. SB THIRTY TWO YOUR
CALL IS GOING TO WRECK THE
ECONOMY. INSTEAD WE MET THAT
GOAL FOUR YEARS AHEAD OF
SCHEDULE. ENTER PAVELIC WANTED
THINGS GARDENING PAUL JUST GOT
CLEANER. HOWEVER YOU CAN
PORTANTINO THAT EVEN THE
CURRENT BUILDUP OFGREENHOUSE
GASES IN THE ATMOSPHERE IS
UNSAFE THAT MEANS MEDICATION
ALONE WON'T CUT IT WE MUST ALSO
RAPIDLY BEGIN DRAWING DOWN
GREENHOUSE GASES FROM THE
ATMOSPHERE. BUT IT MUST BE A
BOTH AND NOT AN EITHER OR-
CRUCIALLY BY LEAKING CARBON
REMOVAL TARGETS TO XCELERATED
MITIGATION TRAJECTORY SB FIVE
EACH YOU. WILL ENSURE THAT
COVER A LITTLE BIT NOT TAKE
PLACE WITH OPTIONS REPORTER FOR
THE REQUIREMENTS TO CLARIFY
THAT ADDITIONALITY. THERE WILL
BE CHALLENGES AFFORDABILITY IS
AN ACUTE CONCERN COMBINED TO
CALIFORNIANS THAT IS THE
QUESTION OF HOW NOT WHETHER. WE
SPENT FIFTY SIX BILLION DOLLARS
A YEAR ON GASOLINE MEMBERS.
SHOULD BE MORE THAT REVENUE TO
POWERING OUR HOMES AND CARS
PEOPLE TO CHRISTY WILL CREATE
JOBS BUILDING AND
INFRASTRUCTURE AND LOWER
ELECTRIC RATES FOR EVERYBODY.
THANKS COSTS OF MAINTAINING
HARI. THE GREAT WILL BE SPREAD
OVER MORE SALES. THE NOW
BECAUSE NO SAN IN ENACT ON
QUITE THAT WE CAN RECYCLE. OUR
TO BE ABLE TO TELL MY KIDS THAT
THE FATHER THAT WE WROTE TO THE
WORLD REFOCUSES ATTENTION ON
CLIMATE ACTION THIS FALL IN
GLASGOW. COMING OUT OF THE
TRUMPCARE AND ENDEMIC
CALIFORNIA HAS A PIVOTAL
OPPORTUNITY TO RAISE THE BAR
THE GLOBAL ACTION TO ONCE AGAIN
LEAD BY EXAMPLE. FIFTY FIVE ANY
TO START THAT CONVERSATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I THOUGHT.
OKAY ADULT COUNTY. THIS BUDGET
IF YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU
KEEP A VERY BRIEF BECAUSE
YOU'RE CALLING UNFORTUNATELY
USED A USED A FEW TIMES. SO
PLEASE PLEASE MAKE IT IS
CONNECTED OKAY POSSIBLE.
UNDERSTOOD YES THIS IS DAN
CAMPBELL WHEN YOU SEE BERKELEY
AND I'M HONORED TO TODAY TO
SPEAK ON SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
EIGHTY TWO. I WANT TO STRESS
THAT WHILE THE GOALS OF BEACH
YOU ARE AMBITIOUS THEIR
ACHIEVABLE GOALS BASED ON THE
DRAMATIC PROGRESS WE'VE SEEN IN
CLEAN ENERGY TECHNOLOGY COSTS.
EQUALLY IMPORTANT SB FIVE
EIGHTY TWO WILL TRIGGER AN
INTEGRATED SUITE OF ACTIONS
SUCH AS THE BILLS WERE HEARING
TODAY. THEY WILL INVEST NOT
ONLY IN A LOWER COST ECONOMY
BUT IN SOCIAL JUSTICE IN THE
STATE THAT COMMITTED TO THAT. I
WILL. COMMENT ON THE CLIMATE
SCIENCE THOSE ARE WELL BOUNCE.
BUT I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS A REMARKABLE
RECORD AS WE JUST HEARD. VERY
DIFFICULT GOLDEN MAKING THEM
ACHIEVABLE. AB THIRTY TWO AND
SB THIRTY TWO AND BEFORE THAT
AB FOURTEEN NINETY THREE ALL
XCELERATED GOALS. AND THEIR
WORDS HARD LARGE NUMBERS OF
SKEPTICS WERE CALIFORNIA'S ONE
MILLION SOLAR ROOFS AND ONE
MILLION ELECTRIC VEHICLE
TARGETS BOLTS THAT WERE
ACHIEVED. THOSE BROUGHT JOBS
QUANTITATIVELY. DEMONSTRABLE
BENEFITS TO THE ECONOMY BY
MOVING AHEAD WITH THESE GOALS
CALIFORNIA THAT WAS MORE THAN
EIGHTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
EMPLOYED. IN THE SOLAR INDUSTRY
AND WE'RE SEEING SHIPS OUT OF
BALSA PEELED INTO GREEN ENERGY
JOBS ALL THE TIME. CALIFORNIA
NEEDS BOLD SHORT AND LONG TERM
ENERGY STORAGE AND AFTER
CRITICAL FEATURE AB TWENTY BY
FOURTEEN IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN. LAUNCHED A STORAGE
MARKETING CALIFORNIA WE'RE NOW
SEEING INDIVIDUAL STORAGE
PLANTS COMING ONLINE LARGER
THAN THE ENTIRE OBLIGATION OF.
ONE POINT THREE GIGAWATTS FOR
TWENTY TWENTY. BUT MOST COULD
BEACH I'M ONLY LIMON ON THE IS
THAT THE- OF NOT IN. THE BILL
ARE FAR HIGHER THAN ANY OF THE
AFTER. OF THE COST OF THE
TRANSIT. WE SEEM TO THE FIRES
WE'VE SEEN THE DESTRUCTION
COMMUNITIES LIKE PARADISE AND
WE'VE SEEN THROUGH THE LACK OF
INVESTMENT IN DISTRIBUTED CLEAN
ENERGY AND ENERGY STORAGE. THAT
CALIFORNIA HEY THE MUCH HIGHER
BILL FOR NOT TAKING YOUR
CRITICAL GOALS ARE USED MY LAST
TWO MINUTES WITH THE THIRD AND
PROBABLY MOST IMPORTANT REASON
WHY WE NEED TO PASS A LET'S
MAKE IT HAPPEN MINUTE Y.
MODERNO MIGHT APOLOGIZE SENATOR
STERN. YEAH I GOT IT OKAY-
APPROVED CALIFORNIA IS A NON
JUST CALIFORNIA SPARE THE AIR
DAYS RESULTING BLACKOUTS TOXIC
SPILLS DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECT COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
BLIND COMMUNITIES BY INVESTING
IN FIVE EIGHTY TWO WE INVEST
SOCIAL JUSTICE WE BRING DOWN
THE COST FOR ALL OF US. WHILE
WE RECLAIM CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE
LEADERSHIP POSITION SO I
REQUEST YOUR YES VOTE ON THIS
BILL I AM HAPPY TO WORK WITH
YOU AND I RECOGNIZE THE
CRITICAL ECONOMIC BENEFIT THIS
WILL BRING THE CALIFORNIA. HAS
THE KNOWLEDGE CLIMATE LEADER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
ATTENTION AND I HAVE SUBMITTED
MY COMMENT- THE POSITION PAPER
AS WELL. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR. ALL
RIGHT LET'S GO TO- LET'S LOOK I
DON'T SEE ANYONE ELSE HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IN PERSON OR
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY. LET'S
OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES. THANK
YOU IF YOU WERE IN SUPPORT YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO NOW.
ONE AMEND ZERO IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
A ONE EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AMERILA THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION VERY IMPORTANT SB.
FIVE EIGHT. THANK YOU NEXAVAR
LINE OF ONE HUNDRED YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WHAT MADRE WITH THE
COMMON CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB FIVE AQ AND THANK YOU
CENTERS STERN PORTABLE
LEADERSHIP. THANK YOU AND NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF SIXTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
KRIEGER FOR THREE FIFTY
SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND ACCESSIBLE LINE A
ONE OH FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MRS DR ERICA
THOMPSON THE FOUNDATION FOR
CLARIFICATION THANK YOU SENATOR
STERN VERY LEADERSHIP ON THE
FILE AND- WE ARE IN THE PARK.
THANK YOU AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE OF ONE TWENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. JANET COXON FOR THREE
FIFTY SO IT CAN VALLEY BANKING
CENTER STERN IN STRONG SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORT IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH
LET'S NOT GO TO THE OPPOSITION
I KNOW- ONCE AGAIN WE MISS
SILVERTHORNE FROM THE CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE AND THEN MARGOT
PARKES FROM- FROM WHISPER. WHEN
WE START WITH U. S.
SILVERTHORNE. THE MORNING CARE
ACT ARE GOING OUT DRINKING OF
COMMERCE AGAIN YOUR
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THAT REPRESENTS A DOUBLING OF
OUR STATE LIKE GIGI GOLDEN PINE
WHERE WE'RE STILL STRUGGLING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO RECHARGE
TWENTY THIRTY GOALS WITHOUT THE
FINANCIALLY IMPACTING
CALIFORNIA ENERGY RATES. GAS
PRICES IN THE. CAR CONSUMER
GUIDE. HE OF YOU CAN BEGIN THE
THAT YOUR CHEAPER THIRTY
INCLUDING A DOUBLE OVER THE-
CAR AND- FUEL FILTER BUT CARBON
FUEL STANDARDS. THE FINANCIALLY
REDUCING YOUR TEETH YOUR CAP
AND TRADE WILL GENERATE KLEIN
BILL READ TO. DUBLINER OF
ENERGY EFFICIENCY AND BILL.
ADOPTING REQUIRE ZERO OR LOW
EMISSION TURN AND BUSES.
REPORTING PURCHASES EUROPE
TRUCKS AND EQUIPMENT REQUIRING
1% WE AND BY TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE. CALIFORNIA ALSO PUT THEIR
ON THE URINATION PENALTY
YEARLING CAL MANDATED THAT.
NEED YOU'RE A MEASURE TRUCKS
GOAL IN TWENTY. ACROSS ALL TO
HI. AND THE GOVERNOR IS THE IS
IMPORTANT RIGHT. DOT SHOULD BE
CALLED THE TAX IMPLICATIONS
THERE. IS A OFTEN BECOME THE-
YOU A- HOW TO RETRACT THIRTY.
AND THIS BILL REQUIRE STATE
COULD THAT BULL WITH NO DISCUSS
ORDER. ON HOW O PUT AGAINST
TACTIC. ISSUED USUALLY RIGHT
NEEDS OTHER ISSUES THAT I BY UP
TODAY. SO IN ADDITION THE BILL
CAN DEMAND THE REQUIRE RETREAT
PLAN BE REACHED AT MEGA
EMISSION AND WE WILL GO BACK
CLICK. THIRTY FIVE. WOULD BE
KILEY CHILD WHICH THE BANK.
INTERNATIONAL GOLDMAN THE PAIR
THE CHOIR ON THE BILL ALSO
REQUIRES RESTORING ATMOSPHERIC
IN OCEAN G. H. T. THREE
INDUSTRY APPLY TO FIFTY BUT
ALSO COULD. DAVID YOU'RE VERY
DIVERSE ACCOUNTABLE. FOR THESE
REASONS DO REMAIN MCCORKLE.
WITH THE BILL. OKAY I'M. I'VE
I'VE I'VE COUPLE OF COMING
THROUGH THE GARBLED BUT THINK I
CAN I GOT THE FOR- THANK YOU
THEY GIVE US OVERTIME I WAS NOT
TO MARGOT PARK FROM WHISPER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AHMED
NICK GOOD MORNING. ON PART
ELECTION PATROL THIRTY. HERE
CAN. WITH THE BEST. BE FIGHTING
EACH YEAR. WE APPRECIATE AND
WANT OFTEN ARE. OPEN ABOUT.
NEUTRALITY NEGATIVE IN THE-
THAT FRANKLY. IN NINETEEN
NINETY LEVEL. THIRTY AND- THEY
BELIEVE THE AUTHOR CALLED. IN
NOT IMPROBABLE. AND I BELIEVE
THAT. YEAH PROBABLY THE BILL
CALLED MULTI AGENCY IN. THE
MISSION. WELL THAT BE
APPROPRIATE JUAN AND I'LL MY
COLLEAGUE OVER WHEN IT OUT
THEIR RESEARCH. AFTER THAT I
BEGAN THEIR TWENTY ONE. THE
PLAN THAT'S RIGHT LOOK AT THE
TECHNOLOGY AND POLICIES TO GET
TROUBLES GOING LEGALIZE. SHOULD
WAIT ABOUT AN HOUR WHAT WE NEED
MAKING- ADDITIONAL PART THE
WHILE WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING CONGRESS WITH.
AROUND THE ARE NEEDED AND- NEED
A MISSION CALLED ME NOT ON. SB
EIGHT YEAR THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU THANK YOU MUCH PART
LET'S A I DON'T SEE HERE IN
PERSON OR IN ROOM TWENTY IF WE
CAN TURN TO THE- FIVE TWO PHONE
LINE. FOR OPPOSITE ADDITION
OPPOSITION. FIVE EIGHTY TWO.
THANK YOU FOR IN OPPOSITION YOU
MAY PRESS THE ONE AND THEN THE
ZERO. ONE ZERO DO THEY ONE AND
THEN ZERO HERE IN OPPOSITION.
AND ONE MOMENT WE HAVE A FEW
LINES QUEUING UP. JUST A
REMINDER IS ONE AND THEN ZERO
FOR OPPOSITION OF SB. FIVE
EIGHTY TWO. I WILL GO SEVENTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BERTHON CAP
KEY ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU OVER A LINE OF ONE
TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MANY MENTION ON BEHALF OF THE
AGRICULTURAL ENERGY CONSUMERS
ASSOCIATION AND OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER OPPOSITION TO AT THIS
TIME. OKAY THANK YOU FIVE WELL
THIS NOW BRINGS THE ITEM TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
THOUGHTS DISCUSSION. SENATE
CASKEY. CLICK TO SEE THIS
MORNING THE AMBITIOUS US
SENATOR STERN- AS I NOTED AT
THE COMING OUT OF PARIS THE
ACCORD SAID- SEPARATED CLIMATE
ADAPTATION AT ABOUT 17%
OBVIOUSLY AB THIRTY TWO DIDN'T
ALLOW THAT A. B. SB THIRTY TWO
DOES ALLOW A DOES ALLOW WITH-
CAN YOU EXPLAIN THAT WORLDWIDE
GOAL WITH THE- RESTORATION
RESILIENCY THAT YOU'RE- PUTTING
FORTH NOW. I THINK I THINK WHAT
WE'RE PROPOSING HERE SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT IN THAT. BUT THE AIM
IS NOT TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
MAKE- CARBON REMOVAL OR
ADAPTATION EFFORTS NECESSARILY
COUNT TOWARDS THE MITIGATION
GOAL IN THE SAME WAY SO BUT
THAT. BY PUTTING RESOURCES
AGENCY WHICH HERETOFORE HAS NOT
REALLY HAD THE BIN IN THE
DRIVER'S SEAT ON. OUR CARBON
STRATEGY- AND TO SORT OF
ESTABLISH A PROCESS THROUGH
THAT ARCHITECTURE- IT'S A
PROPOSAL YOU KNOW I I'M I'M
OPEN TO ARGUMENTS ABOUT THE
ROLE FOR INSTANCE ON A PATH TO
CARBON NEUTRALITY THAT CERTAIN
TYPES OF MITIGATION EFFORTS
PLAY BUT AS YOU KNOW THEY
BELIEVE BETWEEN MITIGATION AND
ADAPTATION RIGHT. I THINK I
THINK FINDING THAT LINE TO BE
REALLY IMPORTANT ESPECIALLY THE
NATURAL WORKING LAND SPACE I
THINK YOU'RE RIGHT TO RAISE THE
TENSION THERE BECAUSE THERE ARE
CERTAIN ACTS THAT ARE
MITIGATION ACTION IN A NATURAL
WORKING ON AN ADAPTATION AND
HOW WOULD THAT WORK I DON'T
THINK WE HAVE THAT ANSWER
SORTED OUT YET BUT I WANTED TO
SEND THE SIGNAL OF A- SOME KIND
OF- COROLLARY AND DEFENSIBLE
FRAMEWORK ON ITS OWN TO RIDE IN
PARALLEL NOT TO BE SEPARATE
DECISION THE SCOPING PLAN NOT
TO BE ACCOUNTED FOR IN THE
SCOPING PLAN BUT- TO HAVE. NOT
THE AIRBOARD DRIVING BUT REALLY
THE AGENCY OVERSEEING ALL THE
RESEARCH SIDE. OKAY I'M- MORE
ON PAGE. TO PAGE SIX WE TALK
ABOUT THE CARBOMER NO OPTIONS
THIS IS A QUESTION ASIAN
BIOMASS CONVERSION. ARE YOUR
SPONSORS- AND I GUESS YOU ARE
PREPARED TO. SUPPORT ALL THE
CAL CARBON SEQUESTRATION
OPTIONS THAT ARE AVAILABLE IN
ORDER TO ACHIEVE THIS GOAL
THERE ARE THE I DON'T NEED TO
TELL YOU THERE ARE SOME CARBON
SEQUESTRATION STEP WILL REDUCE
CARBON THAT THERE'S A LOT OF AS
I LOOK DOWN THE SCOREBOARD OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE SUPPORTING
THIS. WOULD SAY OH NO DON'T DO
THAT YEAH WE WANT THIS LAUDABLE
GOAL BUT DON'T DO THAT SO I'M
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE WE'RE ON
THE SAME PAGE HERE YOU'RE SO
RIGHT TO RAISE IT AND I AGREE I
THINK THERE ARE THERE ARE AREAS
THAT MAKE ME. ANXIOUS IS AS
OPENING SALVOS- I DON'T THINK
THAT THE FIRST MOVING PROJECTS
SHOULD BE AREAS WHERE THE
SCIENCE IS UNCERTAIN BUT ALSO
WHERE THEIR- COULD BE DIRECT
EMISSIONS REDUCTION DIRECT
EMISSIONS POTENTIAL IN ACTUAL
FRONTLINE COMMUNITIES SO
REFINING THE DEFINITION OF
CARBON REMOVAL AND THAT
RESTORATION FRAMEWORK TO ENSURE
THAT. I THEIR PRIORITIZATION IS
PUT IN HERE OR OR SOME KIND OF
ABILITY TO- ENSURE THAT THERE
IS NO SE- NET EMISSIONS
INCREASE IN A COMMUNITY OR
ACTUALLY WHAT I'D LIKE TO SEE
IS A COROLLARY NET EMISSIONS
DECREASE SOME ABILITY SAY YES
YOU'RE REMOVING CARBON BUT CAN
YOU ALSO ASSOCIATE THAT WITH
SOME KIND OF LOCAL EMISSIONS
BENEFIT I THINK THOSE KINDS OF
METRICS WHICH WILL HELP US.
REFINE IT BUT I WILL TELL YOU
WE DON'T HAVE ALL THOSE ANSWERS
YET I MEAN I GET IT IT'S NICE
THE NICE TO TALK ABOUT WORKING
LANDS AND EVERYBODY ALL ALL THE
SPONSORS EVERYBODY'S ARE UP
THERE BUT THERE'S A LOT OF
EMISSIONS THAT ARE GOING ON THE
COVERED ENTITY'S AND THE CAP
AND TRADE WOULD LOVE TO BE ABLE
TO GET THE. GREEN LIGHT TO SAY
YOU CAN JUST. CAPTURE A CARBON
FIBER SMALL. AND THEN PUT IT IN
A ABANDONED OIL WELL AND IT BE
PEOPLE BUT JUST SO WE'RE WE'RE
SURE WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
IF WE'RE TRYING TO GET IN THAT
ZERO AND NEGATIVE WE'RE GOOD
WE'RE AND WE'RE USING ALL THE
TOOLS- ON. THE VULNERABILITY-
PUTTING PEOPLE FIRST AND ON THE
ON THE- THE CLIMATE IMPACTS I
AGES. FOOD FOR THOUGHT I KNOW
IN THE BAY AREA WE HAVE A LOT
OF SEA LEVEL RISE DISCUSSIONS
ARE GOING ON IN YES WHEN WE
HAVE SEA LEVEL RISE THEY WILL
FLOOD THE LOW LAYING AREAS
WHICH TEND TO BE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES OR AREAS THAT HAVE
TO BE REPRESENTED BY ME BUT PUT
THAT ASIDE SOME OF THE
SOLUTIONS ARE- BUILDING A
BRIDGE AND TAKING OUT SOME
LEVEES THAT WERE THERE THAT
THAT ACTUAL WORK WILL NOT BE
GOING ON IN A IF PER SE.
VULNERABLE COMMUNITY BUT THE
BENEFIT OF THE WORK WE GO AND I
JUST WANT TO THE AS WE LOOK AT
THESE BIG IDEAS- IT THAT THAT
ANY AND THEIR REGIONAL AND YOU
MIGHT NOT WE MIGHT HAVE TO MOVE
BEYOND THE COUNTY AND THE AND
THE CITY WHERE PEOPLE ARE
SAYING THIS IS THIS IS. WHAT
WILL BENEFIT ME AND I WOULD SAY
THE MILK MAYBE A BIGGER
PROJECT- I GUESS AND- I ALSO
SUGGESTED TO THE CRITICS THAT
SAY WE CAN'T GET A SPENDING
PACKAGE RIGHT NOW THAT IS
PUTTING US ON TARGET TO REDUCE
OUR GREENHOUSE GASES BY 40%
WEEK WE CAN'T WE'RE SPENDING A
BUNCH OF MONEY ON THE LAUDABLE
THINGS. THAT ARE NOT REDUCING
CARBON AND WE GOT YOU KNOW IN
FACT THIS MEMBERS IS COMMITTEE
OR TIRE LISTEN TO ME TALK ABOUT
THE DISTINCTION BETWEEN CARBON
REDUCTION AND POLLUTION WHICH
IS ALL PROBLEMS- WHAT DO YOU
SAY TO THE CRITICS THAT SAY WHY
THIS IS AMBITIOUS IN THE SENSE
OF COMMITMENT. IT'S NOT THE
NUTS AND BOLTS TYPE OF. THE
ACTIONS THAT THEY WANT TO SEE
FROM THE 40% CLIMATE-
REDUCTIONS THAT WE HAVE RIGHT
NOW. I THINK THEY'RE RIGHT IN
THAT IF WE KEEP SPENDING. AND
INVESTING THE WAY WE ARE
CURRENTLY WON'T BE ENOUGH H. A.
W. N. N. AS WE BROUGHT UP IN
THE HEARING YOU HAD WITH THE
TRANSPORTATION CHAIR HERE THE
OTHER DAY. MAKE THE ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION NUMBER IN DOES
YOUR MISSION VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR INSTANCE.
WHAT I RAISED TO THE TO THE
MINISTRIES I SAID. YOU KNOW IF
YOU DO THE AMERICAN JOBS PLAN
MATH WE'RE ACTUALLY ON TRACK
FOR FIVE BILLION A YEAR IF IT
ACTUALLY IF WE GOT ONE FIFTIETH
OF THE MONEY. FIVE X. THAT KIND
OF. SCALE OF INVESTMENT AND I
WOULD SAY THE SAME THING ON
WILDFIRE RIGHT WE WERE ABOUT TO
SEND A DEAL FOR HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS I KNOW THAT SOUNDS LIKE
A LOT OF MONEY FIVE X. I MEAN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AND WE
HAVEN'T DONE THAT EXACT MATH
BUT- THAT SCALE OF INVESTMENT
IS ACTUALLY WHAT'S GOING TO BE
REQUIRED TO GET THERE AND I
DON'T THINK WE'VE- WE FIGURED
OUT HOW TO BE. AMBITIOUS WITH
OUR OWN CURRENT SCALE SO I GET
THAT IT'S PUSHING US BEYOND
THAT BUT- THIS CAN'T JUST BE
DONE BY REGULATION AND NOT
ALONE I MEAN THAT THAT AMERICAN
JOBS PLAN. AND A MAJOR MAJOR
FEDERAL INVESTMENTS PROBABLY
THE ONLY PATH WE CAN WE CAN
MAKE. WELL YOU ARE RIGHT ABOUT
WE SHOULD BE SAYING SPENDING
FIVE X. ON WILDFIRE PREVENTION
IN ORDER TO. THE NEXT DECADE TO
REACH OUR GOALS SO- I'M GONNA
BE SUPPORTING THE MEASURE TODAY
I SOMETIMES BY A- LOOKING
FORWARD TO THE WORK THAT YOU DO
YOU TOO AND ALSO MAKING SURE
THAT D. ADVOCATES REALIZE THAT
THESEARE ALL THE TOOLS IN THE
TOOLBOX WHICH SOME OF THEM MAY
BE ONES THAT THEY ARE.
UNPREPARED TO EMBRACE EMBRACE
IF IT AND COOPERATION PUT
PRIVATE SECTOR TODAY TO REACH
TO REACH THESE THINGS IS GOING
TO BE A RELAXATION THAT'S GOING
TO BE NECESSARY IN ORDER TO
TAKE TO GET HERE AND I THINK
SOME OF THEM. BUT WHEN I SAID
MY TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS IN AND
SAY I'M PARTY YOUR CROWD THEY
LIKE IT BUT WHEN IT COMES DOWN
TO THE DETAILS THEY'RE NOT
GONNA LIKE IT- SO. THAT SAID.
THANK YOU. SORRY FOR NOT BEING
HERE FOR- PRIMARK SO YOU MAY
HAVE TO REPEAT JUST A LITTLE
BIT LIKE I. WHAT DID YOU SAY-
AS A LEGISLATOR NOW FOR NINE
YEARS I I'VE SEEN SB THREE
FIFTY I MEAN WE'VE SEEN ALL
KINDS OF LAUDABLE LIKE REALLY
AGGRESSIVE- AMBITIOUS. TARGET
IN. FOR YOU I'M I JUST I THINK
FOR ME IT'S LIKE WHEN WE DID
THE WATER BOND WE TALKED ABOUT
HOW MUCH MONEY WE THOUGHT WE
COULD GET IN BONDS BEFORE WE
ACTUALLY WENT OUT AND SAID HEY
HOW MUCH WATER DO WE REALLY
NEED TO FIX OUR PROBLEMS AND
HOW HOW DO WE GET THERE WE
DON'T WE DO THINGS BACKWARDS
ARE WE DON'T. ANALYZE THE
SITUATION AND SAY HEY. THIS IS
THE GOAL. THIS IS THE THANKS TO
GET YOU TO THAT GOAL. WE GO THE
OTHER WAY. WE GO HEY WE'RE
GOING TO MARKET GOAL OUT THERE.
IN FOR EXAMPLE. WE HAD- AB
THIRTY TWO WAS THE THEIR
STARTING OF THIS WHOLE. PROJECT
IN. IN FOR THE FOR THE WE WERE
IN TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION.
THE CHAIRWOMAN STOOD ON HER
FEET FOR. FOUR AND A HALF HOURS
AT LEAST I THINK. AND WE TALKED
ABOUT THE STEPS. WHEN WE TALKED
ABOUT GETTING WHERE WE WANT TO
GO. AND ONE WHEN WE LOOK AT THE
AUDIENCE AND WE LOOK AT THE-
WHERE WE'RE GOING AND WHAT HOW
WE'RE ACHIEVING IT WE'RE
SPENDING. HUGE AMOUNT OF
MONEY I MEAN IF YOU IF YOU LOOK
AT THE GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
FUND IT COMES AT A COST TO
CALIFORNIANS. SO I'M I'M
PAINTING A REALLY BROAD PICTURE
HERE BECAUSE THIS IS A REALLY
BROUGHT THIS IS A REALLY
AGGRESSIVE. ONE OF THOSE GOALS
AGAIN. AND SO ARE MY QUESTION
TO YOU IS. THE DEVIL'S IN THE
DETAILS AND HOW WE GET THERE. I
DON'T I I'M FOR THE FOR THE
LIFE OF ME I DON'T LIKE TO SET
POLICY WITHOUT HAVING A ROAD
MAP OF HOW WE'RE GOING TO GET
THERE SO COULD YOU GIVE ME A
ROAD MAP. AND I'M NOT YOU PUT
WHATEVER NUMBER YOU WANT TO PUT
ON IT BUT TELL ME HOW WE'RE
GOING TO GET THERE AND SHE WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO CHEAT BECAUSE
AT THE END OF THE DAY. NOW ALL
OF A THIS IS THE QUESTION THAT
HAS TO BE ANSWERED. TO
CALIFORNIANS. WHO ARE PAYING. I
MEAN. WE HEARD. THE BUDGET
CHAIR. LAST WEEK ON THE FLOOR
SAY. YOU CAN'T AFFORD TO LIVE
IN CALIFORNIA SO WE NEED TO.
GIVE PEOPLE. MORE RECENTLY
ACTUALLY TAKE. TAXPAYERS MONEY
AND GIVE IT TO THE
DISADVANTAGED FOLKS. WELL BUT
DIDN'T DATE WERE ALL TAXPAYERS
WHETHER IT'S FEDERAL MONEY OR
STATE MONEY. OR IF THE
REGULATIONS ARE WHICH IS THIS
BILL WOULD CAUSE A REGULATION.
IT IS LIKE CALIFORNIA THIS IS A
FACT. SO SECRET THAT WE PAY 40%
MORE THAN ANY OTHER STATE. IN
ELECTRICITY COSTS AND THAT'S
BECAUSE WE HAVE THESE
AGGRESSIVE GOALS AND THAT'S
WHERE THIS MONEY IS COMING FROM
SO WE TALK ABOUT THE
AFFORDABILITY OF CALIFORNIA.
IT'S BECAUSE WE'VE PASSED THE
REGULATIONS AND IT TRICKLES
DOWN TO HEY YOU GOT TO PAY MORE
MORE MONEY AT YOUR AT THE GAS
PUMP. AT THE AT YOUR LECTURE
CITY YOUR BUILDING BECAUSE IT
ALL DRIVES COSTS UP SO MY
QUESTION TO USE TELL ME HOW WE
GET THERE. IT BY TWENTY THIRTY
BY THE WAY WHICH IS. NOT VERY
FAR OFF. THANKS FOR THE
QUESTION IN THE CHALLENGE IT'S
NECESSARY IF I'M BRINGING A
BILL LIKE THIS BEFORE YOU SO I
DON'T THINK IT'S A ILL FOUNDED
THE SCOPE OF WHAT YOU ASK- AND
I THINK I OWE IT. TO YOU AND
EVERY MEMBER WHO'S GONNA HAVE
TO VOTE ON. IF THEY IF THE BILL
MAKES IT THROUGH HERE TODAY.
BEFORE THIS BILL- IT SHOULD
MAKE IT TO THE FLOOR. WE CAN'T
AS A WHOLE SENATE VOTE ON
SOMETHING THAT DOESN'T ANSWER
SOME OF THOSE FUNDAMENTAL
QUESTIONS I CAN'T PROMISE YOU
HAVE EVERYTHING HERE TODAY BUT
LET ME GIVE YOU A SENSE. OF
WHAT I MEAN VERY PRACTICAL
TERMS. WHEN THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION AND
THE INDEPENDENT SYSTEM OPERATOR
ARE TRYING TO DECIDE RIGHT NOW.
WHAT KIND OF POWER TO BRING
ONLINE AND LONG TERM. ARE THEY
GOING TO MAKE A SORT OF SERIES
OF SMALLER INCREMENTAL
DECISIONS AND TRY TO FILL THE
GAPS TO HIT TWENTY THIRTY OR
THEY GONNA TRY TO REIMAGINE THE
ENTIRE GRID WHERE YOU HAVE.
ZERO CARBON BASELOAD RENEWABLES
FROM. GEOTHERMAL AND BIOMASS
LOOKING AT CCS AND DOING BIG
CREATIVE THINGS ARE WE JUST
GONNA KIND OF RATCHET UP. A
LITTLE SOLAR WIND AND KIND OF.
E. LIMPAR WAITED THIRTY-
LIKEWISE IN THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR I THINK GOVERNOR LAID
OUT SOME OF THE VISION BUT- YOU
KNOW WE KNOW THAT THAT'S GOING
TO BE BIG. BUT THE PIECES THAT
DON'T GET TALKED ABOUT- IN
AGRICULTURE AND FORESTRY. THOSE
SECTORS ARE GOING TO BE
DECIMATED OVER THE NEXT
DECADES- YOU CALIFORNIA WILL
NOT BE FAR MOBILE BY THE END OF
THIS CENTURY ON CURRENT
TRAJECTORY SO. HOW TO ACTUALLY
RESTORE THE LAND BRING IN
AGRICULTURE EMPOWER THEM- BRING
IN I DON'T WANT TO SHUT DOWN
INDUSTRY WITH THIS BILL I'D-
LIKE I DON'T THINK CALIFORNIA
SHOULD BE A PLACE THAT IMPORTS.
ALL OF ITS FUEL OR ITS CEMENT
OR ITS WOOD OR ANY OF THOSE
PRODUCTS RIGHT. I THINK WHAT
I'M TRYING TO FORCE AN HONEST
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT IT
ACTUALLY MEANS TO BE. BE AS
BOLD AS WE WANT TO BE HERE. AND
THAT RESTORATION FRAMEWORK AND
THAT REMOVAL PIECE I. AND
CENTER Y. CASI POINT WILL. ODD
AND- CONVERSATION A LITTLE BIT
I THINK IN THE STATE. AND
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE FOLKS WHO
MAYBE DON'T ALWAYS SIT ACROSS
THE TABLE IN FRONT LINE
COMMUNITIES AND MAYBE THAT THE
TRADES THAT ARE WORKING THERE
IN. THE OIL INDUSTRY IN THE
ELECTRIC VEHICLE INDUSTRY PLAY
PLACES THAT ARE NOT SUPPOSED TO
TALK SO I WANT TO FORCE THAT
WITH THIS. AND I'M I'M HOPING.
THAT THAT THAT'S POSSIBLE
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S NECESSARY.
THAT THAT'S REALLY IT I DON'T
WANT THIS TO BE. UP A PRESS
RELEASE EXERCISE OF A OF A NEW
FANCY NUMBER. I'M I'M I'M I
TIRE OF THOSE TWO AND IF IT
TURNS OUT THAT. THEY'RE HAVING
A NEW NUMBER FOR TWENTY THIRTY
ISN'T THE RIGHT WAY TO REALLY
PUSH THE AIRPORT AND PUSH THIS
ADMINISTRATION. TO DO BIG
THINGS IN THE CURRENT PLANNING.
IN THIS SIX TWO YEAR PERIOD
RIGHT WHERE THEY'RE GOING TO
MAKE THEIR OWN PLAN WITHOUT US.
IF IT'S IF THAT'S NOT THE RIGHT
MECHANISM TO PUSH THEM TO
ACCELERATE. I'M OPEN TO WHAT IT
IS I WANTED TO START I WANTED
TO SEND A SHOT ACROSS THE BOW
HERE AND SAY. THIS IS HOW BIG I
THINK WE SHOULD BE GOING IN
THIS NEXT COPING PLAN AND- AND-
IF WE DON'T DO THAT I THINK
AGAIN WE'RE GOING TO SORT OF
JUST TRY TO MAKE EVERYONE HAPPY
AND LIMPAR WAY TO TWENTY
THIRTY. WHILE THE WORLD BURNS
SO I OWE YOU MORE. MATH
MODELING DEATH. I'VE REPORTS E.
THREE VIEW ANY P. L. LAWRENCE
LIVERMORE STUDY INTERESTING
WANT TO CARBON NEUTRALITY. BUT
LET'S DIGGING DEEPER HERE
BECAUSE IT EZER OF THAT SO.
THAT THAT'S THAT'S. MY BEST
SHOT AT A- QUICK RESPONSE. I
APPRECIATE. FIVE I WOULD SAY
THAT- YOU KNOW AS A BUSINESS
OWNER AND SOMEBODY WHO COMPETES
WITH BUSINESSES THAT ARE ARE IN
CALIFORNIA. I LIVE MY BUSINESS
IS VERY CLOSE TO THE BORDERS I
AM NOT A SEVENTY FIVE MILES
FROM. FROM OREGON AND ABOUT A
HUNDRED TEN MILES FROM NEVADA
AND THOSE COMPANIES DON'T HAVE
ANY OF THE SAME- RESTRICTIONS I
HAVE OR THE COST I HAVE SO. IT
IF THERE ARE NO BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA I GUESS YOU MAYBE
MEET YOUR MISSION LAWS BUT WE
ALSO HAVE A PROBLEM OF A
REVENUE PROBLEM WE DON'T HAVE
BUSINESSES SO I'M NOT GOING TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY BUT I
WANT TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION BECAUSE I THINK. I
THINK WE NEED TO HAVE THE UP
FRONT DETAILED INFORMATION SO
YOU CAN BRING THAT. THE OIL
COMPANY AND ELECTRIC COMPANY
TOGETHER- THE LECTOR EVEY GUYS
RIGHT AND- AND I KNOW THAT YOU
WERE ON THE U. WE SAID ON A LOT
OF THE SAME COMMITTEES AND WE
HAVE A LOT OF THE SAME PASSIONS
ABOUT. IT IS HOW WE GET THERE I
THINK IS THE DIFFERENCES OF
MAYBE YOU KNOW AND OUR IDEAS
AND WHAT'S BEEN REALLY
FRUSTRATING THIS YEAR AND I
THINK THAT YOU YOU YOU BRING IT
UP AND SOME OF YOUR COMMENTS IS
THAT WHAT WE'VE SEEN FROM THE
AIR BOARD AND FROM. YOU KNOW
THE THAT THAT WHEN WE DID
AUDITS WERE NOT GETTING WORSE
WHEN YOU WHEN YOU BROUGHT UP I
KEYED OFF OF IT LAST. EEK IN
THE TRANSPORTATION MISSION WHEN-
MAY IT WAS. I CAN'T WHICH
TWENTY TALK ABOUT THE ONLY
THING. A MILLION CARS AND WE-
YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT A LOT OF VEHICLES THIRTY.
FEET IS SO THOSE ARE THOSE ARE
REALLY HIGH NUMBERS TO GET TO
SO. I THINK WE OWE IT TO THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA WE'RE
GONNA LEAD. AND WE'RE TRULY
GOOD ONLY. NOT JUST LEADING
FEEL GOOD AND DO THEM AND GET
THAT PRESS RELEASE BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT I'VE BEEN SEEING
FOR THE LAST EIGHT YEARS WE GET
THREE PRESSURES BUT THE DEVIL'S
KNOT IN THE DETAILS THE DETAILS
ARE NOW BEING WORKED OUT AS WE
GO THROUGH IT. AND THE COST IS
HUGE. AND WE'RE NOT GETTING
WHAT WE WHAT WE PUT WHAT WE'RE
PAYING FOR. WHETHER IT'S- THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL WHETHER IT'S
WHETHER IT'S LOW INCOME PEOPLE
IN THAT AND RUDY SALAS IS
DISTRICT THAT THAT AREN'T
GETTING IT. THE E. V. I MEAN
THOSE ARE THE THINGS THAT WE
REALLY NEED TO DIG INTO WE TALK
ABOUT DISADVANTAGED FOLKS.
THEY'RE NOT THE TABLE. THEY ARE
THE WEALTHY PEOPLE UNDERSTAND
HOW TO GET TO THE GRANT PROCESS
OR THEIR- AND THEY'RE JUST
THEY'RE DRIVING IN THE- IN THE-
IN THE- IN THE FAST LANE. AND
THE POOR PEOPLE RUNS SLOWLY
BREATHING BAD BETTER IT'S JUST
IT'S WHAT WE GOT TO BE MORE
RESPONSIBLE AND I KNOW I'M NOT
THIS IS NOT AT DIRECT YOU WHICH
IS SOME OF MY THOUGHTS TO GET
US WHERE WE CAN HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WHERE WE HAVE A
ROAD MAP. AND THEN WE CAN
FIGURE OUT THE COST AND HOW WE
GET THERE SO I APPRECIATE THAT
CONVERSATION AND SORRY I MISSED
YOUR OPENING REMARKS BY.
APPRECIATE THE DIALOGUE IN AND
IN THE OF TRYING TO GET
SOMETHING DONE ON THE GROUND
AND WHEN IT COMES TO AGRA I'LL
BE I'LL BE TO TABLETHERE'S A
THERE ARE SOME TOOLS OUT THERE
BUT WHEN WE TALK ABOUT HOW WE-
DO BETTER WITH OUR SOILS. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. YES INDEED-
AMBITIOUS BILL TIME. BUT AN
INPUT OBVIOUSLY IMPORTANT ON SO
HAD APPREHENDED HIM MOTIONS.
FROM SENATORS HOURS HAVE WHICH
ARE TO CLOSE CENTER. RESHAPE
THE RIGOR IN THE DIALOGUE
THAT'S WHAT I EXPECT OUT OF
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
COMMITTEES TO ELEVATE THIS KIND
OF. THESE TENSIONS AND THE
DETAILS SO I MAKE A VERY FIRM
COMMITMENT TO YOU MISTER CHAIR
THAT- WANT TO. DO A LOT MORE
HOMEWORK WITH YOU IN THIS
COMMITTEE AND I APPRECIATE THE
STAFF'S WORK BUT WE'RE GOING TO
NEED YOU IS PARTNERS HERE AND I
WOULD SAY THE SAME GOES BY THE
WAY FOR A BUDGET SUB CHAIR. AND
FOR TRANSPORTATION CHAIR WHO
HAPPEN TO BE SITTING BEFORE ME-
I DON'T WANT THIS TO BE A SOLO
MISSION HERE I WANT THIS TO BE
A- AS AN EXERCISE THAT THAT
LIFTS ALL BOATS AND HOPEFULLY
GIVES US ROOM TO. TO BE
CALIFORNIA TO BE WHO WE ARE
BECAUSE WE WON'T. WE RECOVER
FROM THIS PANDEMIC THE WAY WE
USED TO DO THINGS- WE'RE GOING
TO SLIP BACK INTO ALL THE SAME
PROBLEMS AGAIN AND FALL BEHIND
FURTHER THAN WE CAN EVER CATCH
UP SO. WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIFLE.
THANK YOU. THE CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALDERON ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN SB FIVE EIGHTY TWO BY
SENATOR STERN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER ALAN HI.
ALAN I BATES. BATES NO DALLY GO
DOWN I KNOW GONZALEZ AND SALAS
I SKINNER STERN HI STERN HI MY
COUNTY HI CASKEY I. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ARE THERE
ANY IS THERE HE IS. BUT THERE
IS- TIME TO GO OVER AND BUDGET
OKAY SO NOW LET'S GO TO ITEM
FIVE S. B. TWO EIGHTY NINE OUR
GOOD FRIEND THE ENERGIZER.
EDDERY BY ANY JOSH NEWMAN. AB
DAY MR IS IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD
THAT I WOULD STOP BY I AM VERY
SORRY FOR MY NOTED THAT WE
PROVIDED US I ACTUALLY HAD FOR
BILLS IN OF THE COMMITTEE THAT
I JUST COMPLETED. THEY WERE
NEARLY AS POPULAR AS THIS BILL
IS ABOUT TO BE FIVE. MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I AM HERE
BEFORE YOU DID ADVOCATE ON
BEHALF OF S. B. TWO EIGHTY
NINE- WHICH WE CREATED
CONVENIENCE STATEWIDE PRODUCER
FUNDED COLLECTION AND RECYCLING
PROGRAM FOR LOOSE. AND PRODUCT
EMBEDDED BATTERIES AS YOU'RE
PROBABLY AWARE BECAUSE OF THE
HAZARDOUS METALS ACROSS
MATERIALS THAT BATTERIES
CONTAIN. CALIFORNIA CLASS SIZE
BATTERIES AS HAZARDOUS WASTE.
AND EXPLICITLY BANNED BATTERIES
FROM SOLID WASTE LANDFILLS.
WE'RE DONE WITH THEIR LOOSE
BATTERIES IN PORTABLE
ELECTRONICS THEY'RE EXPECTED TO
SAVE THEM SORT THEM AND THEN
FIND INAPPROPRIATE DISPOSAL
OPTION. UNFORTUNATE BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY LACKS A
STREAMLINED AND CONVENE A
COLLECTION RECYCLING SYSTEMS
BATTERIES. AT THE MOMENT THIS
TENDS TO BE MORE THE EXCEPTION
THAN THE RULE- I WOULD ASK YOU
IS CONTACTING CONCERN THE BILL
BEFORE YOU. JUST TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO THINK ABOUT ALL YOUR
BATTERIES YOU THINK ABOUT ALL
THE DOUBLE A. AND TRIPLE A. AND
OTHER TYPES OF BATTERIES THAT
YOU GO THROUGH A YEAR. POWERING
ALL THE MANY DEVICES THAT ARE
SO DEEPLY EMBEDDED IN A
THOROUGHLY MODERN LIVES THESE
DAYS. REMOTE CONTROLS COMPUTER
KEYBOARDS MICE CLOCKS
FLASHLIGHT YOUR KIDS TOYS THAT
KIND OF THING. NOW THINK ABOUT
ALL THE RE CHARGEABLE DEVICES
EVERYBODY CARRIES THESE DAYS AS
WELL EACH ONE WITH ITS OWN
LITHIUM ION OR SIMILAR BATTERY.
NOW MULTIPLY YOUR BATTERIES BY
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION JUST
UNDER FORTY MILLION PEOPLE AND
CONSIDER HOW CHALLENGING IT IS
TO PROBABLY RECYCLE ALL THOSE
BATTERIES ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU
CONSIDER THE FACT THAT THERE'S
CURRENTLY NO UNIFIED SYSTEM IN
PLACE. IN CALIFORNIA FOR DOING
SO WERE DOING SO WELL. NOW
CONSIDER THIS ALARMING FACT AS
WELL EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THOSE
BATTERIES CONTAINS HAZARDOUS
TOXIC AND CORROSIVE MATERIALS.
LIKE MERCURY CADMIUM LITHIUM
AND LET WHEN IMPROPERLY
DISCARDED BATTERIES POSE A
SERIOUS ENVIRONMENTAL HAZARDS
BECAUSE OF A COMBINATION OF
INCREASED CONSUMPTION. A LACK
OF CONVENIENT DISPOSAL OPTIONS
HIGHER LEVELS OF TOXIC
BATTERIES AND PRODUCTS ARE
CONTINUALLY ENTERING THE WASTE
STREAM IN CALIFORNIA. WHEN
BATTERIES ARE TOSSED INTO THE
TRASH INSTEAD OF PROPPING
PROPERLY RECYCLED THE END UP IN
LANDFILLS WHERE THEY DECLARE
DECAY AND LEAK. AS DISPOSABLE
BATTERIES CORRODE THEIR
CHEMICAL SOAK INTO SOIL AND
CONTAMINATE GROUNDWATER AND
SURFACE WATER. DELICATE NO
RESTRAINT ECOSYSTEMS ARE
COMPROMISED WHEN EXPOSED TO
BATTERY CHEMICALS WHEN WE DRINK
FROM TAP WATER FAUCETS WE COULD
BE INGESTING DANGEROUS METALS.
LITHIUM BATTERIES IN PARTICULAR
THE ONES THAT YOU FIND YOUR
CHARGEABLE DEVICES CAN BE VERY
UNSTABLE. AND WHEN IMPROPERLY
DISPOSED TO POSE SERIOUS FIRE
HEALTH AND SAFETY HAZARDS IN
FACT OVER THE PAST DECADE. THE
MASSIVE INFLUX OF IMPROPERLY
DISPOSED OF LITHIUM ION
BATTERIES INTO CALIFORNIA'S WAY
STREAM HAS RESULTED IN AN
ALARMING NUMBER OF FIRES IN OUR
MATERIAL RECOVERY. FACILITIES
WASTE COLLECTION TRUCKS AND
LANDFILLS. WHEN LITHIUM ION
BATTERIES BURN IT RELY RELEASES
FLUORIDE GAS WHICH POSES
SERIOUS TOXIC THREATS TO THE
HEALTH. AND SAFETY OF WORKERS
FIRE FIGHTERS IN THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES THE
VAPORIZE COMPONENTS OF BURN
BATTERIES ALSO GET TRAPPED IN
THE ATMOSPHERE AND POLLUTE
LAKES AND STREAMS IN THE FORM
OF ACID RAIN. AS WELL AS
CONTRIBUTING TO GLOBAL WARMING.
ACCORDING TO A TWENTY EIGHTEEN
CALIFORNIA PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL SURVEY TWENTY OF THE
TWENTY SIX MATERIAL RECOVERY
FACILITIES. THAT THEY SURVEYED
EXPERIENCED AT LEAST ONE FIRE
DURING THE PREVIOUS TWO YEARS.
65% OF THOSE FIRES ALMOST TWO
THIRDS WERE ATTRIBUTED TO
IMPROPERLY DISCARDED. LITHIUM
ION BATTERIES. WITHOUT
DRAMATICALLY REDUCING THE
NUMBER OF LITHIUM ION BATTERIES
ENTERING CALIFORNIA'S WE STREAM
CALIFORNIA WILL SUFFER
ADDITIONAL FIRES. THAT WOULD
JEOPARDIZE WASTE OPERATIONS AND
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF WORKERS
AND OUR COMMUNITIES. YOU'LL BE
HEARING FIRSTHAND TODAY FROM
ONE OF THE LEAD WITNESSES. THIS
MORNING ABOUT THE DEVASTATING
IMPACT OF THESE FIRES UNDER ITS
PROVISIONS SB TWO EIGHTY NINE
WILL CREATE A CORD ANY SYSTEM.
OF FREE AND CONVENIENT
COLLECTION BINS FOR MOST LOSING
PRODUCT BETTER BATTERIES AT
RETAIL LOCATIONS ACROSS THE
STATE. TO OUR CONSUMERS REPLACE
BATTERIES INTO THE BINS FOR
PROPER DISPOSAL RATHER THAN
DISCARDING THEM ALONG WITH THE
REST OF THEIR HOUSEHOLD TRASH.
THE BILL WOULD ALSO CREATE A
CONSUMER OUTREACH AND EDUCATION
CAMPAIGN TO EDUCATE
CALIFORNIANS. AND ENCOURAGES
THE PROPER DISPOSAL OF ALL
TYPES OF BATTERIES THIS
APPROACH TO POLICY GENERALLY
FOR TWO IS EXTENDED PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY. WHICH S. B. TWO
EIGHTY NINE WILL APPLY TO
CONSUMER BATTERIES. HAS FOR
ROOTS AND KILL. LAW HONEST PRE
EMPLOYED TO EFFICIENTLY AND
EFFECTIVELY IMPROVE RECYCLING.
AN ARRAY OF HARD TO RECYCLE
MATERIALS FROM MATTRESSES TO
AUTOMOBILE TIRES TOO NOT
COINCIDENTALLY CAR BATTERIES AS
WELL. IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN THIS
LEGISLATOR PASSED BY NEARLY
UNANIMOUS VOTE SB TWO ONE TWO.
AUTHORED BY OUR COLLEAGUE
FORMER SENATOR HANNAH BETH
JACKSON WHICH REQUIRES
MANUFACTURERS IN THE
PHARMACEUTICAL INDUSTRY TO TAKE
BACK UNUSED AND WASTED NEEDLES.
AND DISCARDED DRUGS. S. B.
TWENTY NINE REPLICATES THIS
MODEL AND CONTINUES THIS VERY
POSITIVE TREND. OPPOSITION IS
LIKELY TO ASSERT THE BILL WOULD
INCREASE THE COST OF VITAL.
PRODUCTS TO CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS TO THAT I WOULD RE.
PER OUT THAT THE- OF THESE LIFT
ION INDUCED FIRES ARE ALREADY
BEING BORNE. BY OUR WASTE AND
RECYCLING OPERATORS HAVE
GOVERNMENTS FIRE PROFESSIONALS.
THE ENVIRONMENT PUBLIC HEALTH
AND CONSUMERS AS A PARTIAL
CONSEQUENCE CALIFORNIA
CITIZENSHIP FOR THE GARBAGE
RATES WILL INCREASE IN THE NEXT
THREE YEARS. AND SEES LITHIUM
ION BATTERIES CONTINUE TO CAUSE
TOXIC FIRES ACROSS THE STATE.
THE COST OF INSURING LOCAL
WASTE MANAGEMENT FACILITIES
CERTAIN TO INCREASE AS WELL.
THE PRODUCERS OF CONSUMER
BATTERIES DO NOT CURRENTLY
SHOULDER ANY OF THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE TOXIC
FIRES. IN OTHER IN VINYL HARM
CAUSED BY THEIR PRODUCTS. BUT
REALLY PRODUCES IS PART OF A
MORE EFFECTIVE END TO END
SYSTEM FOR RECYCLING SERVER
BATTERIES. WE CAN PREVENT THESE
DISASTERS FROM OCCURRING
THEREBY SAVING. THE COST OF
HIGHER GARBAGE REYES WHILE
PROTECTING THE HEALTH OF THE
PUBLIC REDUCING THE RISK TO
WASTE FOR CITY WORKERS. AND
BETTER SAFEGUARDING
CALIFORNIA'S LAND WATER AND AIR
BINDING MANUFACTURERS AND
RETAILERS TO A SYSTEM SUCH AS
THIS. IS EMINENTLY SENSIBLE AND
FAIR AND CONSISTENT WITH OTHER
SIMILAR EFFORTS IN CALIFORNIA
FOR THE BILL'S SPONSORS MY
OFFICE HAVE BEEN MEETING
REGULARLY WITH OPPOSITION. AND
WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO WE ARE
SENSITIVE TO THEIR CONCERNS AND
COMMITTED TO GENERATING
SUPPORT. AMONG ALL PARTIES WERE
LEAVING THE INTENT OF THE BILL
INTACT WITH ME VIRTUALLY TO
TESTIFY TODAY ARE JOE LUMBERTON
LOT MARIANA. EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF RETHINK WASTE EDUCATION
SCHMELZER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL I RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU.
THIRTY SANTA CLARA WILL GO YOUR
FOR WITNESS. YES I'M SORRY
JERRY TO BE CLEAR I DO AND I
DID ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS
GRACEFULLY. BOTH BOTH PRESENT
AND PAST TENSE. AND PERHAPS IN
THE FUTURE RIGHT HOPEFULLY ALL
AMENDMENTS WE EVER FOR THE
FORCE UPON IN THE FUTURE OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATE
ELECTRIFICATION LET'S GO TO-
TO- DILEMMA. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN HELLO- MEMBERS MY
NAME'S DELIVERY ON AYE SERVICE
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR RETHINK
WASTE. WE ARE A PUBLICLY OWNED
SOLID WASTE AGENCY IN SAN MATEO
COUNTY WE ARE A PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF SB TWO EIGHTY NINE.
OR AGENCY WAS FORMED IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO WE PROVIDE
ESSENTIAL SOLID WASTE
MANAGEMENT SERVICES IN OUR
COMMUNITY. TO ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THOUSAND
RESIDENTS ELEVEN THOUSAND
BUSINESS TOURS. EACH YEAR ARE
SIXTY MAKE SIXTEEN ACRE
FACILITY HANDLES OVER ABOUT
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND TONS OF
WASTE MATERIALS AND WE HAVE
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED. WORKERS
UNDER BASED ON SITE. IN TERMS
SIXTEEN. OR FACILITY EXPERIENCE
STATE THE FIRST CATASTROPHIC
EFFECTS OF THE LITHIUM ION
BATTERY DUES FIRE AT A
RECYCLING CENTER. THE FIRE
COMPLETELY DEVASTATED OUR
FACILITY SHUTTING US DOWN FOR
FOUR MONTHS AND CAUSED EIGHT
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
DAMAGES. WELL IT WAS SHUT DOWN
FOR FIFTY WORKERS WERE ALSO PER
LOG IT TOOK ABOUT A YEAR TO
FULLY REPAIR EVERYTHING. PRIOR
TO THE FIRE WE HAD ONE SERVICE
PROVIDER NOW WE NEED SEVEN TO
PROVIDE THE SAME COVERAGE OR
PREMIUMS OF STYLE SKYROCKETED
IN A BIG INCREASED TWELVE FOLD.
IN THAT TIME PERIOD INSURANCE
PROVIDERS ARE SIMPLY FINDING IT
TOO RISKY TO COVER FACILITIES
LIKE US DUE TO THE RECENT
NEGATIVE TREND PUBLIC BMI AND
FIRES. WE GO PER MINUTE MANY
PREVENTATIVE MEASURES TO REMOVE
THEM FROM THE WASTE STREAM BUT
STILL RECEIVE MANY BATTERIES
THAT THREATEN OUR FACILITIES
AND OUR WORKERS SAFETY. IN A
RECENT STUDY WE STILL HAD
RESTORE FINDING A LEVIN
BATTERIES PER HOUR IN OUR
FACILITY ANY ONE OF THEM COULD
LEAD TO ANOTHER FIRE. LIKE THE
ONE IN TWENTY SIXTEEN. ANOTHER
FIRE ON THAT MAGNITUDE COULD
CAUSE US TO LOSE ORANGE QUICKLY.
THESE BATTERIES THREATEN ENTIRE
OF OUR FUNDED WASTE COLLECTION
AND RECYCLING INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDS FIRES PROPOSED A PROPOSED
A SERIOUS SAFETY THREAT TO OUR
WORKERS UNFORTUNATELY THIS
ISSUE IS NOW BECOME COMMON.
RECYCLING FACILITIES ACROSS THE
NATION THIS IS A CRISIS BUT
NEED TO SOLUTION NOW WITH PMI
AND BATTERIES ARE BECOMING MORE
AND MORE COMMON EVERYDAY
PRODUCTS PRODUCTS. SB TWO
EIGHTY NINE IS CRITICAL TO
PROTECTING OUR INDUSTRY
INDUSTRIES INFRASTRUCTURE AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY OUR WORKERS
SAFETY I RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR
VOTE. ON THIS BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. BURKE
MEXICO TO. WHO'S YOUR NEXT.
THIS IS A SPONSORED. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS JASON SHELTER AND I'M
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL ONE OF THE THREE CO
SPONSORS OF SB TWO EIGHTY NINE
I ALSO REPRESENT PRISM A JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY THAT PROVIDES
RISK AND INSURANCE SERVICES TO
PUBLIC AGENCIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA THEY ARE ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL- MISTER
NEWMAN AND MR THE MARIANA
COVERED THE NEED FOR THE BILL
NICELY- I'M GONNA FOCUS ON WHAT
THE BILL ACTUALLY DOES AND TRY
TO PUT THAT INTO CONTEXT I
NOTING THAT THE OPPOSITION IS
REFERRED TO IT AS COMPLEX AND-
CONCEIVED. WE OBVIOUSLY
DISAGREE SB TWO EIGHTY NINE
ESTABLISHES A PERFORMANCE BASED
COLLECTION RECYCLING SYSTEM FOR
ALL THESE BATTERIES IN CONSUMER
PRODUCTS THAT CONTAIN NON
REMOVABLE BATTERIES- THIS IS A
STRUCTURE THAT WE'VE SEEN
BEFORE PRODUCERS WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO DESIGN FUND- AND
OPERATE A PLAN THAT WOULD BE
APPROVED BY CAL RECYCLE- THERE.
ARE- A NUMBER OF ELEMENTS TO
THE- PLAN AT ALL. A FEW PER.
GOALS THAT WILL HELP THE
PROGRAM STAY ON TRACK- BUT
OTHERWISE IT'S FREE THE
INDUSTRY UP TO IMPLEMENT A
PROGRAM THAT WORKS FOR THEM IT
IS BEING. PERFORMANCE BASED
REGULATORY STRUCTURE AS OPPOSED
TO A COMMANDING CONTROL TYPE OF
REGULATORY STRUCTURE. I DO
WANNA REMIND THE COMMITTEE THAT
THIS'S BEEN DONE BEFORE IN
CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY QUITE
EFFECTIVELY. SB TWO EIGHTY NINE
IS BASED ON RECENT LEGISLATION
TO ENACT SIMILAR PROGRAMS FOR
LEFTOVER DRUGS IN USED NEEDLES-
IF CALIFORNIA CAN ASK THE
MAKERS OF VITAL HEALTH CARE
RELATED PRODUCTS YOU TO COLLECT
THEIR ITEMS. WE CAN CERTAINLY
ASK THAT OF BATTERY MAKERS- THE
FINAL VERSION OF THE DRUG
SHARPSVILLE WAS NEGOTIATED WITH
THE PRODUCERS AND PASSED BY
BOTH HOUSES. I WITH
OVERWHELMING MAJORITIES AND I
WANT TO BE CLEAR OF THE AUTHOR
AND THE CO SPONSORS HAVE BEEN
AND WILL CONTINUE WORKING WITH
THE OPPONENTS- AND WE WERE WE
ARE OPEN TO FINDING SOLUTIONS
TO THEIR CONCERNS. THERE IS NO
QUESTION THAT THE BATTERIES AND
THE PRODUCTS COVERED BY THIS
BILL HAVE EXTRAORDINARY END OF
LIFE AND TAX- FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS. ZACKS UNIVERSAL WAIT
AROUND. SMALLHOLDER IF IT DOES
NOT YOU TO REVENUE THOUGHT
ABSOLUTELY TRYING TO CAN. WITH
SIDES. ABSOLUTELY SO WITHOUT
MISTER CHAIR WE JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR THANK YOU
OKAY. SORRY THANK YOU- LET
LET'S NOW GO I DON'T SEE ANYONE
HERE IN THIS ROOM ARE TWENTY
FORTY FOUR ADDITIONAL SUPPORT-
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINES YOU
WANT TO WEIGH IN IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IF YOU WERE IN
SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. ONE NINE ZERO FOUR
SUPPORT WE WILL GO LINE OF
EIGHT TOP FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING FOR
NUMBER TWENTY TWENTY ALL WITH
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE
WE'RE PROUD TO CO SPONSOR AT
THE TWO EIGHT NINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANKS TO A LINE OF
THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS JOHN
KENNEDY WITH THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THE BILL. THANK YOU.
NEXT TO VOTE SO LINE OF THIRTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NUMBER
ONE ONE ONE THIRTY FOUR ONE
THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS JIM
LINDBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRENCH COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THE NEXT. EXTRA
GO TO LINE ONE MOMENT SORRY
ABOUT THAT. ONE EIGHTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AMERICA
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION VOTERS
IN SUPPORT OF ATHLETES YOU
EIGHTY NINE. THANK YOU MEXICO
LINE OF ONE TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
SHARE MEMBERS- TO **** IT UP ON
BEHALF OF THE FOLLOWING I
NATIONAL COMMISSION ACTION
COUNCIL. THE STATION OF NORTH
AMERICA STOP WAIT AND WESTERN
FOSTER WASTE MANAGEMENT
AUTHORITY IN SUPPORT SB TWO
EIGHTY NINE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT TO GOAL LINE OF ONE
TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING CAPTAIN FREEMAN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
TO GOAL LINE OF ONE THIRTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO SURE
MEMBERS THERE TOLD HIM TO HAVE
A BIGGER CALIFORNIA'S CITIES IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO EIGHTY NINE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MEXICO
CAROLINA ONE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MEMBERS KILL
ROBINSON REGISTERED SUPPORT FOR
THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANKS TO A LINE OF ONE THIRTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
CHRISTINE LOQUITUR CALLAGY IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MEXICO LIGHT OF ONE THIRTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MARSHAWN K. ON BEHALF OF THE
RESOURCE RECOVERY COALITION OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. THANK YOU
THANKS FOR THE LINE OF FORTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ERIC
SAID WITH MERCED COUNTY
REGIONAL WASTE MANAGEMENT
AUTHORITY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
S. B. TWENTY NINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND ACCESSIBLE I
KNOW OF- ONE THIRTY TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS MAX PERRY ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF LONG
BEACH ALSO IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO
FURTHER SUPPORT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
SO MUCH. OKAY ARE SO THERE'S NO
NO ONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION- NO
OF TIMES ARE KNOWN AS IN
SUPPORT ON THE PHONES- LET'S
NOT LET'S NOT TURN A OPPOSITION
FOLKS WANT TO RAISE CONCERNS
AND- BUSINESS CARDS. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SCOTT COVERING
HER BATH OF THE RECHARGEABLE
BATTERY ASSOCIATION. WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE
PROPONENTS AND THE AUTHOR IN
FACT IN JANUARY WE SUGGESTED
THAT THEY ADOPT THE- DC MODEL.
THIS IS THE FIRST OF ITS KIND
IN THE NATION IT TOOK EFFECT
THIS YEAR. CREATIVE RECOVERY
RECYCLING PROGRAM. THAT REQUEST
WAS REJECTED OUTRIGHT TO GIVE
YOU AN UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
THIS BILL DOES. IT ALLOWS
CALPERS CYCLE TO IMPOSE FEES ON
STEWARDSHIP ORGANIZATIONS IT
ALLOWS EVERY OTHER STATE AGENCY
THAT MAY BE IMPACTED BY WASTE
OR FIRE OR HAZARDOUS MATERIALS
TO ALSO IMPOSE FEES IN THE
BILL. IT ALLOWS RETAILERS TO
IMPOSE ANY FEES THEY WANT ON
STEWARDSHIP PROGRAM SO WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. FLOOR SPACE
INSURANCE EMPLOYEE TRAINING
EMPLOYEE BENEFITS. ALL OF.
THESE COSTS WILL BE PASSED ON
TO CONSUMERS IN THE FORM OF
HIGHER PRICES WHAT THE BILL
ALSO DOES WHICH WILL INCREASE
THESE COSTS IS. HE HAS CERTAIN
EXEMPTIONS SO EXEMPTS CONSUMER
MEDICAL DEVICES FOR EXAMPLE
WHICH WERE NOT EXEMPT IN DC I
UNDERSTAND THE PROPONENTS ARE
NOW TALKING TO OTHER GROUPS
THAT EXEMPTING THEM TO. THE
SMALLER THE UNIVERSE THE HIGHER
THE PRICES. THE MATTRESS BILL
DOESN'T EXEMPTS SOME MATTRESSES
THEY'RE ALL COVERED BUT THEY'RE
LOOKING TO DO TO CARVE OFF
OPPOSITION IS TO SHRINK THE
UNIVERSE. AS IT RELATES TO
FIRES THIS BILL IS GOING TO
CREATE THE PUT BINS IN STORES
SO TARGET VAPE SHOPS OR
WHATEVER. THERE'S NO SIZE
RESTRICTION ON THE BATTERIES
THAT CAN GO IN THESE BINS THERE
FIFTY POUND CONSUMER BATTERIES
WILL BE TOSSED INTO THESE BINS.
ALONG WITH BUTTON CELLS AS WELL
AS ALL THESE PRODUCTS THAT HAVE
BATTERIES IN THEM TOYS SMALL
DRILLS WATCHES PHONES COMPUTERS
YOU NAME IT. AND THEY'RE ALL
GONNA SMASH ON TOP OF ONE
ANOTHER SO NO WONDER THE WASTE
AGENCIES SUPPORT THE BILL
BECAUSE YOU'RE PUTTING THE FIRE
RISK IN THE STORES. AS RELATES
TO RATES AND DATES. BUT THIS
BILL SET UP AS A SCENARIO WHERE
A VAPE SHOP CAN ACTUALLY GET
PAID TO PUT A PIN IN THEIR
SHOP. AND THAT WOULD TAKE AWAY
THE OBLIGATION OF TARGET FOR
EXAMPLE IT'S IN THE SAME
REGION. HOW YOU GONNA MEET YOUR
RATES AND DATES IF A SHOP THAT
HAS ZERO FOOT TRAFFIC COLLECTS
HAS THE BINS FOR THE BATTERIES.
OWN BY THE WAY HE PUT VAPES IN
THOSE BINS IT'S A VIOLATION OF
FEDERAL LAW- YOU KNOW AGAIN THE
DC LAW WAS NO PANACEA. BUT AT
LEAST IT WAS. COGENT COHERENT
IN NEGOTIATED OVER SEVERAL
YEARS. WHERE IS THIS. SEEMS TO
BE A WISH LIST FOR THE
PROPONENTS. AND IT'S NOT. IT IN.
AND THE COST WILL BE BORNE BY
CONSUMER. FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECT THAT WERE. QUESTION
OVER. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERRANO FRAZIER- OKAY OTHER
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO RAISE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL HI I
DON'T SEE WHAT ELSE IN EITHER
OF THE ROOMS IN PERSON HOW
ABOUT ON THE PHONE LINES
MATAMATA. THANK YOU FOR IN
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. WE WILL GO LINE
OF SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BONDOC THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION OPPOSED TO SP TWO
EIGHT NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO TOWLINE OF THE SEVENTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DON
KHAKI MCCUE CAP CAME TO THIRTY
SOME HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION. YEAH IT'S
UNFORTUNATE BECAUSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. AND WE DO HAVE
TO MARK CUBAN UP ONE MOMENT
MISTER CHAIR. WE'LL GO TO LINE
ONE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN FIRST AVENUE MALL ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF TWENTY.
CHINA'S OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE JACOB
KATHY WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF
HOME APPLIANCE MANUFACTURERS WE
ARE OPPOSED TO SB TWO EIGHT
NINE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHORED FURTHER ON
THIS BILL. THANK YOU AND NEXT
OVER TO LINE OF ONE THIRTY
EIGHT ONE THREE EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE ADAMANTLY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN PERSPECTIVE
OPPOSITION. AND LACK OF MY
COMMENT WITH THE- THE MONEY TO
WORK BURKE. WISH TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR TO FIND RESOLUTION
CREATED THANKS. THANK YOU AND
WE HAVE NO FURTHER OPPOSITION
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. OKAY
WILL COME BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE MAY SEEM IF YOU
THROUGH THE COURSE OF THE
DIALOGUE YOU'LL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY CENTER TO. ANSWER
SOME OF THE CONCERNS HAVE BEEN
RAISED BY. MISTER GOVERNOR
OTHERS- OKAY LET'S GO TO YOU
CENTER DOLLARS. THANK YOU ISSUE
CARE. SO LOOK I THINK THIS IS A
THE BILL THAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN
I'LL JUST TELL YOU THAT I DON'T
DISAGREE WITH THE FACT THAT
FACT I DID A RECYCLING BILL
FOR. ELECTRIC CARS LIKE WHAT'S
THE PLAN AND IT'S A STUDY BILL
AND GOT PASS GOT SIGNED LAW BUT
I THINK. MY QUESTION TO YOU IS.
FROM MY OBSERVATIONS BILL FOR
FATHERS HEFTY FINES NUMBER ONE
I THINK THAT ARE. OUTRAGEOUS
AND WHAT AT THE END OF THE DAY
WE GOT TO GET THE JOB DONE WE
GOT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT
HAVING FIRES AND THAT AND WE
HAVE A- REASONABLE. AMOUNT OF.
THE OF THE CONSUMER BUY IN
BECAUSE IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT
YOU JUST HAPPEN TO IT TO
MANUFACTURE THE MANUFACTURE BY
AS WELL YOU WE'VE HEARD A LOT
OF OPPOSITION AND I WANT TO
HAVE YOU. IF THE ANSWER TO ME
HOW WE GONNA STOP THE FIRES.
THAT AT THE LOCAL LEVEL WHEN
YOU IF YOU THROW THESE ALL IN
THE SAME BAND YOU HAVE
OPPORTUNITY FOR FIRE. AND SO
WHAT'S THE THOUGHT PROCESS ON.
THAT WOULD BASICALLY WHERE DOES
SHIFTING LIABILITIES WHAT I
HEARD THE TESTIMONY OF AND I'M
NOT INTERESTED IN SHIFTING
LIABILITY I'M INTERESTED IN
FIGURE OUT A WAY THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY CYCLE IS VERY SAFELY.
AND THAT YOU KNOW WE GET BUY IN
FROM THE PUBLIC. AT APPRECIATE
THAT SIR. SO I DON'T THINK THE
INTENT HERE IS NOT TO SHIFT
LIABILITY IT'S- YOU KNOW IT'S
PROBABLY NOT TO CREATE AN
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE. RACHEL
IS SO I WOULD KIND OF
STIPULATED THIS IS A HARD
PROBLEM TO SOLVE. RIGHT I MEAN
AS AS I THINK I MENTIONED MY
TESTIMONY. THESE PRODUCTS ARE
UBIQUITOUS- AND IF THERE IS NO
CENTRALIZED SYSTEM AT THE
MOMENT THAT IS WORKING CLEARLY
IT IS NOT WORKING- IF WE'RE
GETTING ELEVEN BATTERY LITHIUM
ION BATTERIES PER HOUR IN IN
WASTE. MANAGEMENT FACILITIES.
BACK TO MISTER GOVERNOR'S POINT
ABOUT- YOU KNOW SOME BATTERIES
BEING TOO LARGE THAT THE YOU
KNOW DO YOU CAN DESIGN PROGRAMS
THAT TAKE THAT INTO ACCOUNT-
YOU CAN ALSO DESIGN PROGRAMS
WERE THOSE. THE BINS WILL BE
EMPTIED ON A REGULAR BASIS SO
WOULD PREVENT. YOU KNOW THOSE
SORTS OF- RISKY SCENARIOS. BUT
THIS IS A CLEAR IT'S A WORK IN
PROGRESS. WHERE WE START IS TO
YOUR POINT WE YOU KNOW WE'VE
GOT A PROBLEM THAT IS
DESPERATELY IN NEED OF.
ADDRESSING IN CALIFORNIA THE
ANSWER WE'VE BEEN GLAD TO WORK
WITH. ALL STAKEHOLDERS SO FAR
GLAD TO CONTINUE DOING THAT I
THINK THAT'S THAT'S COMMON TO
THE EXPERIENCE OF MOST OF THE
CPR PROGRAMS- THAT IT'S AN AREA
PROCESS AND MY GOAL AT THE END
OF THE DAY IS TO GET. TO A
POINT WHERE MANUFACTURERS
ESPECIALLY BUT ALSO RETAILERS.
CAN UNDERSTAND- AND
PARTICIPATE. IN A PROGRAM IT
MAKES SENSE TO THEM AS WELL. SO
WITH MADE HOW HOW DO YOU JUST.
OF YOU BABY- GOT A CALL. I
GUESS MAYBE NEED LIKE THE WORD.
LIABILITY TRANSFER BUT YOU
BASICALLY ARE SAYING TO THE
MANUFACTURE AND TO THE RETAILER
THAT THEY GOT TO DEAL WITH IT
INSTEAD OF AT THE- AT THE-
WASTE RECEIVING A POINT. WHAT
CHART I MEAN DIDN'T ALWAYS
BETTER TO MAKE THEIR WAY YOU
KNOW TO SOME SORT OF WASTE
MANAGEMENT PROCESS WHAT WE
DON'T WANT IS FOR THEM TO BE
INTERMINGLED YOU KNOW WITH
COMMON HOUSEHOLD TRASH- AND SO
THAT'S THE EIGHT THINK THAT'S
INHERENT IN THE DESIGN HERE SO
I IT YEAH I DON'T WANT TO GET
IN ARGUMENTS SEMANTICS BUT WE
DO WE DO WANT TO SHIFT
RESPONSIBILITY- YOU KNOW HAVE
LIABILITY COMES WITH THAT I
THINK WE DESIGNED THE SYSTEM
PROPERLY THAT WE CAN WE CAN
ADDRESS QUESTIONS OF LIABILITY
TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S NO
UNDUE EXPOSURE. SO THIS IS THE
POLICY COMMITTEE WHERE WE TALK
ABOUT HOW IT WORKS AND THEN
AND- SO FOR THE DETAIL OF IT WE
DIDN'T HAVE TOO MUCH. TROUBLE
UNTIL WE HAD AYE ON LITHIUM
WHICH IS WHAT'S CAUSING. IT
TYPICALLY IF YOU PUT. THE EVER
READY FLASHLIGHT BATTERY.
BECAUSE THEY WERE THE ONES THAT
REALLY CAUSES TIME THAT THE IN
THAT REALLY BECAUSE OF THE
FIRES AND SO NOW WE HAVE
MIXTURE OF ALL THOSE IN IS
BECAUSE AND THISWAS WHERE WE
TALK ABOUT THIS BECAUSE THIS
BILL ACTUALLY PILLS THE TWO
THOUSAND AND- SIX. RECYCLING
MANDATE THAT WE HAD AVAILABLE
AND SO. I THINK WE'RE I THINK
THIS NEEDS SOME WORK IS WHAT
I'M TRYING TO SAY I DON'T THINK
WERE I THINK THE OPPOSITION HAS
SOME LEGITIMATE- SADISTIC THAT
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED AND I. AND
I'M NOT INTERESTED IN SHIFTING
LIABILITY I'M INTERESTED IN
ACTUALLY GETTING THE JOB DONE.
AND IF IT'S EDUCATING-
SOMETHING ON PACKAGING THAT
SAYS HEY THIS HAS AYE ON THE
THEME BATTERY IN IT CAN'T BE SO
I'M SURE THAT'S ALREADY THERE.
BUT IT'S NOT HAPPENING SO WE
NEED TO DO AN EDUCATION.
PROCESS TO THE PUBLIC AS WELL
THAT THESE CAN BECAUSE THEY
THEY ARE CAUSING FIRES I SHOULD
SAY. BUT IT ALL WE'RE DOING IN
MY OPINION THIS BILL IS JUST
TRANSFERRING. WHERE THE FIRES
ARE GONNA START EITHER GUNFIGHT
STARTED TO. RETAILER WHETHER
RECYCLING THERE OR THEY'RE
GOING TO AND START AT THE PLACE
WHERE THEY'RE YOU KNOW LEVIN
TODAY SO FOR ME I'M A NO. UNTIL
WE GET A LITTLE BETTER DETAIL
AND I THINK THAT WE HAVE TO
BRING ALONG THE MANUFACTURERS.
AND THE RETAILERS- IN THIS
CONVERSATION I'M NOT FAMILIAR
WITH THE MINUTES AT THE-
OPPOSITION DRAFTED BUT I'M
HOPING THEY'LL GIVE ME A COPY
THOSE- SO WE CAN TALK ABOUT
THOSE IN THE FUTURE THANK YOU.
I MEAN I KNOW THE BILL'S HAVING
JUDICIARY NEXT I THINK THAT'S
WHERE SOME OF THOSE- ISSUES OF
CIVIL PENALTIES IN THE RECIPE.
YEAH NO I UNDERSTAND I DON'T
KNOW YOUR YOUR YOUR- YOUR APPS
WITHIN YOUR RIGHTS TO ME THANK
GOODNESS. YES MATT A LOT OF
THOSE MEETINGS BE IF YOU'RE
INTO. AT ALL RIGHT- GO TO
CENTER AGAINST THE- GOOD MORE
AND THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
EXTENDED PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY BILL BEFORE US I
AM CURIOUS SOME OF YOUR-
ADVOCATES OPPOSE A- BOTTLE
RECYCLE. EXTENDED PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY AND FIND THAT-
THE OTHER ADVOCACY AS SUCH I
HAVE A QUESTION ON YOUTH MODEL
THIS AFTER THE NEEDLES. AND
SHARPS BILL WHICH IS A
DIFFERENT AND PRODUCT MEAN WE
NOBODY WANTS TO TOUCH SOMEBODY
ISSUES NEEDLE BUT AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LASSEN COUNTY IS
SAID TO A LOT OF THESE
BATTERIES UNLESS YOU'VE GOT
SOME SORT OF PRESSURE THERE'S
GOOD THERE'S NO FIRE THEY'RE
SAFE. YOU COULD PUT THEM IN A
CHURCH SO D. HERE BECAUSE
YOU'RE YOU'RE PRETTY
PRESCRIPTIVE ON I'M ON PAGE
THREE WITH THE REQUIREMENTS
THAT YOU KNOW THE RETAILERS
WERE FEASIBLE. SERVICE AN
AUTHORIZED COLLECTOR SO I GUESS
EQUIPMENT THE OBVIOUS QUESTION
IS ONE WITH A RETAIL OUTLET NOT
BE FEASIBLE TO COLLECT
BATTERIES. WHAT DO YOU ENVISION
THAT THEY WOULD DO IT AND THEN
WHY WOULD YOU NOT ALLOW THE
STEWARDSHIP PROGRAM THE PEOPLE
TESTED TO GO CRAZY I MEAN
THERE'S- NOT NOT GEARING IT
TOWARDS NEEDLES AND SAY OKAY WE
NEED ALL THE SPECIAL
REQUIREMENTS AND WHO'S GOING TO
HANDLE THEM. BUT BRING THEM TO
YOUR CHURCH YOUR SYNAGOGUE OR
TEMPLE WHATEVER YOU GET
WHATEVER YOU GOT TO COLLECT
THESE THINGS SCHOOLS WHY WOULD
YOU NOT WHAT WHY WOULD YOU NOT
HAVE MET TO SCHOOLS SO. THAT'S
WHAT IS NOT FEASIBLE ABOUT THE
RETAILERS I GUESS THE WAY I'M
READING THE TEXT I'M SORRY THE
SENATE WOULD WHAT IS NOT
FEASIBLE- PROVIDED SOME LEEWAY
FOR. IN A PROGRAM DEFINITION
BUT I DATE I THINK IT'S PRESUME
THAT YOU KNOW MOST RETAILERS
WHO DEAL AND LET THE LION OF
THE BATTERIES. WOULD WOULD BE
PRESUMED THESE FEASIBLE RIGHT
THE MINUTE THEY DO YOU KNOW
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO. IS TO
CREATE AN END TO END SYSTEM
THAT HAS BALANCE NOT UNLIKE
THAT YOU DON'T PLEASE DON'T
HOLD IT AGAINST ME- YOU KNOW
THE RECYCLING OF BOTTLES. THAT
AND SO I YOU KNOW THE
DISTINCTION YOU'RE MAKING
BETWEEN THE NEW PROGRAM AND
THIS PROGRAM. NO I WOULD ARGUE
IS THE SORT OF INCIDENTAL WHAT
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS A
DRESS. A SERIOUS PROBLEM WHERE
YOU HAVE THE UBIQUITOUS
PRODUCT- AND THERE'S NO YOU
KNOW SORT OF LIKE BALANCE
NETWORK THAT THAT THAT EXISTS
TO ENSURE YOU KNOW THEIR THEIR
ULTIMATE DISPOSAL RIGHT THROUGH
YOU KNOW THROUGH THE PRODUCT
LIFECYCLE TO. DATE THE RETURN
OF SOME YOU KNOW SAFE DISPOSAL
MECHANISM. AND SO I DO I DO
APPRECIATE THAT YOU'VE ALLOWED
THAT YOU KNOW PUTTING THEM INTO
DANCE IS NOT GONNA CAUSE A
FIGHT EVERY TIME THAT'S NOT
WHAT CAUSES THE FIRES. WHAT
CAUSES THE FIRES AS THEIR
INTERMINGLED WITH WITH OTHER
KINDS OF. WASTE AND THEN THEIR
CRUSHER OTHERWISE DAMAGED BUT
IT'S AND I ALSO POINT OUT THAT
DID YOU KNOW THIS MAY BE THE
IMPETUS FOR SOLVING THIS
PROBLEM BUT BUT OTHER KINDS OF
BATTERY KIND OF CONVENTION THAT
RISK. POSED AN IMMENSE AMOUNT
OF ENVIRONMENTAL DANGER RIGHTS
OF THERE'S NOTHING WRONG. WITH
SOLVING THIS PROBLEM
COLLECTIVELY AND SO- YOU KNOW
THE STATE TO YOUR POINT OF AT
STATE WHAT YOU PLAN. BY A KNOW
THIS IS A PAUL COMMITTEE WE
HAVE BEEN. TO WORK WITH- ALL.
VERTICALLY UP. TO GET TO. OF
GOTTEN THERE YET BUT- YOU KNOW
MORE THAN TO GET TO DOING SO
THIS THIS WILL GO TO- ARE- THE
OTHER HOUSING WILL CONTINUE
WORKING ON IT THAT'S THAT IS NO
DIFFERENT THAN THE EXPERIENCE I
THINK WITH TWO TWELVE. I TO MY
POINT WAS THAT NEEDLES AND
SYRINGES HAVE A CERTAIN
LIMITATION. AND MODELING THE
PROGRAM AFTER THAT THAT HAS
LIMITATION I DON'T BELIEVE
THAT. THE COLLECTION OF THE
BATTERIES WUNSCH SEGREGATE THEM
FROM OTHER HARMFUL. AND THE-
THE PICK UP IN THE STEWARDSHIP
PROGRAM CAN DESIGN THAT IS
GOING TO CREATE. A HARM DEBT
THAT I CAN THINK OF RIGHT NOW
YOU'RE ALSO NOT SOLVING THE
PROBLEM RIGHT IF THEY IF
THEY'RE STILL DECENTRALIZED
RADIANCE OF THE YOU KNOW
THERE'S TWO COMPONENTS TO IT
CONSIDERS THE SAFETY. BUT
THERE'S ALSO CREATING A
CENTRALIZED SYSTEM. RIGHT WHERE
AND DOES DOES PRODUCTS GET RE
DIRECTED TOWARD YOU KNOW SOME
DID YOU KNOW DISPOSAL SOURCE.
SO IF YOU JUST ASSUME THAT'S
AFFECTING WHAT WE DO NOW WE
KNOW THAT CHURCHES AND SCHOOLS
WILL HAVE. IN RENO ABOUT
ELECTRONIC RECYCLING CAMPAIGNS
IT IS. NOT SOLVING THE PROBLEM.
RIGHT NOW. THAT SERVICE IS
ATTEMPTED THAT ON A GONNA MORE.
NATURE OF SYSTEMIC. OKAY ON
PAGE FOUR OF OUR STAFF REPORT
UNDER J. FOR TALKING ABOUT THE-
EPA'S ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
TASK FORCE. AND RECYCLING IN
AREAS AND COMMUNITIES THAT FACE
UNIQUE CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED
WITH PROPER WASTE MANAGEMENT.
WHAT DO WHAT'D. UNDER THIS
SYSTEM WHAT WITH THAT WHAT WHAT
DOES HE NEED CHALLENGES BE. BUT
THEN THEY JUST DON'T RECYCLE. I
MEAN THAT MIGHT HAVE CHALLENGE
CHALLENGE THAT WAS JUST A MAY
NOT HAVE ACCESS TO- THE SAME
KIND OF WASTE MANAGEMENT
PROGRAMS WE DO THEM AND HAVE
ACCESS TO RETAILERS SO AS AN
EXAMPLE THAT THAT CONTINUE KEPT
UP CAME UP- MOST THE FOLKS HERE
IN THE CAPITAL GET USED TO
RECYCLING OF BATTERIES HERE.
RIGHT THERE WAS THE BEEN BY THE
ELEVATOR AND SO WHEN THE
CAPITAL WAS CLOSED NOBODY KNEW
WHERE TO TAKE THEIR BATTERIES
YEAH AND I THINK YOU HAVE YOU
HAVE THAT PROBLEM IN MANY
COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY THEY
SIMPLY DON'T KNOW THERE IS NO
OBVIOUS EVEN IF THERE'S NO
OBVIOUS DESTINATION SO THE GOAL
IS. TO WORK WITH US COMMUNITIES
THERE'S A BROADER- COMPONENT OF
PUBLIC EDUCATION AWARENESS
THAT'S THAT'S EXPRESSLY
PROVIDED FOR IN THE BILL YEAH
AND SO WE WOULD DO THOSE THINGS
TO TRY AGAIN TO DESIGN A SYSTEM
EFFECTIVELY FROM SCRATCH. THAT
THAT ADDRESSES. THIS THIS VERY
CHALLENGING PROBLEM. RIGHT NOW
I'M JUST SAY I. YOUR HAVE. THE
PRODUCERS EXTEND CREATE A
PROGRAM THAT'S GOING TO MAKE IT
EASY COLLECTED AT EVERY EVERY
PLACE SO I ASSUME THAT THE SAME
TYPE OF COLLECTIONS IN THE
GROCERY STORES OR THE CHURCHES
WERE IF IT WERE TO GO TO- GET
EXTENDED TO OTHERS. DEREK I WE
WANT TO CREATE REGIONAL
INCENTIVES FOR PRODUCERS TO
REACH OUT. TO THEM. FOR
RECYCLING. OKAY THAT'S ALL I
HAVE MISTER. OKAY- WE ASK YOU
WHAT WHAT IS YOUR THOUGHT WHAT
ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS D. C.
MODEL AND SENATOR AND WHAT WE
MIGHT GET A LEARN FROM THEM I
KNOW IT'S BEEN A LITTLE BIT
ALREADY BUT- SO YOU KNOW IT
MIGHT. EXPERIENCES FOR
MICROSERVICES FOLKS WHO WOULD
BE A WE THE SUPPORTERS MY
OFFICE VIEWS THE DC MODEL AS A
GOOD REFERENCE POINT IN ANALOG
AYE AYE I'M NOT TOTALLY SURE
MISTER GOVERNOR FIRST TO THAT
DID YOU KNOW THEY PROPOSED
SOMETHING EQUIPMENT TO IT WE
DID AND WE REJECTED OUT OF HAND
I THINK QUITE THE OPPOSITE IS
TRUE- WE THINK IT'S ACTUALLY A
GOOD REFERENCE POINT- AND SO
THE OTHER PROBABLY DIFFERENCES
THAT ARE INTRINSIC TO
CALIFORNIA- BUT WE'RE IN A
WOULD LIKE TO WORK VERY HARD
AND INTERRUPTING SOMETHING
THAT'S APPROPRIATE OR STATE
THAT. DIED IN MERE IS A SUCCESS
THE SCENE TO SHOOT. BLACKROCK
HOW DO YOU BRING YOU CAN YOU.
OKAY I MEAN I KNOW ALL THESE
ALL THESE BILLS ARE WORK IN
PROGRESS AND AGO SHE ARE ALWAYS
TRICKY- CERTAINLY HOPE YOU CAN
CONTINUE TO HAVE A FRUITFUL
DIALOGUE. AS A THING WAS A LONG
TERM- I'M BY MALES TIME
OBVIOUSLY MYSELF INVOLVED WITH
THE PEER CONVERSATIONS AND-
SEVERAL OF SO YOU KNOW MISTER
JUST TELL YOU KNOW COMPLICATED
IS ALL THE WAY THROUGH- AND WE
ACCEPT THAT AS MY RECORDS AB
AND WILL CONTINUE TO SEND
REGULAR. AND SO HERE I DON'T
THINK ANY MEMBER OF THIS
COMMITTEE WOULD DISAGREE WITH
THE NEED TO ADDRESS THIS
PROBLEM- AND SO THE TO THE
BEAUTIFUL LET'S SAY PROCESSES
WILL HAVE MULTIPLE YOU KNOW
CHECKPOINTS AT WHICH TO REGAIN
YOUR SUCCESS AND I'M COMMITTED
TO WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION-
TO TAKE NOT JUST THERE THERE
ARE OBJECTIONS INTO ACCOUNT BUT
ALSO THE REALITY. THEIR
SITUATIONS THAT WOULD MAKE SOME
OF THE WORDS. OKAY THANK YOU.
HEY WE GET TAKE THAT AS A CLOSE.
YES OUR OUR SPONSORS ALL WHO
THIRD SO NOW WITH BERMAN SPOTS
NINE ZERO CUSTOM THE BILL.
LET'S WAS OPEN UP THE- CAN.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB EIGHTY NINE
BY SENATOR NEWMAN THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY ALLEN
HI. I BATES EIGHT SNOW DALLY.
DALLI NOW BEEN SALAS GONZALEZ I
SKINNER. SKINNER AYE STERN-
STERN AYE WHY CASKEY. BY YEAH
FIVE OKAY I THINK WE CAN CLOSE
THE ROLE ON THAT ONE FOR THE
FIRST TIME WE CAN CLOSER ON THE
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH AT ENTER AND IN A COURT
APPOINTED WORK AGAIN THIS PART
SO LET'S OPEN THE ROLE FOR
VARIOUS BILLS THAT WE HAVE
BEFORE US LET'S START WITH ITEM
ONE SB SIX FORTY THREE THIS THE
ACTUAL A BILL. ON THE FUEL CELL.
ELECTRIC VEHICLE WORKING GROUP-
CONSULTANT CALL THE ROLL. AND
I'M NUMBER ONE SB SIX FORTY
THREE BY SENATOR ARCHER LETTER
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST. AMENDED RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION- THE CURRENT
VOTE IS FIVE TWO ZERO WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I'M THE VICE CHAIR
VOTING HI SKINNER. SKINNER AYE
STERN OF EVIDENCE TURN I. SEVEN
ZERO OKAY THANK YOU WILL CALL
THAT THAT THAT'S OUT WILL CLOSE
RULE ON THAT ONE WE DO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FOR REST HERE-
AND A SPECIAL REQUEST. THIS IS
THIS IS ITEMS THE THREE AND
TWELVE SB TWO SEVENTY THREE BY
HERTZBERG SB FIVE FIFTIES ABOUT
CASKEY. IN SPITE OF THAT AUTHOR
AYE AYE AYE RECOMMENDING AYE
VOTE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR-
CONSULT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BATES HI EIGHT I SKINNER.
SKINNER I STERN. STERN HI.
MARCH TEN DOLLARS UNANIMOUS.
WE'RE GONNA CLOSE ROLE IN THAT
THANK YOU LET'S GO TO THE PRO
TIMES BILL IS SB ONE FOUR TIMES
BILL US INTERACTIONS ON SEA
LEVEL RISE. CRYPTOPAY CORAL.
IT'S AN ITEM NUMBER TWO S. B.
ONE BY CENTER ATKINS THE MOTION
IS TO PASS THE FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTERS
TO ZERO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
AM VICE CHAIR NOT VOTING. BATES
DOLLY. PHTHALATE NOTE SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STERN BOB STERN
HIGHWAY CASKEY. HI CASKEY I'VE-
FIVE TWENTY FIVE TO ONE WE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE ON THAT. AND
DONE. AND SEND THAT TO
APPROPRIATIONS ALRIGHT LET'S
NOW GO WE KNOW THAT WE
DEMOCRATS ACCOUNT LET'S GO TO
HI LEYVA CENTER LEAVE HIS BILL
SB THREE SEVENTY TWO. ON
SERVICE- WAS AT ALWAYS KALRA.
ITEM NUMBER FOR SB THREE
SEVENTY TWO BY SENATOR LEYVA
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THAT FIRST. REFERRED
COMMITTEE ON TRANSPORTATION
CURRENT VOTERS THREE ZERO WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I ADVISED HER
VOTING ON DAILY. DALLY NO
SKINNER. SKINNER AYE STERN.
STERN AYE WERE CASKEY. HI
CASKEY I HI THE BILL IS OUT
GOING OVER TO TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE LET'S NOW GO TO
SENATE WHAT WE JUST DID CENTER
NEWMAN FILLS GONNA CENTER
WIENER'S BILL ON THE CLIMATE
CORPORATE ACCOUNTABILITY ACT
THIS IS A- A DEMANDED THAT TO
PASS A MINUTE TO GO TO
JUDICIARY. CENTIMETERS BILL
COSBY KALRA. I REMEMBER SIX SB
TWO SIXTY BY SENATOR WIENER.
YOUR VOTING I'D VICE CHAIR
VOTING NO- SKINNER. SKINNER AYE%
STERN STERN AYE OR CASKEY BY
VOTING KASKY NOT VOTING. YEAH
THE FOURTEENTH WE'RE CLOSER ON
THAT- IT WON'T HEALTH YOU
ALWAYS KEEPING US ON OUR TOES
YOU PROCEED THAT- MEMBERS
DOLLARS BILL AND- AND AT THE
REQUEST THE AUTHORS IS PEOPLE
FOR THIS AGENDA OF AND HE'S
GONNA TAKE SOME FURTHER MOMENTS
FOR FUTURE MEETINGS. PETER
HEARING- THE NEXT ONE IS SB
THREE FORTY TWO THIS IS LEADING
ADULTS IS BILL ON AS C. A. Q.
M. D. BOARD MEMBERSHIP.
SECURITYHOLDER ALL. AND A
NUMBER EIGHT ESPYS AT THREE
FORTY TWO BY SENATOR GONNA
GONZALEZ THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE. IT IS TWO ZERO WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I ADVISED HER
NOT VOTING. BATES DALLY THE
DAILY NOT VOTING. SKINNER HI
SKINNER AYE STERN TINA STERN
AYE WHITE HOUSE SCHEME. BYE
CASKEY I. OR RIGHT NOW IT IS K.
THIS. FIVE ZERO. YEAH. ALL
RIGHT WELL WE'LL GO TO ITEM
NINE NOW THIS IS A CENTER TO
THE HOSPITAL. SB SEVEN TWENTY
SIX THANK AND VOTE ON ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT WAS FIVE TWO ZERO
FIVE ZERO INTO THE AYE STICK
AYE IT'S GOING OFF TO- TO GO
FROM GOVERNMENT FIVE. SO WHEN I
GO TO SOME TWENTY SIX THIS IS A
TRANSCRIPT SUBSISTED ONLY
STRATEGY- D. PASSES AMENDMENT-
BUT REFERRED TO TRANSPORTATION.
SB SEVEN TWENTY SIX CONSULTAS
COST. WE HAVE FEATURE VOTING
I'D THE VICE CHAIR NOT VOTING
DALLY. DALLI NO SKINNER HI
SKINNER AYE STERN. EARN HIGH.
THANK YOU WELL THAT'S OUT THEM
IN SPITE OF FOR THE SENATE DOES.
VOTE SO THERE WE ARE ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GONNA GO TO ITEM NUMBER
TEN THIS SB SEVEN SEVENTY SIX
THIS IS ALSO SENDING A DOSS
BILL SAFE DRINKING WATER WATER
QUALITY. CANCEL PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. EMITTER ITEM NUMBER TEN
SB SEVEN SEVEN SIX BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ EMOTIONS DO PAST THAT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE CREDIT
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY. WITH
THE CHAIR VOTERS FIVE ZERO
CHARMING I ADVISED HER VOTING
AYE DALLY. DALLY NO SKINNER.
SKINNER I. ALL RIGHT I WILL
CALDERON AT IT'S GOING TO GO
OVER TO JUDICIARY SENATE NEXT
AND FINALLY OUR OUR COLLEAGUE
CENTER STERN'S AMBITIOUS
CLIMATE BILL SB FIVE EIGHTY
TWO. THIRTY DOLLARS FAVORITE
BILL OF THE DAY- LET'S CALL THE
ROLL I AM THEM ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN SB FIVE EIGHTY TWO BY
SENATOR STERN THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED. REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON NATURAL RESOURCES
AND WATER. THE VOTE IS FORTY
TWO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I THE
VICE CHAIR VOTING NO. SKINNER
SKINNER I. I DON'T FIVE TWO
TWO. THE BILLS OUT- IT'S GOING
TO GO OVER TO NATURAL RESOURCES
AND WATER. AND I THINK WE'VE
GOT EVERYTHING- CENTER SKINNER
ARE YOU ARE YOU AT ON
EVERYTHING YES OKAY I THINK
WE'VE CLOSER ROLE AND WE'RE ALL
SET AND- I WANT TO THANK OUR
STAFF IS ALWAYS- FOR ITS HARD
WORK MEMBERS WE HAVE SEVERAL
MORE HEARINGS COMING AND SOME
OF THE- THIS BILL THIS DAY WAS
TRICKY THE FUTURE BUILT DAYS
WILL BE TRICKIER. FAST SO I
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S FOR
BERENSON AND PARTICIPATION IN
WITH THAT WILL LET DURING THIS
MEETING.